MEMBER MIGUEL SANTIAGO SO --
BRIEFLY -- MISTER SANTIAGO HAVE
OPENING REMARKS -- YES THANKS
MANAGER I'M EAGER TO GET TO THIS
SO I KEEP MY REMARKS -- VERY
GOOD -- BRIEF BUT NONE THE LESS
WE HAD A COMMITTEE HEARING ABOUT
THE ABOUT THE SAME ISSUE BUT A
YEAR AGO OR SO.
AND THIS WILL HELP US TO PREPARE --
I'M A TO GET AN UPDATE TO BE
PREPARED -- FOR THE NEXT MERGING
SHE SHOULD HAPPEN AND WE KNOW
THAT IT ALWAYS DOES NOT A
QUESTION OF THE QUESTION IS IF
IT HAPPENS TO QUESTION ONE IT
HAPPENS AND SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. FOR PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER GIVES UP TO THE THIRD
TO LEARN -- TO TAKE A LOOK AT
ISSUES AND WE CONSIDER THEM --
AS WILL TAKE A LOOK AT SOME
IMPROVEMENTS THAT CAN BE MADE SO
I APPRECIATE YOU -- REACHING OUT
AND PUT THIS TOGETHER THANK YOU.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU.
I'M JUST BE VERY CONCISE ABOUT
THAT'S THE GOAL OF THIS HEARING.
IS TO LOOK FOR HOW WE IMPROVE
THE SYSTEM OVERALL FOR EVERY
COMMUNITY THIS PAST WEEKEND I
HOSTED EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT.
TOWN HALL IN SIMI VALLEY MY OWN
COMMUNITY -- IS WELL SUPPORTED
BY VENTURA COUNTY FIRE WE HAD
ABOUT SEVENTY RESIDENTS COME OUT
THERE WAS NOT A SINGLE RESIDENT
WHO HAD YET OPTED IN TO V. C.
ALERTS.
UNFORTUNATELY SO WE KNEW THAT
THAT WAS ONE CHALLENGE MANY OF
THE RESIDENTS DID NOT KNOW OR
UNDERSTAND THAT IF THEY WERE
FOLLOWING SOCIAL MEDIA FOR THEIR
UPDATES THEY NEED TO BE
FOLLOWING.
THE OFFICIAL ACCOUNTS OF THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT OF THE
VENTURA COUNTY FIRE AND SO WE WE
SHARE THAT INFORMATION WE ALSO
SHARED -- INFORMATION ABOUT NICK
SOUL ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT YOU
CONTINUE TO HAVE AN A. M. RADIO
AM FM RADIO IN YOUR HOME WITH
BATTERIES OR WITH SOME KIND OF
SOLAR CAPACITY.
BUT WHAT WE KNOW WE NEED IN THIS
SYSTEM IS GOD PROTOCOLS THAT
WORK FOR THE FIRST RESPONDER
COMMUNITY AS WELL AS THE
OFFICIALS ON THE GROUND WHO THEY
ARE RESPONSIBLE TO WORKING WITH.
THAT WE NEED REDUNDANCY WE NEED
STRUCTURAL REDUNDANCY AND THAT
MEANS WORKING WITH ALL OF OUR
PRIVATE SECTOR PARTNERS -- AS
WELL AS A FIRST RESPONDER
COMMUNITY TO ENSURE THAT
REGARDLESS OF THE TYPE OF
EMERGENCY.
PROTOCOLS ARE IN PLACE THAT KEEP
PEOPLE SAFE SO WE WELCOME ALL OF
YOU BEING HERE AT THE TABLE WITH
US TO HAVE THIS IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION WHAT WE'RE GONNA BE
LOOKING FOR STATE LEGISLATORS IS
HOW WHERE AND HOW CAN WE FILL IN
THE GAPS HOW DO WE MAKE THIS
SYSTEM.
HOLE HOW DO WE MAKE IT FUNCTION
HOW DO WE MAKE IT IMMEDIATELY
RESPONSIVE I'M IN A WAY THAT
HELPS US SAVE LIVES SO IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME TODAY AND TO
GET EVERYONE HOME FOR DINNER
PLEASE I KNOW WE HAD ORIGINALLY
SAID YOU KNOW REMARKS OF ABOUT
EIGHT TO TEN MINUTES.
IF YOU COULD CONSIDER MAYBE
GOING FROM ABOUT ME TO MAYBE
FIVE TO EIGHT MINUTES -- PERCENT
OF TESTIMONY THINK THAT'LL HELP
US ALL MOVE ALONG TODAY SO WHY
DON'T WE GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED THEN WITH OUR FIRST
GROUP.
AND THAT IS PROVIDING THE STATE
PERSPECTIVES SO WE HAVE MARKET A
DUTY DIRECTOR OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
MICHAEL PICKER PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA P. UC AND CHIEF
THOMAS PORTER DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION.
A GENTLEMAN THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY
.
I COULD AFTERNOON -- MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANKS.
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO SHARE WITH YOU SOME INSIGHT
INTO THE ISSUE OF A LEARN
MORNING AND OUR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HOW IT
RELATES TO EMERGENCY SERVICES --
OXY MCCARTY SHE THE DIRECTOR OF
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES.
I I THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT THE
LAST.
COUPLE OF YEARS HAVE BEEN
UNPRECEDENTED IN CALIFORNIA --
YOU KNOW IN THE CONTEXT OF
WILDFIRES -- WE'VE SEEN OVER
THREE MILLION ACRES BURNED AND
THAT COSTED ABOUT SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND WILDFIRES HOUSTON
SEVENTEEN AND EIGHTEEN EIGHT OF
WHICH RESULT IN CATASTROPHIC --
DISASTERS AND IMPACT OF THE
COMMUNITY AND YOU KNOW I THINK
FROM TWO THOUSAND AND TWELVE
ACTUALLY TWELVE THIRTEEN WE'VE
ACTUALLY SEEN A VARIETY OF
DISASTERS IN THE STATE
EVERYTHING FROM.
FROM NOT JUST FIRED BUT
EARTHQUAKE FLOODS ATMOSPHERIC
RIVERS STATUS BUT WE COLLAPSE IN
IN -- CHICO AND ORVILLE -- WE
SAW -- THE REFUGIO OIL SPILL WE
SAW THAT KELLY SO GAS LEAK AND
WE HAD A TEARS ATTACK IN.
SAN BERNADINO WE'VE HAD.
ALL OF THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT
WE ALWAYS PREPARE FOR AND YOU
KNOW CLEARLY OUT BETWEEN
SEVENTEEN AND EIGHTEEN WE LOST
CLOSE. TO THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
STRUCTURES DESTROYED.
AND OVER A HUNDRED SIXTY
FATALITIES.
AND CLEARLY WELL OVER TWELVE
BILLION INSURED LOSSES.
I THINK THAT AFTER SEVENTEEN
REALLY THE FOCUS -- WAS ON ALERT
AND WARNING AND BEING ABLE TO UP
UPGRADE THAT.
SYSTEM AND AND AT THAT TIME --
YES MOVE TO REVISE AND ADVANCE A
MORE CONSISTENT STANDARDIZED
ALERT AND WARNING GUIDELINE.
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
WE RECOGNIZE THAT VIRTUALLY ALL
DISASTERS ARE.
A MERGER ON A LOCAL LEVEL AND
AND THAT'S WHERE OUR PUBLIC
ALERT AND WARNING EFFORTS NEEDED
TO FOCUS.
PROVIDING GUIDANCE TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ON BEST PRACTICES IN
PROTOCOLS IN TRAINING AS WELL AS
ACCESS THE UTILIZATION OF KEY
COMMUNICATION TOOLS SUCH AS THE
FEDERAL INTEGRATED PUBLIC ALERT
AND WARNING SYSTEM OR I PAUSE --
WE CONVENE A STANDARDIZED
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT ALERT
WARNING SPECIALIST COMMITTEE
WHICH WAS MADE UP OF LOCAL AND
STATE GOVERNMENT.
INDUSTRY REPRESENTATIVES FROM
ALL THE DIFFERENT PUBLIC SAFETY
AGENCIES TO CREATE UPDATED ALERT
WARNING GUIDELINES -- THIS WAS
ACTUALLY REQUIRED BY SENATE BILL --
EIGHT THREE THREE THEY CAME IN
IN -- TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND
THE GUIDELINES WERE DISTRIBUTED
IN MARCH OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
STANDARDIZED.
STANDARDIZING THE APPROACH AS
WELL AS THE USE OF SIMPLE
METHODS THAT MUST ENSURE
COMPREHENSIVE ALERT AND WARNING
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL COUNTIES ARE
NOW.
BEGINNING TO USE THOSE
GUIDELINES AND ENHANCE THEIR
STANDARDIZED ALERTING.
PROTOCOLS ACROSS THE ACROSS ALL
OF THEIR SYSTEMS ON CLEARLY PART
OF THAT IS THE OPTED OUT OPT OUT
SYSTEM MANY -- INDIVIDUALS
BELIEVE THAT THEY STILL NEED TO
OPT IN AND IT WAS ADDITIONAL
LEGISLATION BY SENATOR JACKSON
THAT WAS PUT IN PLACE.
BUT NOW SAYS THAT -- YOU HAVE TO
ACTUALLY OPT OUT COMMUNITIES
COUNTIES AT THE COUNTY LEVEL CAN
USE -- UP PUBLIC PAID OUT FROM
UTILITIES AND EXCEPT FOR A TO BE
ABLE -- TO GET INFORMATION AND
PUT.
INDIVIDUALS IN THE COMMUNITY
INTO AN ALERT MORGAN
NOTIFICATION SYSTEM. ONE OTHER
AREA THAT WE WORKED ON
ADDRESSING AND LEARNED WARNING
WAS THE ISSUE EVACUATION.
AND THE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
STANDARDIZED TERMINOLOGY.
WE HAVE FOUND THAT THE
CALIFORNIANS ARE UNCLEAR ON THE
APPROPRIATE PROTECTIVE ACTIONS
TO TAKE WHEN EVACUATION ORDERS
WERE ISSUED BECAUSE DIFFERENT
PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES WERE
USING.
DIFFERENT TERMINOLOGY -- WE
CONVENE AN EVACUATION
TERMINOLOGY WORKING GROUP --
COMPRISE AGAIN OF OF OF ALL THE
PUBLIC SAFETY AND ENTITIES
EMERGENCY SERVICES FROM EVERY
REGION IN CALIFORNIA -- AND THE
GROUP UNANIMOUSLY RECOMMENDED A
SERIES OF STANDARDIZED TERMS.
STANDARDIZED TERMS FOR THE USE
BY PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND THOSE
ORIENTED AROUND EVACUATION
ORDERS EVACUATION WARNINGS AND
SHELTER IN PLACE ORDERS AND
THOSE ARE NOW BEING CONVEYED AND
LAID OUT THROUGHOUT THE THE
STATE.
BOB WE CONTINUE TO ADVANCE THE
LORTON WAY TECHNOLOGIES NOW
THROUGH THE PREPARATION OF OUR
NEXT GENERATION.
NINE ONE ONE THE CORNERSTONE OF
THIS WILL BE THAT NEXT
GENERATION SYSTEM WILL BE IP
BASED.
LAW AND WILL BE CAPABLE OF
INTEGRATING DATA SOURCES AND
EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES AND WILL
INCLUDE A COMMON STATEWIDE LEARN
MORNING PLATFORM.
THAT WILL PROVIDE THE ABILITY
FOR EVERY LOCAL AGENCY TO
RECEIVE GENERATE AND VIEW ALERTS
AND WARNINGS.
THE NEXT GENERATION SYSTEM WILL
INCLUDE REDUNDANT CONNECTIONS TO
EVERY PUBLIC SAFETY ANSWERING
POINT OR P. SAP USING THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SAFETY
MICROWAVE NETWORK TO ENSURE FOR
CONNECTIVITY IN THE EVENT.
THAT A BACK HALL OR THE FIBER
LINE IS DESTROYED.
KELLY ALSO IS ALSO WORKING WITH
EACH OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
ANSWERING POINTS TO PROVIDE A
COMMON GEOGRAPHIC INFORMATION
SYSTEM. TO DELIVER CONSISTENT
MAPPING INFORMATION.
ANOTHER CAPABILITY INCLUDED IN
THE NEXT GEN INCLUDES THE
INTERFACE TO COMPUTER AIDED
DISPATCH.
SYSTEMS USING THE PEACE SAP TO
DISPATCH RESOURCES THAT ARE
CAPABLE OF INTEGRATING DATA FROM
NEIGHBORING AGENCIES AS WELL AS
AUTOMATIC VEHICLE LOCATION AND
OTHER TECHNOLOGIES.
SUCH TECHNOLOGY WILL HELP ENSURE
LOCAL AGENCIES HAVE THE
SITUATION AWARENESS THEY NEED TO
DISPATCH THE CLOSEST RESOURCE.
DURING EMERGENCIES.
IT'S CLEAR THAT AFFECTED
EMERGENCY MEASURE REQUIRES THE
INTEGRATION OF ALL THIS DATA IN
REAL TIME FROM ALL AVAILABLE
SOURCES TO ENSURE THE DECISION
MAKERS HAVE THE INFORMATION
NEEDED TO SAVE LIVES.
BOB ALONG THE ROUTE -- THERE'S
BEEN MUCH EFFORT MADE TO ENSURE
FOR CONSISTENT IMPLEMENTATION
AND USE OF THE ALERT WARNING
SYSTEM.
AND WORK BY STATE LOCAL PUBLIC
SAFETY EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT IS
AGENCIES TO PREPARE FOR NEW
NORMS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THE SYSTEMS THAT WE NOW
USED TO PUSH OUT A LURCH TO THE
PUBLIC AND TO OUR RESPONDENTS
VIA THEIR MOBILE PHONES TABLETS.
TELEVISIONS EXCEPT FOR A ARE
PREDOMINATELY OWN AND MANAGE BY
THE PRIVATE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SECTOR.
AND ARE FULLY DEPENDENT ON A
ROBUST AND RESILIENT SECULAR
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND A SUSTAINABLE POWER.
EMERGENCY ALERTS FACE CRITICAL
LIMITATIONS WHEN POWER IS LOST
OR IN THE CASE THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH NOW WITH OUR EVEN
IF -- INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES
PRETTY BOB BOB.
PRE OP PROACTIVELY SHUTTING
POWER OFF IN ADVANCE OF
POTENTIAL FIRE SITUATIONS.
OR WHEN A CELL SITE GOES DOWN.
INCLUDING THE THEIR BACK CALL
FOR THAT SELL SIDE BOB WHICH
INCLUDES THE FIBER LINES.
EITHER DUE TO LOSS OF POWER OR
FROM BEING DESTROYED BY FIRE
EARTHQUAKE OR OTHER DISASTERS SO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE CELL
SITE ITSELF AND THE BACK FULL --
FIBER CABLE -- THAT SUPPORTS
THAT ENTITY THE LOSS OF THE CELL
SITES PREVENTION ALERTS FROM
GOING OUT TO THE PUBLIC
EFFECTIVELY RECEIVING RECEIVING
THEM DURING NUMBER JUST YOUR
DISASTER.
THE COMMON DENOMINATOR IN ALERT
WARNINGS EMERGENCY NOTIFICATIONS
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS INITIATIVE
RESPONSE IS NOW A RELIABLE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SYSTEM.
IN THE MIDST OF THESE DISASTERS
RELIABLE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SERVICE IS THE LIFELINE FOR
EVERY PERSON OUR MOBILE PHONES
HAVE BECOME AN INDISPENSABLE
PIECE OF TECHNOLOGY.
TODAY WE KNOW THAT OVER 80% OF
ALL NINE ONE ONE CALLS ARE FROM
A CELLULAR DEVICE WE ALSO KNOW
THAT OVER 50% OF ALL HOMES IN
THE U. S. USE ONLY A CELLULAR
DEVICE FOR COMMUNICATIONS.
WE KNOW THAT CITED
COMMUNICATIONS CAN BE.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIFE AND
DEATH.
THE REALITY IS THAT SENATOR
DEVICES ARE NOW THESE CRITICAL
LIFELINES YET.
THERE ARE LIMITATIONS OVER THE
LAST SIX YEARS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA TIME AND TIME AGAIN
NATURAL AND HUMAN CAUSED
DISASTERS HAVE PUSHED THE SYSTEM.
BEYOND WHAT.
IT WAS DESIGNED TO SUPPORT.
WE NOW WE KNOW THAT -- WHEN
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO THE SITE
OR NETWORK THEY CAN CALL NAY ONE
THEY CAN RECEIVE ALERT MORNINGS
THEY CAN ACCESS INFORMATION
RELATED TO ONGOING DISASTERS?
AND WE HAVE SEEN SUCCESS STORIES
DEMONSTRATING THAT WHEN THE
SYSTEM IS AVAILABLE IT CAN BE A
POWERFUL LIFESAVING TOOL.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT.
WE'VE ALSO DEMONSTRATED ACCOUNTS
THAT POINT TO INCONSISTENCIES IN
THE SECULAR.
SYSTEM.
MANY TIMES DURING THE DISASTROUS
OTHER SYSTEM SIMPLY DOES NOT
SUPPORT THE NEEDS -- OF THE
PUBLIC OR PUBLIC SAFETY.
I WANT TO STRESS THAT I'M NOT
HERE TO SLAM TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SERVICE PROVIDER THEY ARE
PARTNERS BUT THE IDENTIFIED GAPS
THAT EXIST WITHIN OUR CURRENT
SYSTEM.
I'VE TESTIFIED NUMEROUS TIMES
AND PROVIDED THE STATISTICS OF
NUMBERS OF CELL SITES THAT WENT
OFFLINE DURING RECENT DISASTERS.
WE HAVE DOCUMENTED OUTAGES THAT
HAVE AFFECTED ENTIRE COUNTIES
SUCH AS A COMMUNICATION OUTAGE
MONA COUNTY.
THAT OCCURRED ON MARCH TWENTY
THIRD OF THIS YEAR WHEN THE
ENTIRE COUNTY WAS WITHOUT ANY
COMMUNICATIONS LANDLINE CELLULAR
OR NINE ONE ONE FOR OVER TWENTY
EIGHT HOURS DUE TO A FIBRE OPTIC.
BREAK AND THE LACK OF REDUNDANCY.
THE FCC HAS PUBLISHED A TWO
STICKS ON SECULAR OUTAGES DURING
HURRICANES.
THE STATISTICS SHOW THAT THE
SUSTAINABILITY OVERSIGHT OF
SYSTEM IS INCONSISTENT.
AND DOES NOT MEET THE NEED.
WHEN I REPORT THAT THREE HUNDRED
FORTY ONE CELL SITES WHAT WENT
OFFLINE DURING THE?
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN OCTOBER WILDFIRES AND
FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE
CELL SITES WENT OFF LINE DURING
THE CAMPFIRE AND WILL SEE FIRES.
THIS MEANS THAT YOU WERE IN IF
THAT IF YOU WERE IN THESE IMPACT
AREAS YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO CALL
911- YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
RECEIVE AN ALERT.
AND IN MANY CASES YOU COULD NOT
USE YOUR CELL DEVICE TO ASSIST
YOU WITH THE TERM IN THE SAFEST
EVACUATION ROUTE.
WHEN WE REVIEW THE FCC OUTAGE
DATA FROM HURRICANE FLORENCE IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THREE DAYS
AFTER THE HURRICANE MADE
LANDFALL?
THEY WERE COUNTIES WHERE OVER
50% OF THE CELL SITES WERE OFF
LINE.
DURING HURRICANE MICHAEL.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THERE
WERE COUNTIES WHERE OVER 75% OF
THE CELL SITES WERE OFFLINE DAYS
AFTER THE HURRICANE MADE
LANDFALL.
PC SIX SIX STATISTICS CALL INTO
QUESTION THE WRITTEN RELIABILITY
OF OUR NATION'S PRIVATELY ONLY
MANAGE COMMUNICATION SYSTEM --
AN ERROR WE BELIEVE IT HOLDS
TRUE HERE IN CALIFORNIA AS WELL.
WHERE WE CAN POINT TO SUCCESS
STORIES THAT THE CYSTIC
STATISTICS SHOW?
THAT THERE'S STILL WORK TO BE
DONE OUT AND TO BE FAIR THERE'S
BEEN SOME HARDENING.
IN UPGRADES.
OF THE SYSTEM IN IN CERTAIN
PLACES IN THE STATE AND THIS
OTHER PROVIDERS HAVE WORKED HARD
TO ENHANCE THEIR PORTABLE
GENERATOR SOLUTIONS AND
DEPLORABLE SOLUTIONS LIKE CELLS
ON LIGHT TRUCKS ARE COLDS.
SELLS ON WHEELS WERE EVEN MORE
RECENTLY CELLS ON WINGS OR
FLYING CALLUSES THERE FOR
ACTUALLY CALLED.
WHILE THESE ARE PORTABLE AND
DEPLORABLE SOLUTIONS PROVIDE THE
CAPABILITY AND THE TRAP AND
TEMPORARY SOLUTION FOR WHEN CELL
SITES GO DOWN DURING A DISASTER.
THEY ARE SIMPLY NO SUBSTITUTE
FOR SOUTHERN NETWORK THAT IS
DESIGNED TO BE MORE RESILIENT
FROM THE DISASTER IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
THERE IS SIMPLY NO WAY THAT A
PORTABLE SOLUTION COULD SUPPORT
THE NEED WHEN OVER 50% OF SET
ASIDES IN A COUNTY GO DOWN I
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO
COLLECTIVELY FOCUS.
ON SITE IMPACTFUL HALL HARDENING
AND REDUNDANCY INDEED THE ENTIRE
COMMUNICATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND WHAT DOES THIS MEAN THIS
MEANS THAT -- AT THE PATH
FORWARD.
PLEASE INCLUDE ADEQUATE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AT SAILOR SITES.
HARDENING OF EACH SO YOUR SITE.
TO AN ACCEPTABLE LEVEL TO
WITHSTAND EARTHQUAKES STORM AND
OTHER DISASTER.
INCREASE BATTERY BACKUP
CAPABILITY.
ESTABLISH A GENERATOR BACKUP IN
EVERY SITE THAT CAN SUPPORT.
AN INSURER FOR REDUNDANT BACK
CALL CONNECTIONS THAT ELIMINATE
THE SINGLE POINT OF FAILURE THAT
EXIST IN THE CELLULAR NETWORK
TODAY.
AS WE FACE THE NEW NORMAN
CALIFORNIA ONCE AGAIN.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
BY PARTNERING WITH OUR
TELECOMMUNICATION PARTNERS. TO
MAKE THE NECESSARY CHANGES TO
ENSURE FOR PUBLIC SAFETY GREAT
CONSISTENCY IN
TELECOMMUNICATIONS -- AND
ULTIMATELY THIS WILL SAVE LIVES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
AFTERNOON MICHAEL PICKER I WORK
AT THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION.
I'M GONNA ADD A LITTLE BIT MORE
ON THE CLICK ON THESE ISSUES IS
THE UNDERLYING RELIABILITY AND
RESILIENCY OF THE CORE SYSTEM
THAT PROVIDES TO THE THIS IS
SUPPORT FOR EMERGENCY
COMMUNICATIONS -- I'M GONNA TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT MY WHAT I'VE
LEARNED ABOUT THIS IS THIS
INDUSTRY WHEN I FIRST CAME TO
THE P. YOU SEE I I REALIZED THAT
WE HAD VERY LITTLE REGULATORY
AUTHORITY OVER THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY.
THAT WHERE THERE WAS IT WAS A
PATCHWORK FOR DIFFERENT KINDS OF
TECHNOLOGY OR IFFERENT KINDS OF
SERVICES OVER TIME.
SO I I WELL I WENT TO TO A
MEETING OF THE CALIFORNIA --
TELECOMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION I ASKED HIM WHY ARE
YOU GUYS EVEN AT THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION YOUR
COMPETITIVE WHY IF THERE'S A
MARKET FOR SERVICES AND THERE'S
OPPORTUNITY FOR CHOICE WHY WOULD
BE YOU CONTINUE TO BE REGULATED
BY THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION WHAT YOU
GET OUT OF IT.
CAN I GOT TWO ANSWERS THERE WERE
SOMEWHAT INSTRUCTIVE SO THE
FIRST IS THAT BECAUSE THEY HVE
A LICENSE TO OPERATE AS A
UTILITY EVEN WITHOUT MUCH
AUTHORITY AND REGULATION BEHIND
IT.
THERE THEN ENTITLED TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE PUBLIC RIGHT AWAY
OF THE NETWORK OF WOODEN POLES
THAT ARE ACTED BY THE ELECTRIC
INDUSTRY. TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
A WAY TO REACH CUSTOMERS ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT'S
AN FCC ROLE.
THE SECOND REASON THAT PEOPLE
ARE FOR ME WAS THAT BECAUSE THEY
WERE UNDER THE THE UMBRELLA OF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
THERE'S ONE MARKET STATE WIDE
THAT AND ONE SET OF MARK A RULES
AND THEY DON'T HAVE TO DEAL WITH
A LOT OF LOCAL REGULATION WHICH
ALLOWS FOR FREEDOM OF INVESTMENT
ACROSS THE STATE.
AND TO SOME EXTENT ALL THESE
THINGS WERE DESIGNED TO HELP
BRING FORWARD BROADBAND
TECHNOLOGY INTO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTS NOT JUST THE
OLD COPPER WIRE TELEPHONE
SERVICE.
BUT PROVIDES ALL KINDS OF
DIFFERENT DATA SERVICE SYSTEMS
THAT ARE ENABLED BY FIBER ON THE
TECHNOLOGY AND BROADBAND
TECHNOLOGIES.
AND SO THAT'S BEEN SUCCESSFUL TO
SOME EXTENT AND I DON'T QUITE A
QUESTION AT ALL.
THE THE CHALLENGE THAT I'VE SEEN
EMERGING HOWEVER IS THAT -- AS
YOU START TO SEE THIS MOVEMENT
AWAY FROM A REGULATED ENTITY
PEOPLE ARE COMPETING FOR
CUSTOMERS AND THEY'RE COMPETING
FOR THE BEST CUSTOMERS THEY WANT
DENSITY OF CUSTOMER SO THAT YOUR
INVESTMENT REACHES THE MOST
PEOPLE.
WHO WILL THEN BY SERVICES AND TO
BE ABLE TO PAY BACK THAT COST OF
THAT -- THOSE PEOPLE WHO TEND TO
LIVE IN SPARSER AREAS OR P.
PORTIONS OF COMMUNITIES WHERE
THEY DON'T BUY THOSE HIGH AND
SERVICES LOTS OF BAND WITH.
TEND NOT TO GET THE SAME KIND OF
SERVICES IN HIS AND GIVE SOME
EXPLANATION ON THAT.
THE FIRST THING I WILL SAY IS
THAT THE THE AMOUNT OF
COMPETITION ACROSS THE STATE IS
NOT EQUAL.
FROM PLACE TO PLACE -- OVER A
THIRD OF THE STATE THIRTY FIVE
PER SENT TO THE STATE ONLY HAS
ONE PROVIDER OR NO PROVIDER FOR
THOSE PEOPLE WHO HAVE NO
BROADBAND PROVIDERS.
WE GIVE AWAY GRANTS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND TO BE ABLE TO HELP ALLOW
THOSE COMMUNITIES TO FIND
SOMEBODY WHO WILL PROVIDE THE
BROADBAND AND THEN THEY CAN GET
DIFFERENT SERVICES OVER THAT BAR.
THAT BACKBONE PROVIDER.
THAT WAS PART OF OUR OUR
COMPETITION ANALYSIS TOOL WE DO
WE LOOK TO SEE WHETHER THERE IS
ACTUALLY COMPETITION AND THEN WE
LOOK TO SEE HOW THE SERVICE
QUALITY IS BEING PROVIDED.
SO WE DID A NETWORK EXAM THAT
THE RESULTS ARE FINALLY UP BUT I
CAN POINT TO SOME OF THE THE THE
INFORMATION THAT WE LEARNED
ABOUT THAT PERIOD FROM
200-010-22000.
SEVENTEEN SO ONLY ABOUT 7% OF
CALIFORNIANS REALLY USE THE OLD
A PLAIN OLD OF PHONE SERVICE --
ITS DECLINE PRETTY STEADILY --
BUT BOTH [inaudible]
VERIZON.
FRONTIER IN EIGHTEEN T. HAVE HAD
A HIGHER RATE OF REPORTED
CUSTOMER OUTAGES AND LONGER TIME
PERIODS. TO RESTORE SERVICES TO
THOSE THOSE LIVE REMAINING
LANDLINE CUSTOMERS.
THESE TWO CARRIERS DID NOT
MAINTAIN THE NETWORK
INFRASTRUCTURE TO WITHSTAND.
JUST SIMPLE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONDITIONS -- CUSTOMER ADAGES
INCREASE.
WHEN IT'S RAINING AND SNOWING?
MOST CENTRAL OFFICES DON'T HAVE
REDUNDANCY OR BACKUP POWER
DURING EQUIPMENT FAILURES.
EIGHTEEN T. AND VERIZON FRONTIER
IN CALIFORNIA AGAIN OF FOCUSED
ON THOSE REALLY DENSELY
POPULATED URBAN SUBURBAN AREAS
WITH CUSTOMERS DO HAVE.
DIFFERENT CHOICES WHEN THEY
DON'T GET THE QUALITY OF SERVICE.
SO MANY THE THESE RURAL AREAS
AND SOME SUBURBAN AREAS ARE IN
THAT WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE
THAT IS SEEN FIRES BUT IT'S ALSO
TRUE IN AREAS WHERE THAT ARE
PRONE TO FLOODING AND OTHER
KINDS OF CONTACT CATASTROPHIC
ISSUES.
I GOT TO SAY THAT IT DOESN'T
WORK FOR PUBLIC SAFETY EVEN ON A
DAY TO DAY BASIS.
SO -- SPEAKING TO THE LOSS OF A
FIBER CABLE IN LAS
COMMUNICATIONS NINE ONE ONE A
PUBLIC SAFETY PROVIDERS IN LARGE
PARTS OF MENDOCINO HUMBLE
CINNAMON LAKE COUNTIES ARE
CENTER MIKE WEIR SAID.
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY OR RISK
WHEN A SIMPLE FIBER CUT CAN LEAD
TO RURAL RESIDENTS NOT BEING
ABLE TO ACTION AN AMBULANCE THE
FIRE DEPARTMENT OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS A STANDS NOW HE
SAYS.
TELECOM COMPANIES DON'T LET
EMERGENCIES OFFICIALS KNOW WHEN
THE LOCAL NINE ONE ONE SYSTEMS
NOT OPERATING WHICH PUTS THEM.
AND THEIR THEIR THEIR
CONSTITUENTS IN DANGER.
SO AGAIN SOME.
RURAL AREAS DON'T HAVE THAT CELL
SERVICE THEY CAN COMPETE WITH A
PLAIN OLD TELEPHONE SERVICE THAT
I'VE ALREADY DESCRIBED AS BEING --
IN DECLINE -- I WON'T GO INTO
THE SPECIFICS IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME.
BUT WE DID DO A WORKSHOP THAT
REALLY REITERATED A LOT OF THE
THE THE DATE OF THAT -- THAT --
THIS -- DIRECTOR -- KILLER DUTY
HAS POINTED OUT THAT'S THE FIRST
TIME I'D HEARD ABOUT THE MASSIVE
LOSS OF THE SELF SITES.
SO I STARTED LOOKING AROUND TO
SEE WHAT THE EXPERIENCE OF SOME
OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES
WAR AND IT DURING EMERGENCY
EVENTS OR LEADING UP TO AND I
THE THE CINEMA COUNTY.
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY.
MANAGEMENT TO THIS AFTER STUDY
CALLED THE CINEMA COUNTY
OPERATIONAL AREA LURKING MORNING
FUNCTIONAL EXERCISE AFTER ACTION
REPORT.
WHICH IS HOW THEY TALK -- IT IN
PART OF THE EFFORT TO COUNTY
STAFF ATTEMPTED TO CONTACT
PEOPLE ASSOCIATED WITH THE
NEARLY THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE THE DAY AGING KEEP SEEKS
ON EMERGENCY WARNING LIST.
THAT IS PURCHASED AND THEN IT'S
UP TO TWICE YEAR FROM EIGHTEEN
T. IN FRONTIER COMMUNICATIONS
BUT THEY CAN ONLY REACH 51% OF
THOSE PEOPLE SUCCESSFULLY TO
EITHER TALK TO SOMEBODY OR TO
LEAVE A MESSAGE.
IN IN A SUBSEQUENT PHASE OF
THEIR TEST THE COUNTY OFFICIALS
TARGETED FIVE GEOGRAPHIC AREAS
FOR TEST OF THEIR EMERGENCY
NOTIFICATIONS TO WIRELESS
CUSTOMERS.
AND THEY FOUND INCONSISTENT
POLICIES AND PRACTICES IN HOW
PROVIDERS ALERT CUSTOMERS.
THAT MAKES THE TASK VERY HARD IF
SOMEBODY FOLLOWS BASICALLY A
LINE DRAWING OF A GEOGRAPHIC
AREA.
AND PULLS OUT PARTICULAR
CUSTOMERS WHO MAY HAVE A BILLING
ADDRESS FOR ANOTHER PROVIDER
ACTUALLY HAS A POLY GONE AROUND
A CELL TOWER THAT THE USED TO
CON A MAP OUT HOW YOU NOTIFY.
THAT DOESN'T MAKE IT EASY THEN
FOR THE AGENCIES TO COME UP WITH
A SIMPLE WAY TO FIGURE OUT WHO
TO NOTIFY IN A SPECIFIC
GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION. FOR
EVACUATION AND I THINK DIRECTOR
BILL OR DO YOU JUST TALKED A LOT
ABOUT THE NEED FOR BACKUP POWER
FOR THE SELL SIDE SO I WON'T GO
INTO THAT -- THE FOR US IT'S AS
GOOD AS CITY GREAT CHALLENGE TO
SEE HOW THE SYSTEM IS NOT GOING
TO OPERATE THE WAY THAT WE
EXPECTED.
AND THE WAY THE CONSUMERS RELY
ON IT BUT KNOWING AHEAD OF TIME
THAT THERE'S ALL THIS WEAKNESS
IS BOTH IN TERMS OF THE
MAINTENANCE OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE DESIGN OF
THE WAY THAT THE UTILITIES.
AND WORK TOGETHER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHIEF.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S TOM PORTER I'M DIRECTOR
OF CAL FIRE -- AND I WANT -- TO
THEY COVER FOR YOU KIND OF THE
EMERGENCY SERVICES FROM THE
RESPONSE SIDE -- OF THIS THIS
ISSUE -- WELL CAL FIRE A IS NOT
ONE THAT SEND AN AGENCY OR
DEPARTMENT THE SENDS OUT ALERTS
AND WARNINGS -- WE DO PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE AS AS DO OTHERS
AND I'LL MENTION SOME OF THOSE.
IN THE ASSISTANCE IN IN
DEVELOPING THE INFORMATION THAT
THAT TURNS INTO AN ALERT OR
WARNING -- FOR INSTANCE -- WE
ARE UTILIZING -- WEATHER
INFORMATION MAPS FUELS DATA
SEASONALITY -- AND DIFFERENT --
PRODUCTS THAT WE HAVE THROUGH
OUR PREDICTIVE SERVICES -- TO
REALLY PUT SOME FIDELITY TO WHAT --
WEATHER EVENT IS GOING TO DO AND
HOW THAT LOOKS RELATED TO FIRE
STARTS FOR INSTANCE.
SO -- FOCUSING IN ON THE BEFORE
DURING AND AFTER IS WHAT I'D
LIKE TO DO -- AND I WILL KEEP MY
MY COMMENTS -- CONCISE -- BEFORE
A FIRE AT A WE REALLY ARE
LOOKING AT THOSE THOSE WHETHER --
A BALANCE -- THAT MAY BE RELATED
TO LARGE FIRE AT LARGE AND
DAMAGING FIRE GROWTH -- SO WE
WORK WITH -- IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE NATIONAL WEATHER SERVICE
WHICH IS THE SERVICE THAT WOULD
PUT OUT -- AND A EITHER WARNING
OR NOW WATCH FOR A WEATHER EVENT --
AND WE WORK WITH THEM RELATED TO
THE FUELS CONDITIONS AS I
MENTIONED -- AND NOT JUST THOSE
THOSE WINDOW VENTS THAT HAPPEN
FOR INSTANCE IN THE WINTER TIME
WHEN THE HUMIDITY IS WAY UP WE
MAY HAVE.
A HIGH WINDS BUT NOT A FIRE
WEATHER WATCH OR WARNING BECAUSE
OF THE HUMIDITY -- WE WERE WE
HAVE -- IT NINETY TO REMOTELY --
OPERATE OUR REMOTE AUTOMATED
WEATHER STATIONS ROZ'S THAT WE
HAVE THROUGHOUT THE STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREA IN
CALIFORNIA WE WILL AND THOSE OR
SATELLITE -- PAINTING -- OF
WEATHER DATA SOURCES THAT THAT
ALL.
OF THE DIFFERENT -- A AGENCIES
CAN USE -- AND THEN AS MENTIONED
WE USE SATELLITE IMAGERY -- AND
MANY OTHER -- MODELS TO
DETERMINE WHAT WHAT KIND OF FOR
AFFECTS FIRE MIGHT HAVE ON THE
LANDSCAPE.
WE DO THIS THROUGH OUR
PREDICTIVE SERVICES PROGRAM I
BELIEVE I HAVE.
SUPPLIED YOU WITH A HAND OUT OF
THAT SO I WILL TALK SPECIFICALLY
IN DEPTH ABOUT WHAT THAT PROGRAM
DOES PLEASE DO -- ROOT REFERENCE
THAT THAT DOCUMENT -- BUT THEY
THERE ARE TWO OF THEM THERE WERE --
ONES IN RIVERSIDE ONES IN --
READING.
AND THEY COVER THE ENTIRE STATE
SPLIT IN ROUGHLY ROUGHLY IN HALF.
AND THOSE YOU'LL HEAR OFTEN US
TALK ABOUT THE GAC OR GEOGRAPHIC.
AREA COORDINATION CENTERS --
WORK THE NORTH OP SOUTH OPS
THOSE ARE INTERCHANGEABLE AND
THOSE ARE WHERE OUR PREDICTIVE
SERVICES FOLKS WORK -- THE
IDENTIFY SIGNIFICANT FIRE
POTENTIAL AND THEY THEY PUT OUT
OF PRODUCTS ON A REGULAR BASIS
THAT OUR WEB BASED.
AND AVAILABLE TO ANYBODY IN THE
PUBLIC AND FOR DECISION MAKERS
TO ACCESS AND THOSE ARE.
THINGS LIKE A TWO DAY OUTLOOK
WHICH GIVES YOU TODAY AND
TOMORROW WHAT THAT WHAT THE
PREDICTED WEATHER IS AND WHAT
THE LIKELIHOOD FOR LARGE AND
DAMAGING FIRE GROWTH WOULD BE.
AN INITIAL ATTACK ACTIVITY THE
SEVEN DAY -- PRODUCT WHICH
REALLY LOOKS AT ALL ALL OF THE
NEXT SEVEN DAYS AND WHERE WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE -- POTENTIAL. FOR
LARGE AND DAMAGING FIRE --
BEHAVIOR THE SANTANA WILDFIRE
THREAT INDEX WHICHWE'VE HEARD A
LOT ABOUT IN RECENT YEARS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REALLY PUTS
FIDELITY TO WEAR WINDS ARE GOING
TO BE THE WORST AND AT WHAT THE
LIKELIHOOD OF OF LARGE AND
DAMAGING FIRES IS FROM FROM A
SANTA ANA THAT.
AND THEN THE MONTHLY AND
SEASONAL OUTLOOKS WE'VE WE'VE WE
GET FROM THEM KIND OF WHAT
THINGS ARE GONNA LOOK LIKE
THROUGHOUT THE THE YEAR.
ALL THE MONTH IN THE YEAR ALL OF
THESE PRODUCTS ARE UTILIZED IN
THE DEVELOPMENT OF OF THE ALERTS
AND WARNINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT RELATED TO WEATHER
EVENTS.
SO -- WHAT CAL FIRE ALSO DOES IS
ONCE ONCE THESE?
ALERTS ARE ARE -- PUT OUT WE
UTILIZE OUR ARE YOU EDUCATION
PLATFORM AND OUR MEDIA IS SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS TO REALLY
AMPLIFY WHATEVER IS COMING OUT
SO WHATEVER TYPE OF OF ALERT
MORNING -- MUCH LIKE A LOCAL
FIRE AND YES DOES AS WELL WE ARE
AMPLIFYING THOSE FIRE WEATHER
WATCHES RED FLAG WARNINGS --
ALSO OTHER TYPES OF OF WATCHES
AND WARNINGS AND ALERTS THAT
HAPPENED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
WELL -- WELL A FIRE IS GOING
LET'S JUST LET'S JUST LEAVE IT
WITH FIRE -- ITS CLOSEST TO MY
HEART -- WE WILL CONTINUE TO
MONITOR WHAT'S HAPPENING -- WITH
THAT WITH THE FIRE WEATHER THAT
THAT IS -- IS JUST AFFECTING THE
THE SPREAD OF OF WILDFIRE --
ACROSS THE LANDSCAPE AND THEN
FURTHER MAKE PREDICTIONS ON ONE
WILL AREAS THAT WE WILL LIKELY
NEED TO DO EVACUATIONS AND THEN
WE WERE WE WILL ENTER INTO --
UNIFIED COMMAND WITH THE LOCAL.
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY WHOEVER
THAT IS THEY WILL PUT OUT THE
THE ALERTS AND WARNINGS AND HAND
THE EVACUATION ORDERS -- IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE INFORMATION
THAT WE PROVIDE WITH THEM AND
THEN WE REVERSE ENGINEER THAT
FOR RE POPULATION -- ONCE ONCE --
THOSE EVENTS ARE DONE -- MOVING
INTO THE AFTER -- AFTER WILD
FIRE AFTER EVENT OF WE OFTEN
WILL WORK THROUGH OUR OUR A
WILDFIRE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
TEAMS AND ON THE FEDERAL SIDE
THE BEAR TEAMS BURNED AREA
EMERGENCY RESPONSE. TO PUT
SENSORS OUT INTO CREEKS ON
MOUNTAIN SIDES -- TO WATCH --
FLOWS PEAK FLOWS THAT ARE COMING
INTO CREEKS AND DIFFERENT THINGS
WHICH WILL THEN ALSO THROUGH
SATELLITE TELEMETRY OR RADIO
TELEMETRY -- ALERT OF THINGS
LIKE -- FLOODS AND THAT HAPPENED --
ABOVE.
AMONG THE CEO -- AND WAS ONE OF
THE ITEMS THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
ENSURE WENT INTO PLACE -- TO
PROTECT -- RESIDENTS FROM THE
THE FLOODS THAT HAPPEN AND
UNFORTUNATELY THAT DIDN'T.
PROTECT EVERY RESIDENTS BUT WE
DID.
HAVE THOSE THOSE IN PLACE AND
WERE ABLE.
TO IDENTIFY THAT THERE IT TRULY
WAS A THREAT AND IT WAS --
COMING THAT EVENING.
AND THEN FINALLY -- WE UTILIZE
ALL OF OUR SITUATIONAL AWARENESS --
TOOLS THROUGH OUR OUR READY FOR
WILDFIRE APP -- AND ALL OF THAT
INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE TO ANY
PUBLIC MEMBERS THROUGH THAT APP
OR THROUGH OUR WEBSITE.
THANK YOU AND I'M OPEN FOR
QUESTIONS SIMON THANK YOU WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS.
I THANK AHEAD.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK FOR A QUOTE
THE A COUPLE QUESTIONS CAN IN
THIS BUT SPECIFICALLY MAYBE --
MAYBE YOU CAN ANSWER WHAT
SPECIFICALLY ARE THE OBSTACLES
IF YOU HAD THE LAN RIGHT AMOUNT
AND NUTS AND BOLTS.
NOT AT A HIGH LEVEL.
A TO COMMUNICATING INTERNET
EMERGENCY.
I THINK ULTIMATELY.
ITS ITS RELIABILITY -- OF THE
EXISTING SYSTEM.
YOU KNOW -- OF WHEN A WHEN A
SHELL SAY GOES DOWN -- WHEN A
FIBRE LINE GETS BURNED OR BROKEN --
BUT WE WE LOOK WE LOSE THAT THAT
SITE WE OR WE LOSE MULTIPLE
SITES.
AND AND THE REALITY IS IS THAT --
SAYS EVERYBODY'S DEPENDING UPON
THIS SYSTEM.
WE'VE PUT ALL OUR EGGS IN THAT
BASKET -- WE IN THE GOVERNMENT
HAVE VERY LITTLE.
CONTROL OVER BUT WE'RE DEPENDING
UPON IT.
MORE MORE. FOR ALL KINDS OF
VACATIONS THAT WE STILL HAVE OUR
LAND MOBILE RADIOS.
BUT THOSE -- COMMUNICATE TO THE
PUBLIC WHAT COMMUNICATES TO THE
PUBLIC.
IS THE SIDE OR NETWORK.
AND SO WHAT WHAT WE NEED IS
RELIABILITY.
AND THAT MEANS WE NEED TO HAVE.
THE FIBRIL LINES IN THE CABLE.
RAP AND MADE RESILIENT SO IT CAN
WITHSTAND -- DIFFERENT KINDS OF
IMPACTS WE NEED A CELL SITE
THAT'S GOT DEFENSIBLE SPACE
AROUND IT.
AND IT'S HARD AND TO THE TO THE
DEGREE THAT IT'S PROTECTED.
FROM CERTAIN KINDS OF DISASTERS
WE DO HAVE BATTERY BACKUP OR
GENERATOR BACKUP SO THAT WHEN
THE POWER GOES OFF.
IN A DISK IN A DISASTER OR IT'S
PREEMPTIVELY SHUT OFF BY THE
UTILITY.
THAT THAT THE THOSE
COMMUNICATION SITES REMAIN IN
PLACE THAT WOULD GO A LONG WAY --
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE -- THE
COMMUNICATIONS THAT WE WE WE
NEED TO HAVE BECAUSE BECAUSE
EVEN AS WE MOVE TO WHAT'S CALLED
FIRST AT WHICH IS A BROADBAND IN.
A PUBLIC SAFETY INTEROPERABLE.
THE DATA SYSTEM.
THAT'S USING THE SAME AND THAT
IN THE ADDRESS IS THE SAME EXACT
SYSTEM.
AS PUBLIC SAFETY MOVED TO THAT
MOVING DATA AND OTHER CRITICAL
INFORMATION -- IF THOSE SITES
ARE DOWN -- WE WE CAN'T
COMMUNICATE.
SO WE TALK A LOT ABOUT
REDUNDANCY AND I ASKED AS IN OUR
PRIOR HEARING.
ARE WE AT THE POINT WHERE WE
NEED TO BE EQUIPPING EVERY
MUNICIPALITY WITH SOME MEANS
RUDIMENTARY AS IT MAY BE A SIREN
SYSTEM AND OUT EN EL READ
SPEAKER SYSTEM.
SO THAT WE HAVE A FAIL SAFE
MECHANISM FOR COMMUNICATING
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY I
AM I AM LESS CONCERNED WITH HOW
WE WAIT YEARS UPON YEARS. TO
REFORM AND INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
PROBABLY ALREADY NEED SOME
REFORMING WE KNOW THESE FIRES
ARE IMMINENT.
WHAT DO WE DO TO SAVE LIVES?
NOW.
SO I'M JUST GOING TO POINT OUT
THAT NOT EVERY COMMUNITY IS THE
SAME IN VERY DANCE PORTIONS OF
THE STATE FOR EXAMPLE THE
ELECTRIC GRID AND POOR AND MUCH
OF THE TELECOMMUNICATION GRID.
KIND OF LOOKS MORE LIKE AN A
MASH WITH MANY DIFFERENT LINES
THEY CROSS AND WHERE THE WHERE
YOU CAN IF YOU CAN'T IF YOU
CAN'T ACTUALLY.
HAVE SERVICE MOVE FROM ONE PLOY
LINE TO ANOTHER IF THERE IS A
FAILURE AND SOME PORTION OF THE
LINE -- EQ YOU CAN YOU CAN GET
IT UP FAIRLY QUICKLY AND BUT
WHEN YOU GET INTO THE EDGES AND
OUT INTO THOSE REMOTE OR
COMMUNITIES.
THAT ARE DEPENDENT ON ONE LINE
THAT STRINGS OUT OVER MANY MANY
MANY MILES YOU DON'T HAVE THAT
KIND OF OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE
TO USE A MASH. TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SERVICE SO ALL KINDS OF
DIFFERENT KINDS OF SOLUTIONS ARE
GONNA PROBABLY APPLIED IN
DIFFERENT WAYS IN DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES.
BUT IT TO THE EXTENT THAT WERE
NOT MAINTAINING THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE IS YOU SAID IN
TERMS REFORM.
EVERYTHING IS JOURNAL YOUR RISK
EVERYWHERE UNTIL WE ACTUALLY
HAVE SOME REAL CLEAR STANDARDS
IN CAN CAN HOLD THE PROVIDERS TO
THOSE STANDARDS.
WHAT CAN I JUST SAY ON THE SIREN
ISSUE IT LOOKS YOU KNOW SIRENS
AND OTHER FORMS OF?
OF AUDIBLE ALERTING.
DO WORK IN PARTS OF OUR STATE WE
WE HAVE SIRENS SYSTEMS.
ARE A LOT IN OUR COASTAL
COMMUNITIES MOSTLY BECAUSE OF A
TSUNAMI -- RELATED THREAT -- AND
AND THERE ARE COMMITTEES AT THE
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM ONE
TODAY THAT THEY DID STATES.
IF THOUGHTS FOR WERE USING -- A
SIREN SORT OF AND THEY SHOULD
HAVE TO TO LEARN -- RESIDENTS.
SIRENS CAN BE EFFECTIVE -- THERE
ARE AGAIN COMPLEXITIES WITH
SIRENS THAT THERE THERE THERE
ARE WITH THAT THE EXISTING CELL
SITES WHAT THEY THEY NEED TO BE
MAINTAINED IT HAS TO BE IN A
EXTENSIVE -- COMMUNICATION UP
SORRY A PUBLIC EDUCATION PROGRAM
THAT GOES WITH THEM -- YOU HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT UP OTHER
TESTED REGULARLY.
THERE'S A LOT TO DO TO ENSURE
THAT SIRENS ARE IN PLACE --
DIFFERENT TONES MEAN DIFFERENT
THINGS -- MAYBE.
YOU'RE TRADING OFF ONE THING TO
GET ANOTHER TO TO SOME DEGREE.
SENDING THAT IS SO I MEAN YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO GET THE SPEED S. A
SIREN AS YOU'RE GOING TO GET IN
THIS AND IF YOU'RE A VISITOR
COMING THROUGH AN AREA --
THEORETICALLY USING THE THE THE
NEW COULD ALERT AND WARNING
GUIDELINES YOU COULD GET A LATE
MORNING ON YOUR CELL PHONE IF
YOU HEARD A SITE WHERE YOU WOULD
KNOW WHAT THAT.
WOULD THAT WOULD MEAN SO THERE'S
TRADE OFFS -- BUT THERE ARE
APPLICATIONS AND THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH US -- THEY'RE
WORKING ON THAT AS A POTENTIAL
SOLUTION IF IT WORKS FOR THEM.
GERMAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND TESTIMONY
PRESENTED.
ALRIGHT SO I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
OUR NEXT PANEL PLEASE.
WE HAVE SHAUNA GLANDS CITY
MANAGER FOR THE CITY OF SANTA
ROSA REPRESENTING THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES.
UNDER SHERIFF JOHN CRAWFORD NAPA
COUNTY REPRESENTING THE COUNTY
SUPERVISORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
CHRISTOPHER GODLY DIRECTOR OF
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT CINEMA
COUNTY REPRESENTING THE ROLE
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA.
ENSURE OF COREY HONAN BUTTE
COUNTY REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION.
GERMAN THANK YOU WELCOME TO ALL
OF YOU.
AND YOU MAY BEGIN YOUR TESTIMONY
SENATOR ANY.
THANK YOU -- COMMITTEE -- SHAMA
GLENN OF THE CITY MANAGER FROM
THE CITY OF SANTA ROSA.
ON OCTOBER EIGHTH TWO THOUSAND
AND SEVENTEEN A SERIES OF SMALL
WILDFIRES FUELED BY HIGH WINDS.
FORM SIX MASSIVE FIRES IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE THOSE FIRES
WITH THE TUBS FIRE WHICH CROSSED
INTO SANTA ROSA IN THE EARLY
HOURS OF OCTOBER NINTH.
THE TUBS FIRE BURN THROUGH HOMES
THROUGHOUT SANTA ROSA'S
HILLSIDES JUMP SIX LANES OF
HIGHWAY ONE A ONE AND SWEPT INTO
SUBURBAN RESIDENTIAL AREAS AT AN
UNPRECEDENTED RATE.
THE NUNS FIRE WHICH BEGAN ON
OCTOBER EIGHTH BECAME THE
LARGEST OF THE WINE COUNTRY
FIRES AND ALSO IMPACTED SANTA
ROSA.
DURING THE SPREAD OF THE TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN FIRES IN
CINEMA COUNTY PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICIALS WENT DOOR TO DOOR
FRANTICALLY OF TO THE
FRANTICALLY EVACUATE.
RESIDENTS IN SOME AREAS IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT.
NEIGHBORS HELPING TO WAKE
NEIGHBORS BECAME A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF OUR COMMUNITIES
EMERGENCY RESPONSE.
EMERGENCY INFORMATION WAS
DISSEMINATED BY THE CITY AND
COUNTY OFFICIALS TO COMMUNITY
MEMBERS VIA EMERGENCY LEARNING
TOOLS AND THROUGH THE USE OF
NEXT SOUL SOCIAL MEDIA.
AND RAPID COMMUNICATION WITH THE
NEWS MEDIA.
THE SYSTEMS WERE USED TO PROVIDE
EVACUATION ORDERS DIRECTIONS ON
WHERE TO GO SHELTER UPDATES IN
OTHER URGENT COMMUNICATIONS THAT
WOULD CONTINUE FOR MANY DAYS. TO
GIVE AN IDEA OF HOW QUICKLY
INFORMATION WAS CHANGING AND HOW
MANY PEOPLE NEED TO BE REACHED
DURING THE CRISIS.
CONSIDER THESE FIGURES.
AN ESTIMATED ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CITIZENS.
EVACUATED THEIR HOMES HOTELS OR
PLACE OF OCCUPANCY THROUGH THE
COUNTY DURING THE FIRES THE CITY
OPENED ITS FIRST SHELTER TWELVE
FORTY FIVE AM ON OCTOBER NINTH
AT THE COMMUNITY FAMILY CENTER.
THE SHELTER WAS FULL BY THREE
THIRTEEN AM AN ADDITIONAL FORTY
THREE SHELTERS ALSO OPENED
COUNTY WIDE.
THE CITY'S EOC PUBLIC
INFORMATION LINE FIELD AND
FOURTEEN THOUSAND CALLS FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC FROM
OCTOBER EIGHTH TWO OCTOBER
THIRTY FIRST.
IN TOTAL TWENTY FOUR LIVES WERE
LOST IN CINEMA COUNTY MORE THAN
FIFTY THREE HUNDRED HOMES
DESTROYED AS A RESULT OF THE
FIRES.
SANTA ROSA EXPERIENCE THE
UNIMAGINABLE IN OCTOBER OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN BUT AS WE SAW
JUST A YEAR LATER IT CAN HAPPEN
IN WILL HAPPEN AGAIN IN
CALIFORNIA.
SINCE THE FIRES OUR COMMUNITY
HAS FOCUSED ON NUMBER WAYS TO
IMPROVE OUR ABILITY TO REACT
SOONER IN THE EVENT OF A FIRE
THREAT.
CINEMA COUNTY IS INVESTED IN THE
NETWORK OF ADVANCE WARNING FIRE
CAMERAS THAT HAVE BEEN STALLED
IN STRATEGIC VANTAGE POINTS.
THE CAMERAS ALLOW FOR GREATER
ADVANCE NOTICE AND SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS OF A FIRE THREAT.
EVEN WHEN THE FIRE STARTS IN A
NEIGHBORING JURISDICTION.
WE ARE INCREASING FIREFIGHTING
STAFFING LEVELS AND EQUIPMENT ON
RED FLAG DAYS ALLOWING FOR
QUICKER AND MORE IMMEDIATE
RESPONSE OF RESOURCES IN THE
EVENT OF A FIRE THREAT.
WE'VE ALSO EXPANDED THE USE OF
SOME OF OUR EMERGENCY ALERT
NOTIFICATION TOOLS WITHIN THE
COUNTY AND TO CONTINUE TO
EXPLORE DITION ALERT AND WARNING
SYSTEMS -- SHARING THEIR
RELIABLE COMMUNICATION SYSTEMS
IN THE PLACE OF TO DISSEMINATE
URGENT INFORMATION DURING AN
EMERGENCY IS CRITICAL.
MAKING SURE WE HAVE A WAY TO
DEAL WITH KNOWN THREATS THAT MAY
COMPROMISE THE SYSTEM IS
PARAMOUNT.
AS PGA ANY AMPLE IN ITS NEW
MEDICATION MEASURES DURING
CRITICAL FIRE WEATHER CONDITIONS
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
COMMUNICATION CONCERNS THAT
LOCAL AGENCIES MUST CONSIDER.
A PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF
COULD RESULT IN THE LOSS OF FIRE
WIRELESS VOICE AND DATA RADIO
CABLE TELEVISION INTERNET
SERVICE THAT WOULD IMPACT PUBLIC
SAFETY.
PUBLIC SECTOR AND COMMERCIAL
COMMUNICATIONS.
PUBLIC SAFETY RADIO REPEATERS
AND THE ABILITY TO CALL 911-
COULD BE COPPER ICE ONCE BATTERY
BACKUPS DIE OR GENERATORS RUN
OUT OF FUEL.
OUR COMMUNITIES ALERT AND
WARNING SYSTEM COULD BE CRIPPLED
AND IT WOULD BE AT A CRUCIAL
TIME DURING THE CRITICAL FIRE
SEASON.
DURING A P. S. P. S. WE COULD
EVENTUALLY LOSE OUR ABILITY TO
USE WE ARE.
AND OUR LOCAL VERSION OF THE
REVERSE NINE ONE ONE TO ALERT
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO DOES NOT HAVE
A LAND LINE.
CELLPHONE TOWERS NOT EQUIPPED
WITH GENERATORS AND FUEL
SUPPLIES HAVE LIMITED BATTERY
LIFE POTENTIALLY ONLY A FEW
HOURS WHICH MEANS CALLS 291-1
AND AND ANYWHERE ELSE WE WOULD
ALSO BE IMPOSSIBLE FOR PERSON
DIDN'T HAVE A LAND LINE.
SO FAR CELL PHONE PROVIDERS HAVE
NOT BEEN FORTHCOMING WITH THEIR
PLANS FOR MEDICATING A PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF. TO KEEP
THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE RUNNING.
THEREFORE AT THIS POINT LOCAL
AGENCIES ARE LEFT TO ASSUME THE
WORST CASE SCENARIO.
WE MUST BE ABLE TO WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH CELL PHONE
CARRIERS ON THIS ISSUE.
ADDITIONALLY DURING A PS PS WE
DO NOT WE DO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
OUR ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE WITH
OUR MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS.
THOSE WITH ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL
NEEDS HOW DO WE LET THEM KNOW A
P. S. P. IS IMPENDING DEPENDING
HOW DO WE KNOW IF THEY NEED
ASSISTANCE DURING A P. S. P. S.
OF THAT.
THIS REMAINS A MAJOR CONCERN FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCIES ACROSS OUR COUNTY.
AT PRESENT PEACHY ANY IS ONLY
GOING TO CHECK ON THEIR MEDICAL
BASELINE CUSTOMERS.
THIS IS NOT REPRESENTED OF THE
ENTIRE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION.
LOCAL AGENCIES MAY NEED TO
RESORT TO DOOR TO DOOR CHECKS OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WE KNOW ABOUT.
IN AN EMERGENCY THIS COULD BE
DIFFICULT DO CAN TO ALREADY
CONSTRAINED RESOURCES AND EFFORT.
AND THE EFFORT MAY NOT COVER THE
ENTIRE POPULATION AT RISK.
MAKING SURE RESIDENTS UNDERSTAND
WHAT A P. S. P. S. IS AND AND
ARE WELL PREPARED IN THE EVENT
OF ONE IS IMPORTANT.
ENSURING THAT NEIGHBORS ARE ABLE
TO ASSIST NEIGHBORS ESPECIALLY
THOSE WITH SPECIAL NEEDS WERE
MADE A CURSE CRITICAL PONY. TO
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES DURING A P. S. P. S.
AT THAT.
BUT IS THAT TRULY THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY AND I THINK
YOU'VE HEARD EARLIER THAT THIS
IS A CRITICAL PART OF OUR
COMMUNICATIONS -- THEN WE NEED
THIS REDUNDANCY AND AND WORKING
WITH OUR WIRELESS CARRIERS
BECAUSE THEY ARE GOING TO BE THE
FUNDAMENTAL BACKBONE UNDER WHICH
WE COMMUNICATE TO OUR COMMUNITY.
DURING A LOOK SAFETY POWER SHUT
DOWN AND ANY OTHER TYPES OF
MURMURS EMERGENCY RESPONSE WE
HAVE AND THAT CONCLUDES MY
TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU.
THE FUTURE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JOHN
CRAWFORD ON THE NAPA COUNTY
UNDERSHERIFF -- BUT AS WE ALL
KNOW OCTOBER EIGHTH -- TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN BEGAN THE
ATLAS FIRE NAPA COUNTY -- ONCE
IT IS ESSENTIALLY RESOLVED
ITSELF SURE OF ROBERTSON --
DIRECTED US AS A TEAM -- TO TRY
TO KEEP AS HE PUT IT KEEP THE
BUS MOVING FORWARD TO KEEP AN
EYE ON THE RIVER MAYOR TO SEE
WHAT WE CAN DO BETTER HOW WE CAN
IMPROVE.
WE'VE TAKEN ESSENTIALLY A THREE
PRONGED APPROACH TO THAT AT THIS
POINT -- THE IRONIC PART OF
OCTOBER NINTH WAS WHEN THE SUN
CAME UP IN NAPA AND WE WERE ABLE
TO SORT OF TAKE A LOOK AROUND TO
SEE WHAT.
WAS HAPPENING THIS WILL BE MAYBE
BETTER REPORTED BACK TO THE SEES --
AS THE SUN CAME UP THE SAILOR
TOWERS WENT DOWN HAS DID THE
VOICE OVER INTERNET.
CABLE BASED PHONES SO WE LOST
THAT COMMUNICATION.
ABILITY -- SO WE ARE ONE OF
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE.
TAKEN ABACK TO ALL TECHNOLOGY IF
YOU WILL.
WE ARE USING WHAT'S CALLED A
HIGH LOS IRON -- ITS IT'S AN
OLDER SIREN THAT WAS -- SOMEWHAT
USE TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO WHEN I
BEGAN MY CAREERS NO LONGER IN
USE FOR ANY TRAFFIC ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES.
MOST AGENCIES DON'T HAVE IT
AVAILABLE IN THEIR VEHICLES
ANYMORE -- BECAUSE OF THE UNIQUE
NATURE OF IT -- FOR FAMILIAR
WITH IT SOUTH THE SENTRY LIKE
EUROPEAN.
THE SERVICE SORRY -- AGAIN AS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED THERE'S
THERE'S A LOT OF ISSUES WITH --
SORT OF A STATIONARY.SIRENS SYSTEM -- THERE'S
ENGINEERING STUDIES HAVE NEED TO
BE DONE IN A COUNTY LIKE NOW BUT
IT'S VERY RURAL ONE MOUNTAINOUS
WERE SOCIALLY A SERIES OF
VALLEY'S.
IT BE ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE REALLY --
WITHOUT SINCE THE EXTREMES NEVER
GET LAID OUT OF CAPITAL -- TO
MAKE SOMETHING LIKE THAT A
REALITY SO WHAT WE DID.
WAS WE TOOK THE EQUIPMENT THAT
WE HAD. FOR ABOUT A COST OF
ABOUT SIX DOLLARS A VEHICLE WE
HAD TO REPROGRAM TO INCLUDE THE
HIGH LOS IRON -- BEEN WE'VE BEEN
EDUCATING OUR COMMUNITY WITH
WITHOUT REACH THROUGH OUR SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS THE NEWS MEDIA
ANYWAY WE CAN TO LET PEOPLE KNOW
WHAT THE SOUND SOUNDS LIKE AND
WHAT IT MEANS WHAT IT MEANS IS
AND THE SORT OF ORGANICALLY
DURING THE FIRES -- OUR LOCAL
RADIO STATION -- BECAME.
SORT DISPENSER OF INFORMATION
AND SO WHEN WE TELL PEOPLE ABOUT
THE HIGH LOS ARE AND WE TELL
THEM TO CHECK THEIR USUAL
SOURCES OF OF NEWS TO FIND OUT
WHAT'S GOING ON BUT WE ALSO
MENTION THAT THE RADIO IS NOW --
WERE WAS SORT O ORGANIC THE
FIRST TIME IT'S IT'S WORKED
ENORMOUS THE ARMORS THE SERVICES
PLAN AT THIS POINT.
THAT WILL BE WHERE PEOPLE CAN
GET THEIR INFORMATION SHOULD
EVERYTHING ELSE FAIL AS IT DID --
SECONDLY.
WE'VE -- WE SAW A LOT OF SORT OF
ANECDOTAL.
STORIES OF PEOPLE.
THAT WERE WAITING TO BE TOLD TO
EVACUATE -- ADDITIONALLY WE YOU
KNOW WE WE YEAH IN A MORE RURAL
ENVIRONMENT WHEN YOU WE SEND
DEPUTIES ARE OFFICERS OUT DIVIDE
TO EIGHT PEOPLE IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT -- SOME OF THESE DRIVE
WAYS OR A HUNDRED YARDS LONG
EVERY WILL MAINTAIN SOME OF THEM
COULD BE A MILE LONG VERY POORLY
MAINTAINED.
AND WE CAN RUN A TO OBSTACLES
SUCH AS GATES OTHER THINGS THAT
MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR US TO PASS
THROUGH -- YOU KNOW TREES DOWN
ANY NUMBER OF THINGS.
SO -- WHAT WE CAME UP WITH TO
ADDRESS THAT CONCERN PARTIALLY?
IS -- WE CREATE AN EVACUATION
[inaudible]
TO WHICH HERE'S EXAMPLE OF IT.
AND WE MADE THESE AVAILABLE TO
ANYBODY THAT WANTS ONE ARE
COUNTY.
AND ESSENTIALLY WHAT THE IDEA
WITH THIS IS IS TWO FOLD AGAIN.
ONE IF WE ARE OUT FORMING
EVACUATION IN THE CITIZENS PLACE
THIS ON THEIR DOOR THEIR MAILBOX
THEIR GATE.
A YOU KNOW A TREE BUT THE INTO
THEIR DRIVEWAY WILL KNOW THAT
THEY'RE GONNA WE CAN MOVE ON TO
SOMEBODY ELSE IS GOING TO TAKE
IN THAT TIME IT TAKES TO DRIVE A
HALF A MILE.
THROUGH BURNING EMBERS OR
WHATEVER -- WE CAN MOVE ON TO
SOMEBODY THAT STILL NEEDS OUR
HELP.
SECONDLY WHAT THIS DOES IS IT
EMPOWERS PEOPLE TO MAKE THAT
DECISION FOR THEMSELVES THEY
DON'T HAVE TO WAIT FOR US TO
TELL THEM IT'S OKAY TO LEAVE --
IF THEY SEE A FIRE COMING IN
THEIR DIRECTION -- WE HOPE THAT
THEY REMEMBER THAT THIS TAG IS
SORT IN A SENSE GIVES THEM THAT
AUTHORITY IS AND THAT
EMPOWERMENT. TO EVACUATE
THEMSELVES AND NOT HAVE TO WAIT
FOR GOVERNMENT. TO A TO A FOUR
LASTLY.
WHAT WE'VE BEEN INVOLVED WITH IS
WE'VE BEEN WE'VE PARTNERED WITH
CAL FIRE -- TO CREATE THESE
EVACUATION PLAN PAMPHLETS IT'S
PART OF THE READY SET GO PROGRAM.
AND ESSENTIALLY WHAT THIS
INCLUDES IS -- INFORMATION HOW
TO PREPARE YOURSELVES -- WHICH
IS THREE SIGNAL PROGRAM AND IT
ALSO INCLUDES A MAP WITH
PREFERRED ROUTES AS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED IF THE INTERNET'S DOWN
OF YOUR NOT ABLE TO ACCESS YOUR
CELL PHONE YOU'RE NOT REALLY
FAMILIAR WITH YOUR SURROUNDINGS
NECESSARILY.
THIS HAS PREFERRED EVACUATION
ROUTES IT DOES NOT HAVE AN
EVACUATION PLAN WE LEAVE THAT UP
TO THE INDIVIDUALS BECAUSE WE
ALSO -- MAN OUR DISPATCHER
RECEIVED PHONE CALLS FROM
CITIZENS WHO HAD BEEN TOLD TO
EVACUATE.
THE SAID THEY DIDN'T KNOW WHICH
DIRECTION TO GO OVER ASKING OUR
DISPATCHERS TO TELL WHERE TO GO
SO AS PART OF OUR OUT REACH.
WE REMIND PEOPLE THAT THEY NEED
TO BE AWARE OF THEIR
SURROUNDINGS AND THEY AGAIN NEED
TO BE EMPOWERED. TO HAVE THAT
ABILITY TO DECIDE THE BEST WAY.
BASED ON THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES WE
CAN'T THROUGH A PHONE LINE TO A
WHICH WITH FIRES ADVANCING ON
THEM WHICH WAY THEIR DRIVEWAY --
GOES -- WHICH YOU KNOW WHAT'S
THE BEST ROUTE TO TAKE SO.
IN A NUTSHELL THOSE ARE THE
THREE THINGS ESSENTIAL THAT WERE
WORKING ON AN APP COUNTY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE SMITH AND
SIGNATURE MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
ON CHRISTOPHER GODLY WITH COUNTY
CINEMA WHERE I SERVICES DIRECTOR
OF EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT.
THANK YOU FOR THIS SESSION IT'S
A SUBJECT VERY NEAR AND DEAR TO
THE HEARTS OF SOME COUNTY
RESIDENTS.
HAS CLEARLY EVIDENCED BY -- HI
THE RECENT TESTIMONY I WOULD
MENTION THAT FOLLOWING THAT
FIRESTORM OCTOBER
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE COUNTIES TO
IN A VERY BRIGHT SPOTLIGHT -- TO
HIS DECISION AT THE TIME NOT TO
USE THE WIRELESS EMERGENCY ALERT
SYSTEM.
SUBSEQUENT TO THAT OF COURSE THE
COUNTY OR TOOK A VERY
SIGNIFICANT AND VERY FOCUSED
REVIEW.
OF ITS EMERGENCY ALERT WARNING
CAPABILITIES AS WELL AS
ORGANIZATION RESOURCES AT HAND.
THAT EXPERIENCE IS FOR THE
COUNTY TO REALLY MOVE FORWARD
NOW TO DEVELOP FIRST CLASS
COMPREHENSIVE COUNTY WIDE
COMMUNITY ALERT WARNING PROGRAM.
WHICH AND INCORPORATE SUCH AS
TECHNOLOGY WHICH HAS BEEN THE
SUBJECT OF MUCH DISCUSSION TODAY
REALLY ALSO ADDRESSES QUESTIONS
A POLICY.
THE ABILITY TO GET REAL TIME
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS INTO THE
HANDS OF THOSE THAT NEED TO
ISSUE ALERT WARNINGS.
AS WELL AS COMPREHENSIVE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT.
SAID THE RESIDENTS UNDERSTAND
WHICH WARNING SYSTEMS ARE
AVAILABLE AND WHAT THEY SHOULD
DO ONCE THEY BEGIN TO RECEIVE
WARNINGS.
BECAUSE HERE IT'S FROM A CAN WE
TRULY DO UNDERSTAND THAT IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
COUNTY GOVERNMENT IS REALLY
CENTER OF GRAVITY FOR THE ALERT
WARNING EFFORTS FOR MOST OF OUR
RESIDENTS IN THE STATE.
ON ESSENTIALLY FOR ALERT WARNING
COUNTIES WHERE THE RUBBER HITS
THE ROAD.
AND SO TO THAT END WE'VE BEGAN
DEVELOPING AND WE'VE MOVED PAST
ANALYSIS AND RESOURCING.
AND PROGRAMMING AND WE'RE MOVING
FULLY IN TEMPERAMENT TATIAN NOW.
AND WE FOUND FOR CHALLENGES THAT
MAY BE.
DIRECTLY ANSWERING YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT HOW TO IMPROVE OUR OVERALL
SYSTEMS CAPABILITIES.
THE FIRST OF COURSE IS PUBLIC
EXPECTATIONS SERVICE.
THAT HAS EVOLVED RADICALLY ALONG
WITH TECHNOLOGY OF THE LAST
TWENTY FIVE YEARS WE'VE ALL
BECOME USED TO HAVING CELL PHONE
DEVICES.
DIGITAL DATA AT OUR FINGERTIPS
THAT ALLOWS TO MERELY ENGAGE
WITH AND INTERACT WITH THE WORLD.
USUALLY VIA ROBUST COMMERCIAL
GRADE SYSTEMS ARE WELL RESOURCE
FINANCED INVENTED.
ON THE PUBLIC DOES EXPECT IN A
NO NOTICE OF THAT.
LIKE A WILDFIRE T GET
NOTIFICATION WITHIN MINUTES
THEY'RE NOT GONNA WAIT AROUND
FOR HOURS SAYING BELIEVE THAT
THEY SHOULD HAVE THAT
INFORMATION ALMOST REAL TIME.
THAT EVEN IF THEY DON'T OFTEN TO
LOCAL WARNING SYSTEMS THAT THE
GOVENMENT SHOULD HAVE THE
CAPABILITY TO FIND THEM.
WAKE THEM UP.
AND DELIVER INFORMATION ON THE
DEVICE OF THEIR CHOICE IN THE
LANGUAGE THAT THEY PREFER.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO KNOW THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE AN
EXPECTATION THAT LOCAL FIRST
RESPONDERS HAVE AN INSTANTANEOUS.
IF YOU WOULD BIRDS EYE VIEW OF
WHAT'S GOING ON A FULL
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS THAT THEY
CAN THEN CONVEY TO THE RESIDENTS
WHEN OF COURSE WE KNOW THAT'S
NOT THE CASE.
ON THE RESIDENTS ALSO EXPECTED
MANY THESE LOWER WARNING SYSTEMS
TO GET IN REAL TIME VERY
SPECIFIC AND DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS.
AS TO WHAT ACTIONS THEY SHOULD
TAKE.
WHICH ROUTES SHOULD THEY TAKE
WHAT SHOULD THEY TAKE WITH THEM
WHERE SHOULD THEY GO.
AND THEN FINALLY.
RESIDENTS TO EXPECT TO BE ABLE
TO CORROBORATE THIS INFORMATION
IN NEAR REAL TIME.
A SINGLE WARNING OR SINGLE ALERT
MESSAGE IS USUALLY NOT ENOUGH TO
MOVE PEOPLE INTO ACTION.
THEY HAVE TO HAVE A SECOND OR
EVEN A THIRD SOURCE OF
INFORMATION BEFORE THEY MOVE
INTO ACTION.
AND EXPECT THESE TECHNOLOGIES TO
SUPPORT THAT -- IS PRESENT
PICKING INDICATE A PEASANT
PICKER OF CP SYNDICATE WE'D TO
CONDUCT A SIGNIFICANT TEST IN
SUMMER COUNTY. TO REALLY TAKE A
HARD LOOK AT WHETHER THE SYSTEMS
PERFORM -- AND HE HIGHLIGHTED
SOME OF OUR FINDINGS I WOULD
SUGGEST AN UNNATURAL THAT
ESSENTIALLY THE SYSTEMS NO
MATTER WHICH TECHNOLOGY WE'RE
GOING TO DISCUSS TODAY.
SIMPLY DID NOT PERFORM AS
ADVERTISED IN EACH ONE OF THESE
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
PERFORMANCE GAPS.
TECHNOLOGICAL HURDLES CHALLENGES
BECAUSE HE'S TECHNOLOGIES ARE
RELATIVELY.
JUNIOR TECHNOLOGIES COMPARED T
THEIR MORE OLDER AND WELL
RESOURCE TOLD -- COMMERCIAL
BRETHREN.
THERE'S NOT MUCH MONEY ALERT
WARNING.
THESE PROGRAMS THESE
APPLICATIONS.
THEY DON'T GET A LOT OF
EXERCISES ARE NOT NEARLY AS
ROBUST AND AS RESILIENT AS THE
LARGER COMMERCIAL SYSTEMS ARE
ALL FAMILIAR WITH.
SO THE RECOMMENDATION IS
BASICALLY TO BE HONEST WITH OUR
COMMUNITIES I TALK TO PEOPLE
ABOUT THE FACT THAT WHILE WE
MIGHT TRY TO REACH THEM.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GUARANTEE IT
THAT THEY NEED TO MAINTAIN SOME
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THEIR OWN
PROTECTION MAINTAIN THEIR OWN
AWARENESS AND CONNECTING WITH
OUR LOCAL NEIGHBORS.
AND THEN FINALLY REALLY URGE OUR
INDUSTRY PARTNERS WHETHER IT'S
INTEL COMMISSION COMMUNICATIONS
ALERT WARNING. TO REALLY IMPROVE
THEIR ABILITIES TO MEET THE
COMMUNITY WHERE THEY LIVE NOW.
MOST OF US ARE ONLINE SOMETIMES
WE STILL CANNOT DELIVER WARNING
MESSAGES TO PEOPLE FOR ONLINE.
WITH ARE WATCHING SATELLITE TV
IF THEY'RE NOT A LOCAL CHANNEL
WE CAN'T REACH THEM.
OUR COMMUNITY HAS MOVED ON USED
TO COMMUNITY OUR COMMITTEES HAVE
MOVED ON USED TECHNOLOGIES IN
DIFFERENT WAYS.
OUR LORTON WARNING SYSTEMS HAVE
TO MAINTAIN THAT PACE AS WELL.
IN GENERALIZATIONS WAS NOTED IS
A SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE I WILL.
POINT OUT FOR THE PUBLIC SAFETY
CHIEFS THAT THEY'RE ALL SITTING
WITH OTHER CHALLENGES TO
AGGREGATION OF THEIR OWN
CAPABILITIES TO RESPOND.
THEIR ABILITY TO DEAL WITH
ISSUES SUCH AS POTENTIALLY LOSS
OF WATER SUPPLIER PRESSURE.
THE REAL NIGHTMARE IS SPEAK TURN
OFF THE POWER THE CELL PHONE
TOWERS FAIL DUE TO LACK OF
BACKUP TAKE OFF LINE.
AND THEN A WILD FIRE BREAKS OUT.
NOW WE HAVE NO WAY TO REACH
THESE PEOPLE TERE ARE HARMS WAY
OUR OF VALUATION AT OPERATIONS
WILL BE SEVERELY COMPROMISED AS
WELL.
SO IN MANY WAYS -- THE CHALLENGE
FOR CALIFORNIA IS THAT WHILE WE
MAY BE WORKING TO PREVENT
WILDFIRE CONDITIONS.
WE MAY BE IN FACT INCREASING THE
ACTUAL IMPACTS A WILDFIRE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
DURING THESE GENERALIZATION
OFFENSE [inaudible]
AS DIRECTOR GIL TO G. ALSO
POINTED OUT.
THESE WIRELESS BROADBAND
INTERNET CAPABILITIES IN THE
SYSTEMS ARE NO LONGER SIMPLY
UTILITIES THEY'RE NOT JUST A WAY
TO TALK TO EACH OTHER.
THEY REALLY BECOME EFFECTIVELY
CRITICAL LIFE AND DEATH
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE SYSTEM SHOULD BE BUILT AND
OPERATED AS SUCH.
FINALLY AXIS AND FUNCTIONAL
NEEDS IS AN AREA OF SIGNIFICANT
CONCERN.
BECAUSE MOST OF OUR ALERT
WARNING SYSTEMS DO NOT ACTUALLY
SUPPORT AND SERVICE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT SUFFER FROM A
VARIETY OF CHALLENGES IN ALERT
WARNING IS WELLS RESPONDING TO
DISASTERS AS A WHOLE.
THE TERM AXIS AND FUNCTIONAL
NEEDS IS IN FACT NOT ACTUALLY
WELL DEFINED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WE HAVE NO BENCHMARKS
FOR HOW TO PERFORM.
IN TRYING TO DEVELOP ALERT
MORNING PROGRAM SERVICES TO
DELIVER -- FULL CAPABILITIES THE
AXLE AXIS AND FROM FROM THESE
COMMUNITY.
UNDER THE CONCEPT OF NOTHING
FOREST WITHOUT AS WE TWO NEED TO
ENGAGE BETTER A LARGER SET.
HAVE ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS
STAKEHOLDERS AT A POLICY LEVEL.
TO ENSURE THAT OUR SYSTEMS TRULY
IN WELLIES SERVE THOSE WHO MOST
MAY NEED A WARNING SENATE
FINALLY I WILL.
SUGGEST THAT SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES LEADERSHIP AND MONEY.
THE PROBABLY GET THIS ALL THE
TIME -- BUT I'M SURE WITH YOU
IT'S REALLY GONNA TAKE POLITICAL
MORE RESOURCES TO ADDRESS THIS.
AS A COUNTIES LOOK TO DEVELOP
THEIR CAPABILITIES IN THIS AREA.
OUR RECENT ACTIONS MIGHT GIVE
YOU SOME.
IDEA OF THE SCALE OF EFFORT THAT
SEATED.
FIRST OUR COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TO ELEVATE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT FUNCTION WITHIN
COUNTY GOVERNMENT IT'S NOW AN
INDEPENDENT DEPARTMENT.
I ISA DIRECTOR NOW REPORT
DIRECTLY TO COUNTY ADMINISTRATOR.
PART OF THE WILDFIRES TO THE
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT STAFF.
I SPENT LITTLE TIME EACH MONTH
DOING ALERT WARNING SYSTEM
MAINTENANCE TRAINING -- MAYBE
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED HOURS A YEAR
THAT'S FOR POPULATION OF FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE.
SO NOW WE'VE GONE FROM THAT PART
TIME EFFORT TO TO DEDICATED FULL
TIME ALERT WARNING PROGRAM STAFF.
BECAUSE YOU CAN HEARTHE
COMPLEXITIES THE SYSTEMS CAN
OVERWHELM QUITE EASILY ANYONE
THAT.
ONLY HAS A FEW HOURS A MONTH TO
DO WITH THIS.
WE'VE ALSO GREASER SPENDING ON
TECHNOLOGY FROM EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS YEAR TO ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS HERE.
SOON TOTAL ARE LOWER OUR NEW
ALERT WARNING PROGRAM RUNS ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS YEAR OUT OF GENERAL FUND.
ALMOST A DOLLAR PER RESIDENT AND
THIS DOES NOT INCLUDE THE
GENERAL ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT
THE PROGRAM ALSO ENJOYS.
THANK YOU SHOULD BENCHMARK FOR
COUNTY IS OF SOME HAVE STEPPED
TO TO PUT THE MONEY TOWARDS HIS
PROGRAM.
AND THEN FINALLY WE DO NEED TO
BETTER INTEGRATE TECHNOLOGIES --
THAT ARE NOT TRADITIONAL TO
GOVERNMENT.
LIKE A WEBSITE IT'S NOT TOO HARD
TO SET ONE UP COUNTIES BEEN
DOING IT FOREVER.
EXCEPT IT DOESN'T WORK ON
DISASTER DOESN'T SCALE IT WILL
FAIL IN TOO MANY PEOPLE HAD IT'S
NOT DYNAMIC ENOUGH.
IT'S RECRUITED A NEW WEBSITE
THAT AUTOMATICALLY POPULATES ONE
WARNING MESSAGE USE ISSUED WITH
THAT EXACT WARNING MESSAGE IN
BOTH ENGLISH AND SPANISH AND A
MAP OF THE AREA TO BE WARNED.
SO PEOPLE CAN GO TO THAT WEBSITE.
OFF OF A TINY YOUR L. IN THE
MESSAGES SENT TO THEM THEY CAN
CORPORATE THE INFORMATION TODAY
JUST HURT OR THEY DON'T HAVE TO
REMEMBER WHAT THE WE SAID ON THE
VOICE MESSAGE THEY CAN ACTUALLY
SEE IT IN WRITING.
SO CINEMA COUNTY LIKE MANY OF
HER PEERS IS WORKING HARD TO
MAKE ALERT WARNING MEANINGFUL
FOR RESIDENTS AND WE SUGGEST IS
CAN TAKE MORE THAN TECHNOLOGY.
MORE THAN GUIDANCE AND MORE THAN
GOOD INTENTIONS IT WILL REQUIRE
LEADERSHIP COMMITMENT ANSON IF
CAN'T RESOURCES. TO DEVELOP A
TRULY EFFECTIVE SUSTAINABLE --
WARNING CAP CAPABILITY FOR
CALIFORNIANS I APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME AND LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SURE SMITH JR SANTIAGO ARMORS A
COMMITTEE -- THANK YOU MY NAME
IS COREY HONEY I'M THE SHERIFF
OF BIãU COUNTY.
HI MY COUNTY ARE NO STRANGERS TO
MERCY -- MORNINGS AND
EVACUATIONS.
DURING MY TENURE SHERIFF.
MY DEPARTMENT MY COMMITTEE HAD
THE OROVILLE DAM SPILLWAY CRISIS
WHICH RESULTED IN A MASS
EVACUATION.
OF THE SOUTHERN PART OF THE
COUNTY IT IMPACTED TO TO
COUNTIES TO THE SOUTH OF US A
SOUTHERN YUBA AS WELL.
IN ADDITION THAT WE HAD -- A
SERIES OF FIRES THAT FOLLOW THAT --
THAT WEREN'T NEARLY AS NOTABLE
SOME THE FOR TODAY -- BUT WE DID
INDEED HAVE TO IMPLEMENT ARE
WARNING SYSTEM THAT OUR
VALUATION PROTOCOLS.
AND THEN MOST RECENTLY AND I'M
SURE YOU'RE AWARE A CAMPFIRE
OCCURRED.
IN BUTTE COUNTY IT IS TODAY I
HOPE REMAINS TODAY THE MOST
DESTRUCTIVE.
AND DEADLY FIRE IN THIS DETAILED
HISTORY STUDY CALIFORNIA
CERTAINLY WOULD WISH THAT UPON
ANY OTHER COMMUNITY. TO COME TO
YOU WITH THAT LOVE BASE OF
EXPERIENCE AND I WILL TELL YOU
THAT I AM PLEASED TO HEAR SOME
OF THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES
HERE AND I'D LIKE TO AMPLIFY
CERTAINLY WHAT UNDERSERVED
CRAWFORD SAID A MISTER GODLY
SAID -- WITH REGARD -- TO WHAT
WE NEED TO DO.
IN TERMS OF MANAGING THE
COMMUNITIES EXPECTATIONS AND
INSPIRING IN THEM A SENSE OF
RESPONSIBILITY.
YOU RECEIVED A PRIMER I THINK ON
THE STATE OF AFFAIRS WITH REGARD
TO MERCY OF WARNING SYSTEMS I
THINK IT'S A GOOD OVERVIEW.
AND I CERTAINLY SUPPORT WILL MY
OTHER COLLEAGUES OF SAID WITH
REGARD TO THE NEED TO INCREASE
RELIABILITY AMAZON REDUNDANCY
WITHIN THE TECHNOLOGICAL
FRAMEWORK THAT WE USED TO NOTIFY
PEOPLE.
THE FACT THE MATTER IS WE RELY
UPONTECHNOLOGY BECAUSE IT IS
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE WAY TO
ALERT -- THE SIGNIFICANT ARE THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
PEOPLE.
BUT THE FACT THE MATTER IS IT
RELIES UPON TECHNOLOGY AND IN
THE SEARCH OF THE SERVICE
CIRCUMSTANCES TECHNOLOGY
ULTIMATELY FAILS OR CAN FILTER
IT RATHER RATHER QUICKLY.
CERTAINLY INCREASING RELIABILITY
OR DENNIS HE WOULD -- MITIGATE
THOSE RISKS BUT QUITE FRANKLY.
I DON'T KNOW THAT WE WOULD EVER
GET TO A POINT WHERE WE CAN
ENSURE.
WITH 1100% CERTAINTY THAT
TECHNOLOGY WON'T FAIL.
WHAT I'VE LEARNED OVER THE
COURSE OF THIS IN TERMS OF
WARNING PEOPLE YOU HAVE TO
MESSAGE ACROSS MULTIPLE
PLATFORMS?
YOU HAVE -- TO GET THAT
INFORMATION OUT BUT WHEN YOU
MESSAGE ACROSS PLATFORMS THAT
ARE AGAIN BASED ON TECHNOLOGY.
YOU'RE CERTAINLY GOING TO BE AT
A DISADVANTAGE WHEN THAT
TECHNOLOGY FAILS.
IN THE AFTERMATH OF THE ORVILLE
SPILL INTO THE ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS TO STUDY AND
ULTIMATELY CAME TO ME AND TOLD
ME THAT THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY
TO ALERT PEOPLE.
OF A THREAT. TO THEIR LIVES HAVE
A UNIFORMED LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
KNOCK ON THEIR DOOR UNTIL THEY
NEED TO LEAVE THE MEDIA ARE
GOING TO DIE.
BUT THAT'S AND THAT'S NOT
PRACTICAL BECAUSE QUITE FRANKLY
IS NOT ENOUGH LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS IN ANY COMMUNITY TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT.
THAT'S A PRETTY LOW TECHNOLOGY
WAY TO NOTIFY PEOPLE THAT'S VERY
EFFECTIVE BUT IT'S JUST NOT
PRACTICAL.
SO WHAT ULTIMATELY LEARN FROM
ALL OF THIS IS HIS FIRST AND
FOREMOST.
DESPITE OUR ABSOLUTE BEST
EFFORTS AND OUR NEED TO PUT OUR
BEST FOOT FORWARD.
THERE IS NO WAY TO GUARANTEE
1100% SATURATION OF YOUR MESSAGE.
AND THEN SECONDLY THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE THAT PEOPLE WILL DO
WHAT YOU ASK HIM TO DO OR WHAT
THEY NEED.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS PEOPLE
OFTEN AS YOU HEARD A NOR THE
WARNING.
BUT MORE TRAGICALLY THAN THAT IS
THERE NOT BE PREPARED TO DEAL
WITH THE WARNING.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHERE WE ALSO
NEED TO FOCUS -- CERTAINLY THESE
ISSUES ARE IMPORTANT.
BUT WE NEED TO WORK WITHIN THE
COMMUNITIES AGAIN TO MANAGE
THEIR EXPECTATIONS AND INSPIRE
SINCE RESPONSIBILITY IN THEM.
BUT THEY HAVE TO BE PREPARED
[inaudible] TO GATHER
INFORMATION FROM DIFFERENT
SOURCES EVEN WITH SOURCES THAT
THAT -- AREN'T TRADITIONAL IN
TERMS OF THE WAY THEY GATHER THE
INFORMATION -- THAT ARE BASED ON
TECHNOLOGY.
AND THEN THEY HAVE TO BE
PREPARED TO REACT TO THAT
INFORMATION.
THERE'S NO WAY THAT WE IN IN
GOVERNMENT OR WE IN PUBLIC
SAFETY CAN TAILOR A WARNING
SYSTEM OR EVACUATION PLAN THAT
MEETS THE SPECIFIC NEEDS OF
EVERY SINGLE INDIVIDUAL.
THERE HAS TO BE SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY ON THE PART
INDIVIDUAL TO KNOW WHAT.
THEIR PARTICULAR NEEDS ARE WITH
THEIR PARTICULAR CIRCUMSTANCE
ARE HOW THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THAT.
AND THEN WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO
DO IN IN A CRISIS AND YOU'VE
HEARD MY COLLEAGUES TALK ABOUT.
US PUTTING OUT A WARNING --
PUTTING OUT WARNINGS TELLING
PEOPLE EVACUATED THEM CALLING
ASKING WHICH ROUTE.
WAS NO WAY FOR US TO KNOW WHICH
ROUTE BECAUSE WE CAN'T
NECESSARILY DETERMINE WHICH WAY
THE FIRES COMING OR WHICH WITH A
FLOOD IS COMING OR WHAT THE
SITUATION IS. TO PEOPLE HAVE TO
BE PREPARED TO DO THAT ON THEIR
OWN.
AND THEN THERE'S A WHOLE HOST
HER WHOLE SEGMENT OF OUR OUR
POPULATION PEOPLE SPECIAL NEEDS.
A WHO HAVE.
TO AFTER A PLAN IN PLACE AHEAD
OF TIME TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
CAN GET OUT BUT THIS IS NOT
LIMITED TO PEOPLE SPECIAL NEEDS.
MANY OF THE PEOPLE THAT WOULD --
EVACUATE FROM THE CAMPFIRE
WOULDN'T LEAVE BECAUSE THEY HAD
ANIMALS THAT THEY COULDN'T
EVACUATED THEY WOULD WANT TO
LEAVE THOSE ANIMALS.
SO A WHATEVER THAT INDIVIDUAL'S
SPECIFIC NEEDS ARE -- WE HAVE.
TO ENCOURAGE THEM AND INFORM
THEM AND AGAIN INSPIRE IN THEM A
SENSE RESPONSIBILITY TO HAVE A
PLAN AHEAD OF TIME.
BECAUSE FRANKLY WHEN IT'S TIME
TO PUT OUT THE WARNING YOU'RE
ALREADY IN DANGER THAT'S NOT THE
PLAN TO PREPARE THAT'S NOT THE
TIME TO PREPARE THAT'S NOT THE
TIME TO PLAN.
THAT'S THE TIME FOR YOU TO
EXECUTE THE PLAN THAT YOU'VE
ALREADY PUT IN PLACE.
AS WITH THAT I WILL CONCLUDE MY
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THOMAN
PROCEEDED MISTER SANTIAGO
QUESTIONS.
YEAH AND IF I CAN -- MISTER SURE
LIKE TO ASK A COUPLE QUESTIONS --
IS KIND OF INTRIGUING FOR ME IS
TO HEAR SOMEBODY SAY ABLE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE GONNA SELL PHILIP
SOME POINT IN TIME RIGHT.
SO THE QUESTION BUT FOR ME ONE
OF THE BEST PRACTICES -- THAT
YOU'VE IDENTIFIED BOTH FROM A
GOVERNMENT AGENCY STANDPOINT AND
FROM A PRESENT STANDPOINT.
AND IF YOU MIGHT ALSO JUST JUMP
IN ON SOME OF THE TECHNOLOGY
PIECES AND TELL ME WHAT ARE THE
MOST EFFECTIVE ONES -- THAT YOU
SEEN IN REACHING PEOPLE BASED ON
YOUR EXPERIENCE.
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
SO -- WHAT WERE THE BEST NEW
COMMUNITY IN RELATIONSHIP TO
TECHNOLOGY -- ONE OF THE BEST
PRACTICES IN GOVERNMENT AND BEST
PRACTICES FOR RESIDENT WHEN THIS
HAPPENS.
CLOSER THOSE ARE GREAT QUESTIONS
AND CERTAINLY IF I HAD THE THE
CORRECT ANSWER TO EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THOSE WE PROBABLY WITH
THE NEED FOR THIS COMMITTEE
RIGHT -- THAT SAID -- WHAT I'M
HOPING TO CONVEY IS THAT THERE
IS NO ONE SINGLE?
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM AND
CERTAINLY -- HAVING MULTIPLE
WAYS TO COMMUNICATE PEOPLE
INCLUDING THOSE ARE BASED IN
TECHNOLOGY YOU KNOW THE WIRELESS
SOLAR SYSTEM I PAUSE SOCIAL
MEDIA TRADITIONAL MEDIA.
I EVEN THE SIREN SYSTEMS IS A IS
A FORM OF TECHNOLOGY THAT --
DEPENDING ON THE CIRCUMSTANCES --
COULD WORK WELL IN OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCES NOT SO WELL AND
I'VE OFTEN HEAR PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT SIRENS IN.
AND I THINK SIRENS WORK IN
CERTAIN GEOGRAPHICAL AREAS WHEN
THEY WARN ABOUT ONE THREAT WITH
ONE RESPONSE WHEN YOU START
ADDING MULTIPLE THREATS MULTI
WERE SPONSORS IT BECOMES A LESS
EFFECTIVE SYSTEM LET'S LET'S
FIGURE SYSTEM.
BUT I SEE THAT A COME BACK TO
THIS WHOLE NOTION THAT -- I
THINK WE'RE MISSING PART OF THE
BOAT HERE IF WE FOCUS
EXCLUSIVELY ON GOVERNMENTS --
ROLL OR GOVERNMENTS --
CAPABILITIES OF WARNING PEOPLE
THROUGH -- THESEVARIOUS WARNING
SYSTEMS YOU HAVE TO HAVE.
OTHER PLAYERS AT THE TABLE
WILLING TO COME TO THE TABLE TO
PARTICIPATE AND CERTAINLY THAT
INCLUDES -- THOSE -- ENTITIES
THAT PROVIDE THE TECHNOLOGICAL
BASIS TO DO THE WARNING SYSTEM
THAT HAS IMPORTANT PART OF IT
BUT IT COME BACK TO THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMUNITY HAS TO BE PART
OF THIS AS WELL INDIVIDUALS HAVE
TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY.
AND I THINK YOU'RE YOUR OWN
EXPERIENCE WE TALKED ABOUT YOUR
INTRODUCTION.
WHEN YOU WENT OUT AND HELD
COMMUNITY MEETINGS AND I SUSPECT
THERE WAS A LOT OF OUR REACH
PARTY COMMITTEE MEETING ABOUT
SIGNING UP FOR THE VARIOUS MERCY
MASSIVELY KEY SYSTEMS?
BUT YOU YOU YOU READY TO PEOPLE
WHO DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT IT WHO
DIDN'T WHO HAD SIGNED UP FOR IT.
THERE IS THIS SENSE OF APATHY
AND I THINK PROBLEMS SOMETIMES
WHEN.
WE BECOME SO DEPENDENT UPON
TECHNOLOGY IN KAY AND IN MANY
CASES DEPENDING ON THE
GOVERNMENT TO TELL US WHAT TO DO.
AND TO WARN US ABOUT THINGS THAT --
WE ALMOST. FOR GO OUR OWN
RESPONSIBILITY OF MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE A PLAN IN PLACE TO
KEEP OURSELVES SAFE AND I THINK
THAT'S GONNA BE PART OF IT
[inaudible]
MENTOR.
WE'LL SEE THE REASON I ASK THAT
QUESTION IS -- I UNDERSTAND THAT
THE HAS THE PERSON
RESPONSIBILITY ABSOLUTELY -- LET
ME LET ME STEP BACK FOR A SECOND
IN YOUR BED IN YOUR EXPERIENCE
WHAT ARE THE THINGS YOU CAN DO.
TO MAKE THIS IMPORTANT A
COMMUNITY OR NOT NECESSARILY YOU
BUT IN TERMS OF GOVERNMENT
BECAUSE WE FACE THE SAME
SITUATION KIND OF IN OUR AREA
WITH THE AMERICAN RED CROSS
COMES IT BUT THERE'S CERTAIN.
THERE'S CERTAIN LEG WORK TO GET
DONE IN ADVANCE TO MAKE IT AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE WERE IT MAY NOT
BEEN AN IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I'M
NOT TAKING AWAY ASIDE FROM
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY OF AN
INDIVIDUAL BUT ARE THE THINGS
THAT WE CAN DO ARE THE THINGS
THAT.
WE HAVEN'T INVESTED IN OUR
THINGS IT WOULD BE A THAT ARE
WORKING THAT WE'RE DOING FOR
THAT YOU'RE DOING.
THAT HELPED TO MAKE THIS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR PEOPLE SO
THAT YOU'RE PREPARED TO HAVE
WATER I AM AN EX GAY PLAN YOU
YOU HAVE A FLASHLIGHT I'M ALL
THE BASIC THINGS RIGHT AWAY THE
THINGS THAT WE CAN PROMOTE.
OR WERE THE BEST AVENUES OF BEST
PRACTICES IF YOU SEEN SO DOES
BECOME IMPORT.
YES SIR I THINK OF A ROBUST
PUBLIC OUT REACHES BUSINESS PART
OF THAT WHOLE PLAN YOU GOTTA DO
YOU YOU'VE GOT TO BE PART OF
THAT IS THAT IT HAS TO PARTY
PLAN.
I I THINK ALSO WE NEED TO START --
HAVING SOMETHING.
TO PERHAPS YOU KNOW WE TAKE IT
TO THE SCHOOLS AND WE START
TALKING ABOUT A MERCY FOR
PARENTS WITH A PREPAREDNESS WITH
OUR WITH OUR KIDS -- WE TAKE A
TOR SERVICE CLUBS WE TAKE A
DIVERSE COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS.
WE HAVE RESOURCES AVAILABLE --
IN IN A STANDARDIZED PLAN AD
THEN THERE'S ALREADY AM I THINK
A MODEL FOR THAT THE RACE HAD
GROW FOR CO PROGRAM IS PART OF
THAT.
BUT WE HAVE A PLAN THAT WE CAN
REALLY START PUTTING TEIR
MISSION OUT AND CONVEYED IN
MULTIPLE WAYS YOU CAN.
YOU KNOW TO USE SOCIAL MEDIA
RIGHT NOW IS A LOT OF PEOPLE
LOOK TO THAT A LOT OF LOOKS JUST
ME TO BUT MANY THAT MANY THE
MEMBERS ARE MANY THE MEMBERS A
COMMUNITY IN THE CAMP FIRE.
WERE ELDERLY PEOPLE AND FRANKLY
THEY DON'T TAP INTO SOCIAL MEDIA --
LIKE A LOT OF THE OTHER
GENERATIONS OF MEMBERS A
COMEDIAN SO WE MISSED THE BOAT
WITH REGARD TO THAT WE HAVE TO
FIND WAYS TO COMMUNICATE THAT
ACROSS MULTIPLE AND NOT TO
MENTION IT CAN IT CAN OFTEN BE
INFORMATION THAT IS NOT ACCURATE
OR INFORMATION THAT IS NOT --
NOT SOUND FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
ABSOLUTELY THE OTHER THE OTHER
PIECE OF THE STUDENT AND WHY I
KEEP COMING BACK TO THIS NEED TO
INSPIRE.
A MANAGE -- EXPECTATIONS OF A
COMMUNITIES AS INSPIRE THEM
SINCE RESPONSIBILITIES BECAUSE
WELL WE WE DETERMINE -- WHAT WE
FOUND?
BOTH OF THE SPILL WAY INCIDENT
AND ABSOLUTELY WITH THE CAMPERS
AND HIS WITHIN.
LITERALLY A MATTER OF MINUTES --
ALL OF OUR PUBLIC RESOURCES WERE
JUST OVERWHELMED OUR DISPATCH
CENTER WAS OVERWHELMED HER FIRST
RESPONDERS OR WENT.
THERE WEREN'T ENOUGH POLICE
OFFICERS THAT WE SHARE SLOT FOR
STRUCTURES IN BUTTE COUNTY.
TO A NOTIFY EVERYBODY THERE
WEREN'T A FIRE ENGINES TO FIGHT
THAT FIRE AND SO ULTIMATELY
MEMBERS A COMMITTEE HAD A PART
OF THE SOLUTION -- THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH MEAN CLEARLY FROM
GREAT TRAGEDY UNFORTUNATELY
COMES YOU KNOW GREAT NECESSITY
OF OF INVENTION AND AND YOU
REALLY THOUGHT THROUGH KIND OF
ENHANCING CREATING YOUR SYSTEMS
AND FORMING.
ON THE PUBLIC THAT YOU SERVE WE
CERTAINLY GOT A LOT OF VERY
USEFUL INFORMATION FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ON THE AND FOR OUR
FINAL PANEL WE WILL WELCOME UP
THE TECHNOLOGY PROVIDER AND
UTILITIES GROUP.
STEVE CARLSON GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
COUNCIL CTIA THE WIRELESS
ASSOCIATION.
TODD WATSON MANAGER OF NETWORK
ENGINEERING EIGHTEEN T.
CALIFORNIA.
HEY SUSE ROMAN CHIEF LEAD
COUNSEL VERIZON.
CAROLINE MCINTYRE PRESIDENT FOR
CC T. A CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
AND AUGUST KEOGH -- DIRECTOR OF
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT SAN DIEGO
GAS AND ELECTRIC THANK YOU ON
WELCOME.
AND PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR STEVE
CARLSON Và CTIA WHERE THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY.
WE'RE GOING TO START OUT WITH A
TODD WATSON OF EIGHTEEN TO YOU
WHO'S GOING TO WALK THROUGH --
WHAT DAY OF WHAT EIGHTEEN T.
DOES AND OTHER CARRIERS DO FROM
THE BEGINNING TO THE END OF IT
THAT OF A -- OF A DISASTER AND I
THINK IT'LL BE MOST INSTRUCTIVE
I'M GONNA FOLLOW I'M TALKING
ABOUT WIRELESS EMERGENCY ALERTS --
AND HIS WAS FROM MINE WHO'S
CHEAP LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL -- FOR
VERIZON'S GOING TO CHAT ABOUT
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE HEARD
EARLIER AND AND TRY TO GIVE THE
CUP THE IDEA.
THAT COMMITTEE A PERSPECTIVE OF
UP ARGUE WITH SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES.
THANK YOU MADAM AND MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AND MISTER CARLSON.
MY NAME IS TODD WATSON I AM IN
NETWORK ENGINEERING AREA MANAGER
WITH A TNT.
AND THE LOCAL RESPONSE CENTER
COORDINATOR FOR ALL NETWORK
PERSONAL ACROSS THE STATE WHEN
DISASTER HITS.
I HAVE WORKED IN NETWORK
DISASTER RECOVERY FOR TWENTY ONE
OF MY TWENTY TWO YEARS WITH
EIGHTEEN T.. FOR THE PAST FIVE
YEARS I'VE WORKED WITH THE LOCAL
RESPONSE CENTER AS THE LEAD
pCOORDINATOR.
WHICH MEANS I ORGANIZE OUR
NETWORK PERSONAL ACROSS THE
STATE AND COORDINATE A RESPONSE
TO KEEP OUR CUSTOMERS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS CONNECTED DURING A
DISASTER.
I MANAGE OPERATIONS INCLUDING
EIGHTEEN TEASE DISASTER
DEPLOYABLE ASSETS AND TECHNICAL
SUPPORT ENGINEERS.
THESE ARE TEAMS IN THE FIELD
DEALING WITH ANY SORT OF HIGHLY
COMPLEX ISSUE.
INCLUDING RESTORING SERVICE
FOLLOWING A VARIETY OF DISASTER
SCENARIOS.
I'M HERE TO TALK TO TODAY ABOUT
WHAT EIGHTEEN T. DOES BEFORE
DURING AND AFTER DISASTER.
INCLUDING WHAT NEW TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCE ADVANCES WE'RE INVESTING.
TO IMPROVE OUR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE.
WE'VE BEEN BUILDING AND MANAGING
AND RESTORING COMMUNICATION
NETWORKS FOR OVER ONE HUNDRED
YEARS.
WE HAVE ONE OF THE LARGEST AND
MOST ADVANCED DISASTER RECOVERY
PROGRAMS IN THE WORLD.
WHEN LOCAL GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
MAKE THE DECISION TO ISSUE
WIRELESS EMERGENCYALERTS?
ARE NETWORK USES SALT BROADCAST
TECHNOLOGY TO NOTIFY ALL MOBILE
DEVICES WITHIN THEIR DESIGNATED
ALERTING AREAS.
TODAY FEMA'S AYE PA SYSTEMS
ALLOWS THESE LOCAL OFFICIALS TO
INCLUDE EMBEDDED HYPERLINKS IN
THERE WE ARE MESSAGES.
CONNECTING CITIZENS WITH
VIRTUALLY AN UNLIMITED AMOUNT OF
ADDITIONAL EMERGENCY INFORMATION.
AND TRADITIONAL LEARNING TOOLS
REMAIN AVAILABLE OVER OUR
WIRELINE NETWORK AS WELL SUCH AS
AUTOMATED CALLS TO HOME PHONES.
AND REGISTERED CELLPHONES
COMMONLY KNOWN AS REVERSE.
NINE ONE ONE EVERY DISASTER IS
DIFFERENT SO WE MUST BE
ADAPTABLE TO ANY NUMBER OF
VARIABLES.
WE BILL THE STATE OF THE ART
NETWORK THE RESILIENT TOO MANY
THINGS TO GET THROWN AT THEM.
WE HAVE ALSO INVESTED MORE THAN
SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN OUR NETWORK DISASTER
RECOVERY PROGRAM.
WHICH IS DESIGNED TO RAPIDLY
RESTORE COMMUNICATIONS TO AREAS
AFFECTED BY DISASTERS. EIGHTEEN
T. IS THE ONLY TELECOM COMPANY
WITH DISASTER RESPONSE PROGRAM
CERTIFIED BY HOMELAND SECURITY.
WE HAVE A FLEET OF MORE THAN
SEVEN HUNDRED PIECES OF NETWORK
RESTORATION EQUIPMENT INCLUDING
OUR CELL ON WHEELS KNOWN AS
CAL'S.
SO ON WINGS KNOWN AS FLYING
HOUSE.
AND SO ON LIGHT TRUCKS KNOWN AS
CALLS.
AS WELL AS COMMAND CENTERS I. P.
RECOVERY TRAILERS HAS MET TRUCKS
GENERATORS AND MARK.
JUST RECENTLY WE'VE INVESTED
OVER ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN A
NEARLY FIFTY FOOT TETHER BLIMP.
KNOWN AS AN AEROSTAT DON'T
PROVIDE FAR REACHING EMERGENCY
WIRELESS COVERAGE TO DISASTER
IMPACTED LOCATIONS.
WE HAVE A STATE OF THE ART
WHETHER OPERATIONS CENTER WITH
OUR OWN METEOROLOGIST.
A GLOBAL NETWORK OPERATIONS
CENTER.
A TEAM OF OVER FORTY DEDICATED
STAFF WHO WORK TO DEPLOY OUR
TEMPORARY ASSETS ON A TWENTY
FOUR BY SEVEN BASIS.
ON TOP OF OUR EXISTING FORCE
READY IN THE FIELD TO HANDLE
ANYTHING THROWN AT THEM.
WE EVEN HAVE OUR OWN HAZMAT TEAM.
OUR RESPONSE PHILOSOPHY IS BASED
ON THE JUST IN TIME RESPONSE
WHEN OUR NETWORK IS IMPACTED.
EVEN THOUGH WE'VE DESIGNED
MULTIPLE LEVELS OF PROTECTION IN
OUR NETWORK THERE ARE EXTREME
ENVIRONMENTAL EVENTS LIKE
HURRICANES.
CATASTROPHIC FIRES WERE FLOODING
THAT WILL DESTROY EVERYTHING IN
THEIR PATH.
WHEN THAT HAPPENS WE HAVE TEAMS
AND EQUIPMENT READY TO MOVE INTO
AN AREA?
AND RESTORE COMMUNICATIONS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
BEFORE DISASTERS HITS WERE
ALREADY IN PREPARATION MODE.
THROUGH OUR WEATHER OPERATIONS
CENTER WERE MONITORING WEATHER
PATTERNS FOR DIFFERENT TYPES OF
WEATHER THREATS HURRICANES
FLOODS WIRE FOUGHT WILD FIRES
ECCENTRIC.
WORKING WITH THE C. U. E. A AND
CALLOW YES AND CAL FIRE TO
MONITOR THREATS AND PROTECT OUR
NETWORK.
IN CALIFORNIA DURING FIRE SEASON
WERE ALSO WORKING DIRECTLY WAS
SEE YOU EA.
THE ASSOCIATION OF UTILITIES
THAT IS EMBEDDED IN CALLOW YES.
TO MONITOR ANY THREATS THE
PUBLIC SAFETY IS MONITORING.
MORE RECENTLY IN CALIFORNIA
WE'RE PROACTIVELY RESPONDING TO
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS BY
STAGING PORTABLE GENERATORS IN
OR NEAR THE POTENTIALLY AFFECTED
SHUT DOWN AREAS.
WHEN WE SEE POTENTIAL THREATS TO
OUR NETWORK WE'RE PREPARING
THROUGH A NUMBER OF WAYS?
TESTING OR BACKUP BATTERIES
LOCATED CELL SITES CENTRAL
OFFICES IN MOBILITY SWITCHING
OFFICES.
STAGING ADDITIONAL PORTER BOWL
GENERATORS FOR ME RESPONSE AND
CHECKING OUR EXISTING FIX
GENERATORS.
TOPPING OFF ALL GENERATORS OF
FUEL CELL SITES IN SWITCHING
FACILITIES.
PERFORMING ALL WATER STOPPING
MATERIALS IS IN PLACE IN CABLE
FALTERED MANTLE'S.
AND SAN BAY USE PLACES WELL.
IT IS NOTED EARLIER USING TOOLS
SUCH AS WE ARE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS ARE ABLE TO WARN OR
EVEN EVACUATE THEIR COMMUNITIES
PRIOR TO IMPENDING THREATS.
WHAT'S THESE ASTOR HITS WE ARE
AN IMMEDIATE RESPONSE MODE WE
WORK DIRECTLY WITH CAL FIRE AND
SEE YOU E. EIGHT TO PROTECT OUR
NETWORK FROM FIRE DAMAGE AS WELL
AS DETERMINE APPROPRIATE MEANS
OF ACCESS. TO THE AFFECTED AREAS.
WE DEPLOYED SAT COLD SOUND LIKE
COLDS TO ANY COVERAGE AREAS
NEEDED.
ACTUATION CENTERS FIRST RESPOND
OR BASE CAMPS STAGING AREAS
EXCEPT.
WE DO THIS ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IN MANY DISASTERS AND WE
DO THIS FREE OF CHARGE.
IF WE DO HAVE NETWORK IMPACTS WE
QUICKLY ASSESS THE NEED AND
DEPLOY THE BEST AND FASTEST
RESOLUTION POSSIBLE.
ADDITIONALLY WE WILL DEPLOYMENT
ANY OTHER ASSETS TO EIGHT OR
NETWORK RECOVERY.
MOBILE CELL SITES MOBILE COMMAND
CENTERS.
EMERGENCY COMMUNICATION VEHICLES
A SELF SUFFICIENT BASE CAMP
SUPPORT TRAILERS.
HAS MEDIC QUITMAN SUPPLIES
TECHNOLOGY IN SUPPORT TRAILERS
AS WELL AS INTERNAL AND EXTERNAL
RESOURCES FOR DAMAGE ASSESSMENT
AND RECOVERY.
WE'RE ALSO BUILDING FIRST DEBT
WHICH IS HELPING FIRST
RESPONDERS BETTER DEAL WITH THE
DISASTERS.
FIRST IT IS A NEW NATIONAL
PUBLIC SAFETY NETWORK THE CAME
OUT OF THE NINE ELEVEN
COMMISSION.
WITH THE GOAL OF HAVING AN
INTEROPERABLE DEDICATED NETWORK
TO FIRST RESPONDERS. EIGHTEEN T.
ONE THE NATIONAL BILL TO BUILD
FIRST THAT SO THIS MEANS A VERY
LOT OF POSITIVE THINGS. FOR
IMPROVED RESPONSE.
EXPANDING ROLE COVERAGE BOTH
THROUGH OUR FIRST NOT BUILD
ANSWER CONNECT AMERICA FUND
BUILD WE'RE ADDING NEW CELL
SITES ACROSS THE STATE IN RURAL
AREAS.
PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES THAT USE
FIRST THAT WILL HAVE PRIORITY
AND PREEMPTION.
MANY OF THE NETWORK BECOMES
CONGESTED DURING A DISASTER
FIRST RESPONDERS WILL HAVE A
PRIORITY.
OVERALL FIRST NOW WILL PROVIDE
FIRST RESPONDERS ACCESS TO
BANDWIDTH AND RELIABLE
CONNECTIONS THEY CAN USE TO
COMMUNICATE.
SHARE INFORMATION AND USE
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGIES.
FIRST THERE IS ALSO NEXT GEN
NINE ONE ONE READY SO TOGETHER
THAT WILL ENABLE CITIES TO MORE
EASILY.
QUICKLY AND RELIABLY CONNECT
FIRST RESPONDERS TO THE INFO AND
CAPABILITIES THEY NEED IN AN
EMERGENCY.
AFTER A DISASTER.
WE HAVE TEAMS OUT IN THE FIELD
ASSESSING AND FIXING DAMAGE AS
SOON AS IT SAFE TO ENTER.
IN MANY CASES THIS IS EVEN
BEFORE THE PUBLIC IS ALLOWED
BACK INTO THE AREA.
ESPECIALLY DURING FIRE SEASON WE
KEEP MORE SUPPLIES ON HAND IN
CALIFORNIA LIKE FIBER REPAIR
EQUIPMENT EXCEPT.
AND AREAS THAT ARE SO BADLY
DAMAGED THEY REQUIRE REBUILD.
WE COORDINATE CLOSELY WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND OTHER
UTILITIES AND WHEREVER FEASIBLE
REBUILD WITH UPGRADED FIBER-NETWORKS.
THIS IS PRECISELY THE CASE
FOLLOWING THE CAMPFIRE WE'RE 93%
OF THE DAMAGED AREA IS BEING
CONVERTED. TO FIVE TO SUM UP WE
HAVE A MULTI PRONGED APPROACH TO
TO DISASTER SITUATIONS. ONE WE
DESIGNED THE MOST RESILIENT
NETWORK WE CAN. TWO WE EMPLOY A
BEST IN CLASS NUMBER DISASTER
RECOVERY AND RESPONSE PROGRAM TO
GET OR KEEP COMMUNICATIONS UP
AND RUNNING. THREE OUR NATION
WIDE NETWORK DISASTER RECOVERY
TEAM AND ASSETS AS WELL AS THE
EXPANDED COVERAGE AND
VERSATILITY OF FIRST THAT.
HELP KEEP FIRST RESPONDERS
CONNECTED DURING A DISASTER.
WE SPEND TENS OF MILLIONS ON
RECOVERY OPERATIONS EVERY YEAR
IN CALIFORNIA AND NO COST TO THE
GOVERNMENT OR TO THE PUBLIC.
FINALLY WE ARE COUNTING I'M
SORRY WE ARE CONTINUING TO
ITERATE AND EXPERIMENT THE
STRESS GET WORSE. TWO GREAT
EXAMPLES ARE FLYING CAL'S
EXTENDING EMERGENCY WIRELESS
COVERAGE VIA DRONE AND SOON VIEW
BLIMP.
I PERSONALLY MEANT DOING NETWORK
DISASTER RECOVERY FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS MYSELF AND OUR
ENTIRE DISASTER RESPONSE IN
NETWORK TEAMS ARE DEDICATED TO
THIS WORK.
AND WE OFTEN DO IT TWENTY FOUR
BY.
SEVEN WE TAKE PROTECTION OF THE
NETWORK AND THE COMMUNICATION
NEEDS OUR FIRST RESPONDERS.
CUSTOMERS AND CITIZENS EXTREMELY
SERIOUSLY PARTICULARLY IN TIMES
OF NEED.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
SPEAK TODAY I LOOK FORWARD TO
QUESTIONS.
MADAM CHAIR MISTER CHAIR --
YOU'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT --
WIRELESS EMERGENCY ALERTS AND WE
ARE TODAY AND I THOUGHT I GO
INTO A LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL --
WITH THAT -- THE WIRELESS
EMERGENCY ALERT SYSTEM IS ONE
TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX OF LOCAL
PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICIALS AND WE
WOULD SUBMIT THE MOST ROBUST
TOOL.
HAS BEEN IN PLACE SINCE.
TWENTY TWELVE IN THE YEARS SINCE
THE LAUNCH OF THE WE A SYSTEM IT
HAS BECOME ONE OF THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMUNITIES MOST
EFFECTIVE MEANS TO TARGET
PRESIDENTIAL IMMINENT THREAT AND
AMBER ALERTS WARNING THE PUBLIC.
OF IMMINENT DANGER SAYS HIS
FLOODS TORNADOES FIRES TERRORIST
EVENTS AND OTHER INCIDENTS.
CITY I'D ITS MEMBER COMPANIES
ARE VERY PROUD OF THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRIES ROLE IN THE WE HAVE
SYSTEM.
TODAY THE NATIONWIDE WIRELESS
PROVIDERS IN MANY REGIONAL
PROVIDER SERVING MORE THAN 99%
OF ALL WIRELESS CUSTOMERS
PARTICIPATE IN THAT WE HAVE
SYSTEM.
IT IS BUILT ON A TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL FORWARD LOOKING
INVOLUNTARY FRAMEWORK
ESTABLISHED BY CONGRESS.
IT ALSO RELIES UPON THE UNIQUE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE FEDERAL
COMMUNICATIONS COMMISSION FEMA.
THE WIRELESS INDUSTRY AND LOCAL
INNER TO RICH -- ALERT
ORIGINATORS WITH A COMMITMENT TO
THE CONTINUE COLLABORATION
ASSESSMENT AND ENHANCEMENT OF WE
ENSURING THAT WE ARE REMAINS A
TRUSTED SOURCE OF EMERGENCY
INFORMATION FOR THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC.
IS WHEN OF CTA'S HIVE PRIORITIES.
WE ARE DEEPLY COMMITTED TO DOING
OUR PART TO ENSURE THAT WE IS
REMAIN A RELIABLE AND EFFECTIVE
TOOL FOR PUBLIC POP PUBLIC
SAFETY.
WITH THAT IN MIND MY TESTIMONY
TODAY ADDRESSES THAT WE HAVE
SAID SOME SUCCESS HIGHLIGHTS AND
HIGHLIGHTS THE COOPERATIVE
FRAMEWORK IN WHICH WE OPERATE.
IN ENCOURAGES THE STATE TO
ENSURE THAT LOCAL ALERT
ORIGINATORS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF WE IS
INCREASINGLY ENHANCE FEATURES.
BY INCORPORATING WE A BEST
PRACTICES INTO THEIR EMERGENCY
ALERTING PROCEDURES THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT.
SINCE WE ARE LOST IN TWENTY
TWELVE MORE THAN FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND WIRELESS EMERGENCY
ALERTS HAVE BEEN SENT BY OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY PARTNERS TO SAVE
LIVES.
THE WE SYSTEM HAS QUICKLY BECOME
A CRITICAL RESOURCE FOR THE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS WHO RELY ON MOBILE
PHONES EVERY DAY.
AND NOTABLY WE A MESSAGES SENT
DURING RECENT WILDFIRES IN
CALIFORNIA.
DID HELP PEOPLE AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES TO SAFETY.
WE ARE MESSAGES OUR TECHS LIKE
EMERGENCY ALERT AND WARNING
MESSAGES SENT BY NATIONAL STATE
AND LOCAL PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICIALS CALLED ALERT
ORIGINATORS. TO WE A CABLE
MOBILE HANDSETS.
WE USE UTILIZE A PURPOSE BUILT
SELL BROADCAST TECHNOLOGY THAT
UNLIKE TEXT MESSAGES OFFERED BY
WHITES PROVIDERS LIKE A SHORT
MESSAGE SERVICE.
OR OTHER OVER THE TOP MESSAGING
SERVICES HAS BEEN DESIGNED TO
SIMULTANEOUSLY DISTRIBUTE A
MESSAGE TO AS MANY WIRELESS
HANDSETS AS POSSIBLE.
USING THESE TECHNOLOGIES WE CAN
BE GEOGRAPHICALLY TARGETED TWO
AREAS CHOSEN BY LOCAL PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICIALS.
ARE TIMELY DELIVERED AND AVOID
NETWORK CONGESTION ISSUES.
AS DISCUSSED IN GREATER DETAIL
LATER THEME - AUTHORIZES ALERT
ORIGINATORS INCLUDING NATIONAL
STATE AND LOCAL PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICIALS TO SEND WE AS ABOUT
IMMINENT THREATS ARE AMBER
ALERTS.
ALL WIRELESS CONSUMERS WITH WE
ARE CAPABLE HANDSETS CAN RECEIVE
MESSAGES UNLESS CONSUMERS OPT
OUT OF RECEIVING IMMINENT THREAT
RAMBLER MESSAGES.
IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE THAT MANY
OF THE OTHER LOCAL ALERT --
FUNCTIONS ARE OPT IN WHICH AS HE
IS CREATED SOME SOME ISSUES AND
THEN LAYERING IT WITH WE IS.
IS CLEARLY THE BEST THE BEST WAY
TO PROCEED.
THROUGH COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS
THE WIRELESS INDUSTRY HAS WORKED
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
LOCAL ALERT ORIGINATORS TO
ENHANCE WE ARE WITHIN THE
CONTOURS OF THE PURPOSE BILL
CAPABILITIES.
THESE EFFORTS HAVE RESULTED IN A
WITH A SYSTEM THAT ENABLES LOCAL
LEARNED ORIGINATORS TO IN BED A
LINK TO A WEBSITE AND THIS WAS A
MENTION BY -- BY MSTER WHAT'S
IN IT AND SOME OF THE EARLIER
pTHAT OFFERS CONSUMERS MULTI
LINGUAL AND MULTI MEDIA CONTENT
AND ENABLES MORE GRANULAR
TARGETING BELOW THE COUNTY LEVEL
FOR LOCAL LEARNING OFFICIALS
CHOSEN GEOGRAPHIC AREAS.
WHILE THIS INDUSTRY IS ALSO
WORKING TO SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
ENHANCEMENTS REQUIRED BY THE FCC
SUCH AS SUPPORT FOR SPANISH
LANGUAGE EXPANDED MESSAGE
CONTENT LINKS OFTEN TESTING FOR
LOCAL ALERT ORIGINATORS.
AND EVEN MORE GRANULAR GEO
TARGETING CAPABILITIES.
BUT CONTINUE TO ENHANCE ITS
FEATURES LOCAL ALERT ORIGINATORS
ARE INCREASINGLY INCORPORATED
THE PROVEN LIFESAVING
CAPABILITIES OF WE ARE INTO
THEIR EMERGENCY.
A LEARNING TOOL KIT.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
WHILE THE WIRELESS INDUSTRY
CONTINUES TO ENHANCE THE WE
ASSISTANCE CAPABILITIES.
WE ARE IS A LOCALLY DRIVEN
EMERGENCY LEARNING TOOL AND NOT
SURE THAT THAT NECESSARILY COME
THROUGH WITH OUR CONVERSE IN OUR
CONVERSATIONS.
WE ARE MESSAGES ARE DEVELOPED
TARGETED AND SENT BY THE LOCAL
ALERT ORIGINATORS WHO KNOW BEST
HOW TO ADVISE LOCAL RESIDENTS
AND VISITORS HOW TO ACT ON
INFORMATION ABOUT EMERGENCY.
AT A NATIONAL LEVEL WIRELESS
EMERGENCY ALERTS ARE PART OF OUR
BROADER NATION NATIONAL LEARNING
SYSTEM KNOWN AS IPODS MANAGED BY
FEMA -- I PAUSE AUTHORIZED
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
AUTHORITIES WHO ARE THE ALERT
ORIGINATORS TRANSMIT EMERGENCY
MESSAGES TO A FEMALE OPERATED
SYSTEM.
STEVE STEVENS SYSTEM BUT THEN A
CASE AND FORMATS THE MESSAGE FOR
DISTRIBUTION ACROSS A VARIETY OF
CHANNELS INCLUDING THE WITH A
SYSTEM.
WIRELESS PROVIDERS PARTICIPATING
IN THE WITH A SYSTEM SEND THE
MESSAGES AUTHORIZED BY FEMA TO
THE TARGET AREA IDENTIFIED BY
THE LOCAL ALERT ORIGINATOR.
WITHOUT INPUT INTO THE CONTENT
OF MESSAGE BOARD DISCRETION OVER
WHETHER OR NOT TO TRANSMIT IT.
IS COMPLETELY UP TO THE
DISCRETION OF AUTHORIZED FEDERAL
STATE OR LOCAL ALERT ORIGINATORS
TO DO HER TERM IN THE CONTENT OF
A WITH A MESSAGE.
AND TO INDICATE THE TARGETED
GEOGRAPHIC AREA.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
CONTINUE TO ENSURE LOCAL ALERT
ORIGINATORS HAVE ACCESS TO
COMPLETE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
SYSTEM.
AND THE TO THE BUT TOOLS
AVAILABLE TO THEM IN TIMES OF
EMERGENCY INCLUDING FOR EXAMPLE.
GEOGRAPHIC TARGETING BELOW THE
COUNTY LEVEL AND BETTING LINKS
TO THE MULTI MEDIA OR MULTILINK
WILL CONTACT.
CITY I IN THE WIRELESS INDUSTRY
ARE PROUD OF THE CRITICAL ROLE
THAT WE A PLACE IN THE NATION'S
EMERGENCY ALERT SYSTEM.
AND ARE COMMITTED TO CONTINUING
TO WORK COLLABORATIVELY WITH
PUBLIC SAFETY PROFESSIONALS AT
EVERY LEVEL TO MAINTAIN SYSTEM
INTEGRITY AND PUBLIC CONFIDENCE
AND WIRELESS EMERGENCY ALERTS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S HAS WHO
FROM ON I AM TO PLEDGE SLATED
COUNSEL WITH VERIZON AND BEFORE.
BEGAN ON MY PREPARED REMARKS I
FIRST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
ALL THE FIRST RESPONDERS FOR ALL
THEY DO -- I THINK WE FAIL TO DO
THAT SO FAR TODAY AND AND THEY
THEY REALLY HAVE A BIG JOB ON ON
THEIR HANDS -- I ALSO WANTED --
TO COLOR FIVE POINT THE
PRESIDENT PICKER MADE -- I I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WHEN
YOU IDENTIFY COMPANIES YOU
IDENTIFY THEM CORRECTLY -- AND
WHEN HE WAS SPEAKING ABOUT
SERVICE QUALITY ISSUES AND HELP
POORLY -- A I'M A PARTICULAR
ENTITY WAS PERFORMING -- HE
IDENTIFIED THAT ENTITY AS
VERIZON FRONTIER -- THAT
ENTITIES NOT VERIZON FRONTIER
THAT ENTITY IS FRONT HERE -- NOT
NOT VERIZON SO I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT SO.
I WILL -- ALSO STATE THAT --
WITH REGARDS TO THE INFORMATION
THAT WE'VE HEARD -- REGARDING
REDUNDANCY -- I'VE RECENTLY
PARTICIPATED AT THE POND --
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS TASK
FORCE -- AND WE DISCUSSED THE
ISSUE OF REDUNDANCY -- AND OF
THE ISSUE OF SIRENS CAME UP COM
AND THERE COULD SERIOUSLY
CONSIDERING ADOPTING AND AND
IMPLEMENTING A SIREN BASED
SYSTEM.
NOT ONE SYSTEM IS GOING TO DO
EVERYTHING FOR EVERYONE AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S ONE ELEMENT
THAT WE NEED.
TO KEEP IN MIND AND I APPLAUD
THE THE CHAIR WOMAN AND HER --
SUPPORT FOR SIRENS AND EVERYONE
ELSE WHO DOES -- SO THE
BACKGROUND PAPER THAT WAS THE
THE DEVELOPED IN AND OUT SENT
AROUND.
ESSENTIALLY AND WHAT THE CAR
EARLIER PANELS HAVE DISCUSSES
THAT -- THE ONE OF THE VARIABLES
THAT IMPACTS -- THE ABILITY TO
PROPERLY ALERT RESIDENCES THE
OUTAGES THAT HAPPENED WITH
WIRELESS COMMUNICATIONS AND
OTHER COMMUNICATIONS RIGHT --
THERE ARE FOR SURE MANY OTHERS
INCLUDING THE RELUCTANCE OF SOME
OF THE LOCAL AUTHORITIES TO PUSH
ALERTS. TO LARGER GROUPS OF
RESIDENTS -- THAT WAS DISCUSSED
ALSO IN ONE OF THE PANELS.
BUT TO PUT THAT IN CONTEXT I
WANT TO SAY THAT VERIZON -- TO
AS EIGHTEEN T. MENTIONING GAUGES
AND SIGNIFICANT EMERALD BUST --
DISASTER PREPAREDNESS BY
CREATING A RESILIENT NETWORK WE
DO HAVE WE DONE THE C. FEATURES
THAT INCLUDE RING CONFIGURATION --
WE ALSO -- PROVIDE BATTERY
BACKUP AND GENERATOR BACKUP
POWER TO VIRTUALLY ALL OF OUR
MACRO SITES.
WHERE LOCAL BUILDING CODES IN
SPACE -- SPACING AVAILABILITY
ALLOWS IT VERIZON EQUIPS ITS
MACRO SITES WITH GENERATORS THAT
HAVE -- TWENTY FOUR TO SEVENTY
TWO HOURS OF BACKUP POWER.
THAT CAN BE REVIEW -- FOR MACRO
SITES THAT CANNOT HAVE
GENERATORS FOR A SLEW OF
DIFFERENT REGULATORY OR LEGAL
RESTRICTIONS -- WE DEPLOYED
BATTERY ARRAYS TO HAVE A MINIMUM
OF EIGHT HOURS OF BATTERY.
OF THAT BATTERY GETS DEPLETED
DURING A POWER SHUT OFF EITHER
BECAUSE OF A DISASTER OR BECAUSE
IT'S A PROACTIVE -- ONE WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO THEN DEPLOYED
GENERATORS WE HAVE SUFFICIENT
GENERATORS AND IN THOSE
SITUATIONS WHERE A GENERATOR IS
NOT WORKING PROPERLY WE ALSO CAN
GO TO VENDORS AND AND GET
GENERATORS FROM VENDORS.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT AS WE WERE
DISCUSSING THE BATTERY BACK UP
AND THERE WAS SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS AFTER ME
INCREASE BATTERY BACKUP -- AT
MACRO SITES THAT WE TAKE A STEP
BACK AND REMEMBER THAT THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN AND TWO THOUSAND EIGHT FOR
TWO YEAR STUDY THE ISSUE OF
BACKUP POWER.
THE ISSUE DATE THREE HUNDRED AND
THREE HUNDRED EIGHT PAGE
RELIABILITY STANDARDS REPORT --
AND IN CONJUNCTION WITH A THIRD
PARTY CONSULTANT THAT THEY HAD
CALLED TELCORDIA.
AND THAT OUR REPORT CONCLUDED
THAT THE REALITY IS THAT
INCREASING BATTERY CAPACITY IN
FUEL SUPPLIES AT NETWORK
FACILITIES.
WILL NOT PRODUCE A SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION IN THE RISK DURING
MASS OF EVENTS THAT'S A COLD --
SUCH AS NATURAL DISASTERS THEY
HAVE BEEN KNOWN TO THE
COMMISSION FOR OVER A DECADE --
THE THAT STANDARD BUT THAT
RELIABILITY STANDARDS REPORT
FOUND THAT IN 2000888% OF
CALIFORNIA.
CELL SITES HAD BATTERY BACKUP
POWER OR BACKUP POWER IN ONE
MANNER OR ANOTHER.
AND THAT'S A PERCENTAGE THAT
ALMOST -- IS SURELY HAS
INCREASED SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THE
RELIABILITY STANDARDS REPORT
RECOGNIZE THAT IT IS UNFORTUNATE
BUT INEVITABLE THAT
COMMUNICATIONS WILL BE SEVERELY
DISRUPTED DURING MASSIVE NATURAL.
DISASTERS.
AND THAT INCREASING BATTERY
CAPACITY OR FUEL SUPPLIES.
WILL NOT PRODUCE A SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION IN RISK IN THESE
MASSIVELY BATHS.
THE RELIABILITY STANDARDS REPORT
WENT ON TO SAY THAT THE
DESTRUCTIVE NATURE NATURE OF THE
DISASTER EVENTS.
WILL DEFINITELY RESULT IN LOSS
OF COMMUNICATIONS FACILITIES NOT
JUST WIRELESS FACILITIES.
AND GIVEN THAT FINDING IT
CONCLUDED THAT RATHER THAN
ENHANCE.
THE ALREADY EXISTING LEVEL OF
NETWORK FACILITIES REDUNDANCY.
THE FOCUS FOR RESILIENCY SHOULD
BE PLACED.
ON ROLL ROLL BUST NETWORK
RECOVERY AND RESTORATION PLANS.
SO UNDERSTANDING THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE OUTAGES -- EVEN
WITH A BACKUP POWER IN SOME
REDUNDANT -- FEATURES SUCH AS
RING CONFIGURATIONS -- AND WE
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT AVERAGES
ARE FREQUENTLY NOT CAUSED BY
BACKUP POWER DEPLETION.
BUT RATHER THE DESTRUCTION OF
BACK CALL AND TRANSPORT
FACILITIES ON BY OTHER PROVIDERS.
VERIZON'S RESPONSE UNNECESSARILY
TURNS TO PLANNING FOR TEMPORARY
ASSETS AND THE USE OF TEMPORARY
ASSETS.
SO THIS WAS DISCUSSED EARLIER
AND I THINK WHEN YOU TAKE A
PAUSE ON IT IS.
THAT THE WIRELESS COMMUNICATIONS
NETWORK HAS BEEN DEPLOYED IN A
MANNER THAT IS COMPLEX -- AND
HAS MANY FEATURES AND IN TIRE
SORT OF TELECOMMUNICATIONS
NETWORK IS THAT WAY CELL TOWERS
ARE CELL TOWERS BUT THEY HAVE TO
HAVE BACK CALL THAT BACK HALL IS
NOT PROVIDED BY AT LEAST VERIZON
DOES NOT PROVIDE ITS OWN BACK
CALL.
IT LEASES THATFROM OTHER
COMPANIES SUCH AS EIGHTEEN T. OR
THE CABLE COMPANIES ARE FRONT
TIER.
AND SUCH WHEN WE'VE WORKS
PERRANCE SAID OUT OF OUT AGES --
IT HAS BEEN BECAUSE OF THE BACK
HALL PRIMARILY BECAUSE OF THE
DESTRUCTION OF BACKHAUL SO
BATTERY BACKUP REALLY WAS NOT AN
ISSUE IN THOSE SITUATIONS.
WHEN THE NEED ARISES VERIZON
PROVIDES TEMPORARY ASSETS
SWELLING EXPEDITIONS IS IT'S
EXPEDITIOUSLY RESTORE SERVICE?
WE COLLABORATE CLOSELY WITH FEMA
WITH THE STATE AND LOCAL
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT OFFICES
FIRST RESPONDERS. TO DEPLOY OUR
TEMPORARY ASSETS WHERE THEY CAN
ACHIEVE.
THE GREATEST IMPACT.
DISASTER RESPONSE DECISIONS ARE
ACTUALLY COMPLEX AND DO DEPEND
ON MANY FACTORS.
THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE A FAST
TAILORED AND EFFECTIVE SOLUTION
REALLY IS THE KEY.
SO WHEN WE ARE CALLED UPON TO
EMERGENCY WE REVIEW THE
SITUATION TO DETERMINE THE BEST
PATH FOR ENSURING.
THAT APPROPRIATE SERVICE UNDER
THOSE EMERGENCY CIRCUMSTANCES IS
MADE AVAILABLE TO FIRST
RESPONDERS. TO PUBLIC SAFETY
ENTITIES AND COMMUNITY.
AMONG THE OTHER THINGS TO
VERIZON CRISIS RESPONSE TEAM
CAREFULLY CONSIDERS TO SITE WERE
DEPLOYABLE UNITS WOULD ADDRESS
CAPACITY AND SOUND QUALITY
ISSUES.
AND OR WHETHER ANOTHER SOLUTION
IS MORE APPROPRIATE.
IN SOME CASES I THINK WE WANT
POTS ON THIS AND FOCUS ON THIS A
DEPLOYABLE MOBILE WIRELESS UNIT
COULD ACTUALLY DEGRADE.
THE QUALITY OF SERVICE INSTEAD
OF ENHANCING IT.
BY INTERFERING WITH SERVICE FROM
PERMANENT FACILITIES THAT DO
REMAIN OPERATIONAL.
A TEMPORARY ACID AS ACTUALLY
UNNECESSARY MANY SITUATIONS
BECAUSE OF OUR EXISTING NETWORK
FACILITIES.
THERE EITHER SUFFICIENT OR WE
CAN MODIFY THEM ON THE SPOT
FASTER THAN ACTUALLY DEPLOYING.
A TEMPORARY FACILITY.
SO WE WILL MODIFY AND CONFIGURE
EXISTING CELL SITES TO ADD
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY TO RESTORE
IMPROVE SERVICE.
INSTEAD OF MOVING TEMPORARY
UNITS TO A TO A PARTICULAR SITE.
WE HAVE FOUND THAT THE LABOR
AGAIN REQUIRED TO CONFIGURE
EXISTING CELL SITES OFTEN ABOUT
THE SAME AS THE TIME THAT WOULD
TAKE. FOR US TO GET A DEPLOYABLE
UNIT UP AND WORKING.
AND THIS HAS BEEN HELPFUL SO FOR
EXAMPLE DURING THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WILDFIRES WE DEPLOYED.
TWENTY NINE DEPLOYABLE ASSETS
ARE CONFIGURED AND MANY OTHER OF
OUR EXISTING CELL SITES.
SUCH THAT 97% OF OUR NETWORK WAS
OPERATING LIKE NORMAL IN THE
FIRST WEEK OF THE FIRES.
AND 1100% OF THE NETWORK WAS
BACK TO NORMAL BY DAY.
SEVEN AND IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WE I HAVE MANY EXAMPLES
I KNOW WE'RE SHORT ON TIME.
BUT I'LL JUST SAY THAT IN TERMS
OF THE BUTTE.
CALLIE FIRE THE CAMPFIRE -- WE
REPAIRED AS AS THE DAMAGED FIBER
WAS BEING REPAIRED.
OUR ENGINEERS ADDED CAPACITY --
AT HIM RESTOREDSITES -- TO I
HAVE A FIVE DIFFERENT SITES THAT
WERE CRITICAL SITES.
ARE WE MOVED TO A TEMPORARY
NETWORK ASSETS WE HAVEN'T LOOKED
ARE CALLED MOBILE COMMUNICATION
TRAILERS. TO CAROL YES IS BASE
CAMP IN CHICO MUNICIPAL AIRPORT.
ALSO AT THE BUTTE FIRE CENTER
MEDALLION -- AT PARADISE POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
AND STATION EIGHTY ONE IN
PARADISE WE HAD COLDS IN CAL'S
IN OTHER WHAT WE CALL FARM
ANIMALS SOON -- THAT WE DEPLOYED
FOR HELP.
WE DID SO TO ALSO WITH THE WORST%
WOLSELEY FIRE IN THE LA INVENTOR
COUNTIES -- WE GOT OUR ENGINEERS
WORKING TWENTY FOUR SEVEN TO
RESTORE SERVICE TO THE IMPACTED
AREASAS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
WE DEPLOYED MOBILE COMMUNICATION
TRAILERS ALSO TO STE TO FIRE
STATION SEVENTY ONE IN MALIBU
SEVENTY TWO MALIBU NINETY NINE
IN MALIBU.
CAPTURE TEEN IN THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS A COLD IN OAK PARK
THEY CALL TO MALIBU BLUFFS AND
POINT DOOM AND EIGHTEEN PORTABLE
GENERATORS WERE DEPLOYED.
ARE WE PROVIDED ON GOING SUPPORT
SO WE DON'T JUST HELP ALL WITH
GETTING COMMUNICATIONS BACK UP
WE ALSO HELP OUT THE EVACUEES
THAT ARE AT SHELTERS OR
EVACUATION CENTERS BY PROVIDING
INTERNET CONNECTED.
LAPTOPS PHONES IN CELL PHONE
CHARGING THAT IS A BACK YOU
ATION CENTERS.
WE WORK WELL WITH CAL -- YES WE
WORK WELL WITH LOCAL --
EMERGENCY OFFICES.
ARE IN THE THOMAS FIRE FOR
EXAMPLE -- WHICH IMPACT OF
INSURANCE SANTA BARBARA COUNTIES
WITHIN THE FIRST HOURS OF THAT
FIRE VERIZON WAS ON THE GROUND
TO PROVIDE THE NECESSARY.
EMERGENCY SERVICES WHICH INCLUDE
THE MOBILE DEPLOYABLE AS WE
DISCUSSED WE STOOD SIDE BY SIDE
WITH THE EMERGENCY RESPONDERS.
RESPONDERS WE EMBEDDED OUR FOLKS
IT AT THE VENTURA COUNTY.
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER AND
WE HELPED AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
[inaudible]
IN CONCLUSION.
WE DON'T STOP AND REST ABOUT
THIS WE'RE ALWAYS LOOKING WAYS
TO IMPROVE.
ARM INDEED OUR WORK JUST DOESN'T
END.
WE CONTINUE TO FIND THOSE HUESO
FOR EXAMPLE.
RISING IS LEADING THE CHARGE
RIGHT NOW TO INNOVATE IN THE WAY --
WE CAN FIND YOU USE CASES TO
FURTHER SUPPORT FIRST RESPONDERS
AND ENHANCE SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS TO NOVEMBER OF LAST
YEAR WE ANNOUNCED THAT WE WOULD
PARTNER WITH A COMPANY CALLED
RESPONDER CORP -- TO LAUNCH AN
INCUBATOR PROP PROGRAM DESIGNED
TO GIVE START UPS AND OTHER
INNOVATORS ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY
TO DEVELOP TEST AND REFINE NEW
SOLUTIONS.
AND FROM THERE WERE GETTING -- A
CLASS OF NEW.
UP POSSIBILITIES ARE THINGS THAT
WOULD USE AUGMENTED REALITIES TO
ALLOW FIREFIGHTERS TO SEE IN
SMOKE FILLED ZERO VISIBILITY AND
HAZARDOUS ENVIRONMENTS -- AND IT
GOES ON AND ON SO I WILL STOP
THERE BECAUSE I KNOW WE DON'T
HAVE THAT MUCH TIME.
CAROLINE'S YOUR TURN
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THIS HEARING TODAY MISTER
CHAIRMAN I THANK YOU BOTH FOR
BEING HERE TO HEAR FROM THE
COMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY -- WITH
SINCE WE HAVE ALL THESE NATURAL
DISASTERS OVER THE LAST THREE
YEARS THERE'S REALLY SEEMS TO BE
A LOT OF MISREPRESENTATIONS
ABOUT WHAT.
THE COMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY IS
DOING NOT DOING ARE CAPABLE OF
DOING.
SO I'VE GIVEN THE LATE HOUR
TODAY I WANT TO BE VERY FOCUSED
IN MY COMMENTS IN TALK ABOUT
WHAT THE CABLE INDUSTRY.
IS DOING BUT OUR RESPONSIBILITY
AS AND WHERE WE ARE IN A
POSITION TO PARTNER.
WITH FIRST RESPONDERS THE AND
WITH -- LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FIRST
OF ALL STARTING WITH A CABLE
NETWORK -- YOU'VE ALL RECEIVED
I'M SURE THOSE EMERGENCY ALERTS
THAT ARE VERY KNOWING THEY COME
OVER YOU'RE TELEVISION THERE
OFTEN IS THAT WRITING ON THE
SCREEN OR CALL ON THE BOTTOM OF
THE SCREEN.
AND THEY ARE GENERALLY
ACCOMPANIED BY A SOMEWHAT
ANNOYING NOISE IN ORDER TO GET
YOUR ATTENTION.
THOSE ARE THE FEDERAL ALERTS
THAT WE ISSUE PERCENT WENT -- TO
A PRESIDENTIAL ORDER.
AND THEY ARE GENERALLY USED IN
CASES THAT A NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
AT THE STATE LEVEL WE DO HAVE AN
EMERGENCY ALERT SYSTEM WHERE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS ACTUALLY
PUT TOGETHER AN EMERGENCY PLAN.
THAT DOES IN FACT INCLUDE A ROLE
FOR THE COMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY
WITH BOTH THE STATE AND WITH THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS.
SO WE WILL IN FACT ISSUE AN
EMERGENCY ALERT BASED ON A
DIRECTIVE FROM THE GOVERNOR.
THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICE SAYS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS.
THOSE ARE DELIVERED OVER THE
CABLE NETWORK SIMILAR TO
BROADCAST TELEVISION AND RADIO --
I DO WANT TO MAKE THE POINT THAT
THOSE ALERTS DON'T GO OUT OVER A
STREAMING VIDEO SERVICE LIKE A
NETFLIX AS YOU KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE DOING WHAT WE CALL
CUTTING THE CORD.
IF THEY HAPPEN TO BE WATCHING A
SERVICE THAT IS WHAT WE CALL AN
OVER THE TOP SERVICE LIKE IN
HULU OR NETFLIX.
THE A WILL NOT RECEIVE THAT
EMERGENCY ALERT.
SO -- I WANT TO MOVE IN TIME NOW
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT VOICE OVER
INTERNET PROTOCOL OR LATE
SERVICE.
AND I WANT TO START WITH TALKING
ABOUT THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
INTERCONNECTED VOIGTS AND NO
MATTER VOIGTS.
THE BACKGROUND DOCUMENT FOR THIS
HEARING TODAY.
A DISCUSSED VOID AS ONE
TECHNOLOGY THERE IS A DIFFERENCE.
SIXTY INTERCONNECTED VOID
ACTUALLY PROVIDE YOU A DIRECT
CONNECTION TO YOUR HOME.
THE FCC DOES IN FACT REQUIRE ALL
VOID PROVIDERS TO GIVE YOU THE
ABILITY TO CALL 911- THE
DIFFERENCE THE MAIN DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN INTERCONNECTED VOID BUT
NO MATTER FLOYD IS THAT YOU CAN
TAKE NOMADIC VOIGHT.
FROM ONE LOCATION TO ANOTHER
IT'S LIKE A BONDAGE SURVEYS OR
MAGIC JACK SERVICE SO YOU MAY
NOT HAVE AN ADDRESS THAT IS
DIRECTLY CONNECTED TO THAT
PARTICULAR DEVICE.
WHEREAS WITH INTERCONNECTED
VOICE WHICH IS THE THE SERVICE
THAT'S PROVIDED BY -- MY
MEMBERSHIP AT THE ASSOCIATION.
WHEN A CALL IS PLACED TO NINE
ONE ONE THE INFORMATION THE NAME
THE CUSTOMER'S ADDRESS IS IN
FACT PROVIDED TO THE PUBLIC
SAFETY ANSWERING POINTS?
I THINK THERE HAS BEEN SOME
MISUNDERSTANDING THAT THAT
INFORMATION DOES NOT GO TO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY ANSWERING POINTS.
FOR INTER CONNECTED V<c.cyan> IT</c>
DOES GO TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
ANSWERING POINTS.
SO IT ALSO HAS THE ABILITY TO
DELIVER THE REVERSE NINE ONE ONE
ALERTS NOW THE DIFFERENCE THERE
IS IS THAT A PERSON DOES IN FACT
NEED TO REGISTER.
THEIR TELEPHONE NUMBER AND THEIR
LOCATION WITH THEIR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IN ORDER TO RECEIVE
THE REVERSE NINE ONE ONE ALERT.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT WE ARE
SIMPLY THE DELIVERY PLATFORM.
WE DON'T DETERMINE WHEN THOSE
ALERTS ARE ISSUED WITHOUT
DETERMINE WHAT THE MESSAGING AS
WE SIMPLY DELIVER.
THE CALL AS WE ARE ASKED TO DO
EITHER DIRECTLY BY THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OR THE THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR THAT THEY MAY HAVE --
OVERSEEING THE PROGRAM FOR THEM.
CUSTOMERS ALSO HAVE THE ABILITY
TO RECEIVE AN AIM ADD ADD ALERT
VIA EMAIL -- BUT THAT TOO WOULD
REQUIRE THEM TO REGISTER WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT THEIR EMAIL
ADDRESS SO THAT THEY CAN IN FACT
RECEIVE THOSE NOTIFICATIONS BY
EMAIL.
SO.
I WANT TO MOVE ON NOW AND TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE GUIDELINES
THAT -- YES PUT TOGETHER FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT -- THERE'S A
FEW AREAS WHERE WE BELIEVE THAT
THE GUIDELINES ARE ACTUALLY IN
NEED OF SOME CLARIFICATION --
THE GUIDELINES WERE ACTUALLY PUT
OUT AND WE WERE ALLOWED TO VIEW
THAT ONCE THE DRAFT WAS OUT WE
DID PROVIDE TO ME M. PUT -- TO
YES WE DON'T BELIEVE IT WAS
INCORPORATED HOWEVER WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT THE GUIDELINES ARE
CLEAR AS TO WHAT THE ROLE OF THE
VOID BIZ AND DELIVERING
EMERGENCY ALERTS.
WE DO BELIEVE THAT COULD BE
CLEARER IN THE GUIDELINES --
THERE ARE ALSO PLACES IN THE
GUIDELINES WHERE THEY RECOMMEND
I AM.
TRAINING ON THE CAPABILITIES A
CERTAIN TECHNOLOGY THEY
SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFY THE
INTERNET BUT WE WOULD SUGGEST
THAT THAT TRAINING SHOULD APPLY
ACROSS THE BOARD TO ALL
PLATFORMS THAT MAY BE USED IN
THE DELIVERY OF AN EMERGENCY
ALERT.
SO THAT YOU UNDERSTAND -- THE
THE CAPABILITY OF THE TECHNOLOGY
FOR EXAMPLE I WHAT I MENTIONED
EARLIER WITH REGARDS TO THE
DELIVERY OF AN EMERGENCY ALERT
OVER STREAMING VIDEO SERVICE
IT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
AND AND THE ISSUING AUTHORITY
SHOULD BE AWARE OF THAT WHEN
THEY ISSUE THAT ALERT.
THEY SHOULD ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT
THEY SHOULD BE TESTING THE
SYSTEMS AT A TIME WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THAT EITHER IS
CLEAR.
I'M IN THE ALERTS.
MOVING TO A GENERALIZATION.
SO BECAUSE THE CABLE SYSTEMS
RELY ON ELECTRICITY TO OPERATE
OR VIDEO OR VOICE IN OUR
INTERNET SYSTEMS WE ARE IMPACTED
WITH ELECTRICITY GOES OUT
WHETHER IT'S DE ENERGIZED
INTENTIONALLY OR OTHERWISE.
THAT WOULD ALSO IMPACT THE
ABILITY OF OUR ABILITY TO ISSUE
ALERTS. TO PREPARE FOR THE LOSS
OF POWER THAT CAN IMPACT THE
ABILITY TO TRANSMIT EMERGENCY
NOTIFICATIONS CABLE OPERATORS.
DO IN FACT COMPLY WITH STATE AND
FEDERAL LAWS TO OFFER OUR
CUSTOMERS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PURCHASE A BACKUP BATTERY --
THOSE NOTIFICATIONS ARE PROVIDED
TO THEM UPON THE INITIATION OF
SERVICE AND THEY ARE THERE AFTER
PROVIDED TO THE KIDS CUSTOMER AT
ANNUALLY.
THE BATTERY.
IS EQUIPPED IN THE BATTERY
PROVIDES ENOUGH ENERGY IN ORDER
TO ALLOW THE VOICE SERVICE TO
CONTINUE TO OPERATE. FOR EIGHT
HOURS OR TWENTY FOUR HOURS
DEPENDING ON THE BATTERY CHARLES
AND BY BAY CUSTOMER.
SO WE ALSO HAVE BACKUP POWER
THAT IS MAINTAINED AT KEY CABLE
FACILITIES SUCH AS OUR HEAD INS
ARE HAVES ARE NOTES.
AND WE DEPEND ON THAT BATTERY
BACKUP IN ORDER TO KEEP THE
NETWORKS UP AND RUNNING THERE
MAY BE TIMES WHERE WE ALSO HAVE
TO DEPEND ON GENERATORS TO KEEP
THE NETWORKS UP AND RUNNING.
BUT I WANT TO MAKE A POINT ABOUT
GENERATORS IF YOU HAVE A PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF BECAUSE OF
THE WIND.
I THINK WE SHOULD THINK TWICE
ABOUT RENTING GENERATORS GAS
FIELD GENERATORS.
AND THOSE SAME CONDITIONS.
I'M YOU DON'T WANT TO PERPETUATE
THE PROBLEM OR SHIFT THE PROBLEM
I SHOULD SAY.
FROM A ONE INDUSTRY TO THE OTHER
BY REQUIRING THE READING OF
GENERATORS AND WEATHER
CONDITIONS THAT ARE NOT
CONDUCIVE TO SUCH.
SO IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE.
ADLER'S ADVERSELY IMPACT VARIOUS
SERVICES INCLUDING THE PLAIN OLD
TELEPHONE NETWORK THAT WE'VE ALL
BECOME SO COMFORTABLE WITH
VENDOR.
WITH BELIEVING THAT IT'S ALWAYS
GOING TO BE AVAILABLE IF IN FACT
THE THE PHONE OPERATES WITH
ELECTRICITY AS MANY OF THEM DO
THOSE OF US THAT STILL HAVE FONG
HOME PHONES PROBABLY HAVE THAT
PORTABLE PHONE.
THAT ALLOWS YOU TO WALK AWAY
FROM THE BASE THAT PORTABLE
PHONE IS ALSO DEPENDED UPON
ELECTRICITY.
SO AND TO THE EXTENT THAT FEE
POWER GOES OUT ATTY CENTRAL
STATION OR REMOTE OFFICE THE
LAND LINE IS ALSO GOING TO BE
OUT.
SO WHAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT BACKUP
POWER HELPS ENSURE THAT THE
MESSAGES ARE DELIVERED.
THE EXTENT OF A DISASTER WILL
DICTATE WHETHER OR NOT BACK AT
POWDER IS EFFICIENT OR WHATEVER
THAT WORK HAS BEEN SEVERELY
DAMAGED IS MAKING AND MAKING AT
NON SERVICEABLE AND TELL REPAIRS
CAN BE COMPLETED.
SO THE GUIDELINES THE YES
GUIDELINE SHOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
THERE MAY BE CIRCUMSTANCES.
WHERE DISASTER DESTROYED ALL
COMMUNICATIONS AND ELECTRIC
INFRASTRUCTURE AND RELIANCE ON
OTHER TOOLS FOR EMERGENCY NOTICE?
SUCH AS SIRENS AND MEGAPHONES AS
HAS BEEN MENTIONED HERE EARLIER
TODAY MAY BE NECESSARY.
SO THANK YOU I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THERE'S A COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU MY NAME IS AUGUST GILL
I AM THE DIRECTOR OF EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT FOR SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC AND FOR SOME BCKGROUND
I I SPENT OVER THIRTY SIX YEARS
OF THE FIRE SERVICE.
RETIRED AS A FIRE CHIEF IN A
SPECIAL DISTRICT IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY.
AND WITHOUT A SPENT MOST OF MY
CAREER IN EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT.
AND I WAS GIVEN THIS OPPORTUNITY
COUNTY SDG ANY ABOUT NINETEEN
MONTHS AGO AS THE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT DIRECTOR.
IN MY FIRST DAY WAS A P. S. P.
S. OF HALF.
A SO I I SPUN UP THIS BE RAPIDLY.
IN IN THAT I WON THE HISTORY OF
OF SDG ANY AND AND AND WHY WE'VE
BEEN RELATIVELY SUCCESSFUL IN
THESE ADVANCE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND THIRTEEN CENTER YEAH SELECT
BECAUSE HE HAD A TWO HUNDRED
SIXTEEN INDIVIDUAL PS PS ADVANCE.
WITH A HUNDRED NINE CIRCUITS DE
ENERGIZED.
AND BOUGHT FIFTY TWO THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED CUSTOMERS WERE
IMPACTED DURING THAT ETIRE TIME.
NOT NOW WHY US SUCH A LOW
NUMBERS REALLY AND THAT'S
BECAUSE SB GENIES SPENT WELL
OVER A DECADE HARD IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE -- MAKING SURE
THAT WE'VE GOT A RELIABLE AND
RESILIENT -- LIKE TRIPLE GRAD.
AND MAINTAINING THAT AT AT A
VERY HIGH LEVEL SO IT'S BEEN A
VERY PRO ACTIVE STANCE FROM SDG
ANY.
AND AS YOU HEARD FROM --
DIRECTOR GARLIC DO CHI AND FROM
CHIEF PORTER THERE'S NO ONE
THING THAT MAKES THINGS WORK
PROPERLY IT'S A COMBINATION OF A
LOT OF FACTORS.
THAT MAKE YOU SUCCESSFUL IN IN
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT OR IN --
THE PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF --
PROTOCOLS. ONE OF THEM IS THE
RELATIONSHIPS I THINK THESE ARE
THE THINGS THAT MAKE US UNIQUE
OUT THERE -- WE HAVE VERY STRONG
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE COUNTY --
YES WITH SCALE -- YES WITH ALL
OF OUR FIRST RESPONDER AGENCIES --
WE DRILL WE TRAIN ANNUALLY WITH
THEM AND PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHUT OFF IS DISCUSSED QUITE A
BIT DURING THOSE A THIRD OF
THOSE TRAINING EXERCISE SO WE'RE
ALL ON THE SAME PAGE EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS WHAT OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE WHAT OUR
PROTOCOLS ARE.
HOW WE'RE GOING TO DO A ONE
WE'RE GOING TO DO IT AND WE'RE
GOING TO RE ENERGIZE TO RETURN
BACK TO NORMAL OPERATIONS
THERE'S NO SURPRISES IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY DURING THIS PROCESS?
WE ALSO HAVE A GOOD
COMMUNICATIONS PLAN WILL UTILIZE
OUR EMERGENCY NOTIFICATION
SYSTEM AND WE'RE CONSTANTLY
ENHANCING THAT SO THAT WE CAN
MAKE.
A QUICKER MORE APPROPRIATE --
MORE CONFIRMED NOTIFICATIONS TO
THE PUBLIC IN TWO OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE TARGETS THAT ARE
OUT THERE THE MAY BE IMPACTED BY
THE PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF
OF THAT.
AND THAT'S WORKING OUT VERY WELL
FOR US.
ANOTHER PART OF OUR PROTOCOLS
HOW WE GO ABOUT ACTUALLY DID DE
ENERGIZING WE'RE TRACKING THE
WEATHER SEVEN TO TEN DAYS OUT
THROUGH OUR MEET OUR STATE OF
THE ART MAJOR ALL G. UNIT.
AND WITH THAT WE'VE GOT OVER TEN
YEARS OF HISTORY OF WEATHER OUT
THERE FROM TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN WEATHER STATIONS FOR
OVER A HUNDRED AND SOME ODD
CAMERAS THAT ARE OUT THERE IN
THE SYSTEM.
SO WITH THAT TYPE OF OF DECADE
LONG -- INFORMATION IN THE
DATABASE WERE ABLE TO MAKE A
VERY RELEVANT TIMELY APPROPRIATE
DECISIONS IN THE PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF -- EVENTS.
AND THEN WE GET ABOUT THREE TO
SIX DAYS OUT WE'RE STARTING TO
FINE TUNE THAT WEATHER EVENT AND
START TO SAY. TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT ARE THE COMMUNITIES WHAT
ARE THE INFRASTRUCTURES THAT MAY
GET IMPACTED BY THIS AND WILL
START SOME OF THE NOTIFICATIONS
TO THE STATE WILL STARTS ON THE
OCCASIONS.
TO THE COUNTY -- BUT THEM
ALREADY RAPID BREATH RATCHETED
UP ABOUT TWO TO THREE DAYS OUT
BECAUSE NOW WE RUDY GOT A
DEFINITIVE LINE ON ON WHAT THIS
OF THAT'S GOING TO LOOK LIKE.
IN WORKING WITH THE NATIONAL
WEATHER SERVICE WE'RE TAKING A
LOOK AT YEARS AGO IT IS A HIGH
PROBABILITY OF A RED FLAG
WARNING BE IN ISSUED WHICH
STARTS TO LEAD US TOWARDS THE
PUBLIC SAFETY OF AT AND WITH
THAT.
WE'LL START TO PUT TOGETHER A
VERY FOCUS LIST OF IMPACTED
CIRCUITS IMPACTED COMMUNITIES
THAT MAY BE IMPACTED BY THIS OF
BAT AND WILL START TO MAKE THE
NOTIFICATIONS.
LE AND OBVIOUSLY THE THE PRIMARY
METHOD IS -- THROUGH CELLULAR
TELEPHONES -- THROUGH THE
WIRELESS NETWORK WE MAKE THOSE
IN ADVANCE WELL THE ENERGY IS
STILL ON SO THEY GET THOSE FIRST
NOTIFICATIONS AND THAT WE TRACK
THOSE NOTIFICATIONS SO THAT IF
THERE IS.
A TARGET COMMUNITY A SUCH AS
MEDICAL BASS LINE THAT ARE
DEPENDENT ON ON ENERGY FOR THEIR
DEVICES -- WE WOULD DURING THE
EVENT SEND DORA PEOPLE OUT TO
KNOCK ON THE DOORS AND VERIFY
THAT THEY DID GET THE
INFORMATION.
THE DAY AHEAD OF THE EVENT WILL
START OUR OUR PLAN OUR DEEP
PLANNING PROCESS WITH OVER
OPERATED UNITS WILL CALL FOR A
DAY HAD CALL TWENTY FOUR HOURS
IN ADVANCE WE'LL START SETTING
UP OVER A LOGISTICS ARE
OPERATIONAL PLAN.
OUR INCIDENT ACTION PLAN -- WILL
MAKE MORE NOTIFICATIONS TO THE
STATE THE COUNTY ALL THE FIRST
RESPONDER AGENCIES THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES THAT MAY
BE IMPACTED BY THIS AND AGAIN
THE COMMUNITIES THAT WOULD BE
IMPACTED BY THE ABOUT ALSO.
AND THEN AS WE GET INTO THE DE
ENERGIZE ATION WILL BE NOTIFYING
THOSE SAME CUSTOMERS AN IMPACTED
AREAS.
PRIVATE HOPEFULLY UP TO FOUR
HOURS PRIOR TO TWO D. ENTERS IS
ATION THAT THIS IS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
AND WE DO ALL THIS NOTIFICATION
AND YOU'VE HEARD THIS THEME
THROUGHOUT HERE THERE IS A THERE
IS A A A A DEFINITE NEED FOR
PEOPLE TO BE PREPARED.
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
CUSTOMERS THERE ARE FIRST
RESPONDERS THAT EVERYBODY THE
COULD BE IMPACTED.
HAS THE INFORMATION IN ADVANCE
TO PREPARE FOR THE EVENT SO THE
NOBODY'S CAUGHT SHORT ON THIS.
IN THERE DURING THE RESTORATION
PROCESS WAS REPORTED ON OUR
PLANNING AND YOU KNOW YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT EARLIER ABOUT.
WELL ONE OF THE KEY ITEMS ON
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE -- AS
CELLULAR AND WIRELESS
CONNECTIVITY IS RESTORING
SERVICE AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
WE DO THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE VERY
LITTLE REACTION TIME.
BETWEEN WHEN WE DE ENERGIZED AND
THEN WE THEN THE WINDS START TO
DIE DOWN WE START TO GO INTO THE
INTO THE RE ENERGIZE ATION
PROCESS WE'VE GOT EVERYTHING IN
PLACE OUR AIR RESOURCES ARE
GROUND RESOURCES ARE PATROLLERS.
ARE TROUBLE MEN ARE OUT THERE
ARE PLANS IN PLACE EVERYBODY'S
IN THE RIGHT GEOGRAPHICAL
LOCATION LOGISTICALLY.
AND WE EXPEDITE ONCE THE WINTER
DOWN WE'RE SURE AND ONCE WE ONCE
WE PATROL IN SURE THAT IT'S SAFE
WE RE ENERGIZE IN A TIMELY
MANNER AND WE CAN DO THAT PRETTY
QUICKLY BECAUSE WE SO HIGHLY
SEGMENTED OUR CIRCUITS.
THAT WE CAN LIMIT TO SMALLER
AREAS AND RESTORE THE SMALL
AREAS FASTER THAN LARGER
YOURSELF WE ONLY HAVE TO IMPACT
EIGHT PEOPLE ON A SEGMENTED
CIRCUIT VERSUS TWO OR THREE
HUNDRED OR A HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED
VERSUS THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE.
THAT DOES HELP RESTORE THE
SERVICE QUICKER.
I THINK WHAT REALLY DOES IT FOR
US THOUGH IS THE IS THE
HANDSHAKE PRIOR TO THE EVENT --
I SPOKE EARLIER ABOUT OUR
RELATIONSHIPS WITH EVERYBODY I
CAN'T SAY ENOUGH FOR OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE THE CITY
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS CAL FIRE
AND ALL THE FIRE AGENCIES OF SAN
DIEGO COUNTY.
WE WORK TOGETHER REGULAR LAST
YEAR ALONE WE TRAINED OVER
pISSUE WERE DOING ALL THE CHIEF
OFFICERS THE DISPATCH CENTERS.
AND THAT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
COMMUNICATIONS.
WE HAVE TO ENSURE THAT NOT ONLY
CAN WE COMMUNICATE WE KNOW OUR
COMMUNICATIONS PLAN.
THE FIRST RESPONDERS KNOW THAT
COMMUNICATIONS PLANT THE
DISPATCHERS BILL THAT
COMMUNICATIONS PLAN SO THE WE
SEND OUT THAT LIST.
OF PROBABLE PS PS IMPACTED AREAS
THAT EVERYBODY COMMUNICATES IT
THROUGHOUT THE ORGANIZATIONS AND
EVERYBODY'S READY.
FOR I THINK THAT IF YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT HIGHLIGHTS IN AND
WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE THE OTHER
THING WE DO AFTER EACH EVENT IS
DO A VERY COMPREHENSIVE AFTER
ACTION REVIEW.
WE WANT TO KNOW NOT ONLY WHAT WE
DID WELL BUT WHAT WE NEED TO
IMPROVE AND WE GET A LIST OF
THAT AFTER THESE EVENTS AND THEN
MY STAFF IS RESPONSIBLE TO
FACILITATE.
A TIMELY COMPLETION OF THE
ACTUAL ITEMS AFTER THAT WHICH
DRIVE FOR QUALITY ASSURANCE
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT PROGRESS.
PROGRAM POST A MAN.
IN PART OF THAT ALSO IS THE CAME
OUT OF THAT IS GOING OUT TO THE
COMMUNITIES CREE IMPOSED TO MATT
AND FINDING OUT HOW IS IT
IMPACTING THE COMMUNITIES.
HOW DO WE BETTER COMMUNICATE
WITH THEM HOW DO WE BETTER
COMMUNICATE WITH THE FIRST
RESPONDERS AND THEN WE FACTOR
THAT INTO OUR PROGRAM? ONE OF
THE MORE SPECIFIC THINGS THAT
CAME OUT OF THE AFTER ACTION
REVIEW PROCESS IN THE COMMUNITY
EVENTS WAS PEOPLE WERE SAYING
LISTEN IF FOR THE FIRST ALL.
CONNECTIONS DOWN AND WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO GET INFORMATION WORK TO
WE GO TO GET INFORMATION ON THIS
EVENT WORK WE GO TO GET SUPPORT.
SO SDG ANY ESTABLISHED ELEVEN
COMMUNITY RESOURCE CENTERS WHERE
THE PEOPLE IN THOSE IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES IF THOSE ARE.
ARE IMPACTED DURING THIS A MAN
WILL KNOW WHERE TO GO TO GET
THINGS LIKE.
CHARGING THEIR CELL PHONES
WIRELESS CAN ACTIVITY.
GETTING MORE IMPORTANTLY
INFORMATION ON THE STATUS THE
POSITION AND THE STATUS OF THAT
P. S. P. S. ADVANTAGE.
IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD IN THEIR
AREA AND AN ESTIMATE FOR ONE THE
RESTORATION TIME WILL COME ALONG.
WE'LL COME BACK ON SO ALL THAT
IS HAPPENING THAT'S AT AT DURING
THESE EVENTS.
I THINK THAT THAT.
WITH ALL THOSE ITEMS FACTORED IN --
THAT'S FOR OUR SUCCESS HAS BEEN
WITH THE PS PS AMASSED IN THERE
THERE ARE THINGS TO BE DONE WE
DO NEED TO RESOLVE HOW HOW DO WE
INSURE THE RESILIENCY OF OUR
WIRELESS.
AND INTERNET CONNECTIONS BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE SO DEPENDENT WHEN I
FIRST CAME ON THE FIRE SERVICE
WE DIDN'T HAVE CELLPHONES SO
EVERYBODY CARRIED QUARTERS AND
YOU HAVE THE THE THE PHONE
WITHIN THE HARD LINES.
NOW IN IN THE REPORT THAT I READ
PRIOR TO THIS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT 53% OF THE POPULATION IS
ON CELLULAR CONNECTION SO IT IS
THE WAY OF COMMUNICATING NOW AND
IT'S GOING TO BE THE WAY OF
COMMUNICATING PRIMARILY IN THE
FUTURE.
DURING THESE EVENTS AND DURING
THE FIRE EVENTS THAT THAT DO
HAPPEN AND DO OCCUR AS WE SAW
OVER THE LAST YEAR [inaudible]
TO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT TESTIMONY
AS AS SOMEONE WHO HAS A DAUGHTER
LIVING IN SAN DIEGO THAT WAS
VERY REASSURING THANK YOU FOR
THAT -- MY MY THANKS TO THIS
PANEL AND AND YOU KNOW YOU GOT
BEAT UP A LITTLE BIT FIRST
COUPLE PANELS AND WE ANTICIPATED
THAT I HAD SOME SOME GREATEARLY
CONVERSATIONS ON WITH SOME OF
YOU.
AND IN I THINK WE YOU KNOW WE
ARE IN ONE OF THOSE UNIQUE WHAT
IS TRULY A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP WHEN IT COMES TO
EMERGENCY COMMUNICATION BUT WHAT
I HEARD CONSISTENTLY FROM OUR
FIRST RESPONDER COMMUNITY.
AND AND LOCAL OFFICIALS IS THAT
IT'S IT'S GOES SO FAR BEYOND
PARTNERSHIP THIS IS REALLY ABOUT
DEPENDENCY.
WE WE DEPEND ON YOU IN THE
COMMUNICATION SYSTEM THAT YOU
PROVIDE IN KEEPING CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS SAFE AND SO IN
PARTICULAR WANTED TO DRILL DOWN
KIND OF ON A ON A FEW QUESTIONS
ON THINGS YOU YOU.
MENTIONED IN PARTICULAR -- IN A
GIVEN THAT EIGHT EACH
EMERGENCIES IS UNIQUE AND
PRESENTS ITS OWN CHALLENGES AND
THE FACT THAT WHAT YOU DEAL WITH
IN IN DELIVERING YOUR SERVICES
IS TRULY CONSUMER MARKET DRIVEN --
WHAT HAVE YOU LEARNED FROM THE
LAST FEW FIRE SEASONS IN TERMS
OF -- THE AMOUNT OF MOBILE
RESOURCE THAT YOU NEED TO MOVE
INTO A COMMUNITY AND AND PROVIDE
THAT RESILIENCY PARTICULARLY IF
WE'VE GOT MULTIPLE INCIDENTS
HAPPENING -- STATEWIDE WHAT HAVE
YOU LEARNED ABOUT YOUR ABILITY
TO TO DEAL WITH AND AND INTERACT
WITH EACH OTHER -- FOR HELP AND
SUPPORT WITH YOU KNOW SYSTEM
BACK UP.
AND THEN AT SOME POINT DOES IT
ACTUALLY MAKE MORE SENSE -- TO
TO HAVE MORE OF THAT MOBILE
CAPABILITY THAN IT DOES -- YOU
KNOW GROUND HARDENING LIKE WHICH
WHICH OF THOSE TWO OR IS IT
SENATE KIND OF SOME COMBINATION
OF OF THOSE DEPENDING ON THE
AREA THE TERRAIN.
THAT THEY CREATE THAT NECESSARY
REDUNDANCY.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION -- SO.
WHAT WE DIDN'T DISCUSS IS THE
FACT THAT -- THE MOBILE
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE ARE NOT
JUST THE ONES WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA WE CAN BRING OUR
RESOURCES FROM OTHER PARTS OF
THE NATION AND WE HAVE ACTUALLY
DONE THAT -- IN THE IN RECENT
FIRES WE BROUGHT -- MOBILE --
DEPLOYABLE AS FROM OTHER --
STATES AND WHAT WHAT WE FOUND IS
THAT IT IT'S IT'S FINE YOU KNOW
IT'S IT'S SOMETHING LONG AS WE
GET THERE.
AND WE HAVE THE RELATIONSHIPS
THAT WE HAVE WE HAVE A GREAT
RELATIONSHIP FOR CALLOW YES WE
HAVE A GREAT RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE MANY OF THE NOT ALL.
THE COUNTY ALL YES AND LOCAL YES
SO WHEN WE GO IN THERE AND TALK
TO THEM ABOUT WHAT THE NEEDS ARE
WE CAN FIGURE OUT ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY WHERE THERE IS A
SPECIFIC NEED.
AND THEN DECIDE WHAT THE BEST
WAY TO GO ABOUT THAT IS AND
DEPLOYABLE IS NOT THE ONLY THING
THAT WE CAN DO.
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE WE ALREADY
HAVE CELL SITES UP THERE THAT
MAY BE MODIFIED TO INCREASE
CAPACITY AND WE'VE DONE THAT
MANY TIMES OR WE'VE INCREASED
PASSIVE EXISTING.
CELL SITES TO DEAL WITH THE AND
THE THE FACT THAT MAYBE ANOTHER
CELL SITE HAS GONE DOWN BECAUSE
FIBER HAS BEEN CUT OR FOR
ANOTHER REASON.
SO -- SO.
WHAT WHAT WE LEARNED IS THAT WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO IMPROVE UPON
THOSE COMMUNICATIONS MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE?
YOU KNOW -- NOT TALKING PAST
EACH OTHER AND AND WE DON'T FIND
THAT.
BUT YOU ALWAYS WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU READ DOUBLE THOSE
EFFORTS -- WITH REGARDS -- TO
THE OTHER COMMUNICATIONS
COMPANIES AND HOW WE WORK WITH
THEM -- WE DO PRETTY GOOD
ACTUALLY -- YOU KNOW WE WE WE
KNOW THAT WHEN THERE'S A CRISIS
WE HAVE MUTUAL AID AGREEMENTS
AND IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
WORK WITH EACH OTHER -- WE HAVE --
THE ABILITY SORT FOUR NINE ONE
ONE CALLS -- TO GO TO A
COMPATIBLE NETWORK IF OUR
NETWORK IS DOWN AND VICE VERSA --
SO A PERSON AND IS ON A VERIZON --
COMMUNICATIONS PLAN AND THERE IS
AN OUTAGE -- TEMPORARY OUTAGE
THEY CAN DIAL 911- AND WHATEVER
OTHER COMUNICATIONS COMPANY IS
UP TO HAVE COMPATIBLE EQUIPMENT
WILL TAKE THAT NINE ONE ONE CALL.
I'LL JUST ADD A LITTLE BIT --
NICE TO THANK YOU THAT REALLY.
AS YOU SAID AT THE IT'S A
VARIABLE THERE IS NO ONE
SOLUTION TO THE QUESTION -- SO
OVER THE OVER THE YEARS AND WHAT
WE LEARNED FROM THIS IS THAT WE
DO INCREASE HARDENING OF AREAS
WHERE WE CAN WIFE WE CAN PUT A A
PERMIT GENERATOR AND WE WILL.
NOT ALWAYS A SOLUTION WE'VE
ADDED HUNDREDS OF PORTABLE
GENERATORS TO OUR OUR FLEET AND
WE DEPLOY THOSE AND WE HAVE THE
STAGE IN AREAS THAT ARE BEST SET
FOR THAT.
WE PARTNER WITH OUR OTHER
CARRIERS IN IN THE EVENT WE NEED.
TWO AGAIN PERSONALLY IS THE
COORDINATOR FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY OPERATIONS.
WE HAVE DURING THE CAMPFIRE
SPECIFICALLY I MEAN I REMEMBER
WORKING WITH RISE AND I WAS
SPECIFICALLY TO GET CUSTOMERS
BACK ON LINE AND GET CALLS
THROUGH BECAUSE THAT'S REALLY
OUR OUR PRIMARY CONCERN.
BUT THERE IS A ONE SOLUTION
RIGHT BUILDING RESILIENT NETWORK
BUILDING REDUNDANCY AND HAVING A
A FIRST RATE.
RESPONSE IS GOING TO BE THE BEST
SOLUTION AND IN ACCORDANCE WITH
ALL THE ALERTS ON TOP OF THAT I
THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A MIXED
BAG THAT'S GOING TO GIVE US THE
BEST.
RESPONSE.
ARE THERE ANY CURRENT REGULATORY
CHALLENGES THAT.
PREVENT YOU.
OPTIMALLY DOING THIS SYSTEM
RESILIENCY RIGHT NOW IS THERE
ANYTHING THE STATE IS DOING THAT
GETTING IN THE WAY OF WHERE WE
NEED TO BE TO KEEP.
RESIDENTS SAFE [inaudible]
THE I WOULDN'T THINK SO I I I
ONE OF THE THINGS I THINK THAT --
THE THE DATE AND I REALLY
APPLAUD YOU FOR THAT MADAM CHAIR --
BOOK BUT WE SPOKE BEFORE THE
HEARING AGAIN WE KIND OF TALKED
ABOUT COLLABORATION -- I THINK
COLLAB IT ANYTHING IN THIS AREA
CAN BE BETTER I THINK
COLLABORATION TO BE BETTER --
AND SO I FROM THE STATE SIDE I
THINK I WOULD LIKE TO SEE US
TALKING.
WITH EACH OTHER.
RATHER THAN THAT EACH OTHER
WHICH UNFORTUNATELY I THINK
HAPPENED TODAY -- BUT SO WE'RE
HOPEFUL MAYBE USING YOUR GOOD
OFFICES THERE'S THERE'S A AND
AND AND THE VICE CHAIR WHO'S
BEEN A HE WAS BEEN A REAL LEADER
IN THIS AREA -- TO START THE TO
DO BETTER AT TALKING BEFORE
THESE THINGS HAPPEN AND ADDS.
AND WHAT WE CAN WHAT WECAN DO
BETTER ONE OF THE THINGS
UNFORTUNATELY AND WHAT WE'RE
HEARING TODAY -- WAS -- IN THE
RURAL AREAS.
IT'S NOT SO MUCH A STATE ISSUE
IT'S SORT OF A LOCAL ISSUE.
PROBABLY WOULD LIKE TO HAVE ORE
SITES IN CERTAIN PLACES THAT ARE
VERY VERY DIFFICULT TO TO DO.
A IN SOME OF THESE SOME OF THESE
AREAS LIKE THAT.
PUBLIC LANDS AND AND SOME OF THE
RURAL AREAS OF REALLY HARD.
TO THE SITE TO SITE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
NOT IF I CAN ADD -- AS AS HE WAS
TALKING IDEAS ACTUALLY FLOWED SO --
YOU KNOW SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE HAVE IS THE DEPLOYMENT
OF OUR FACILITIES -- IN IN
PLACES WHERE THE A CONDITIONAL
USE PERMIT PROCESS SEEN IS
COMPLICATED THAT THAT'S A LOCAL
ISSUE ISSUE IT'S NOT A STATE
ISSUE BUT THE TIME IT TAKES TO
GET THE PERMITS FOR A MACRO
TOWER -- OR OTHER WIRELESS
FACILITY SOMETIMES CAN BE TWO
THREE YEARS MAYBE EVEN LONGER --
ESPECIALLY IF YOU HAVE COMMUNITY
OPPOSITION AND YOU HAVE AN M. P.
ISM NOT IN MY BACKYARD -- THEN
DID THAT MAKES IT MORE DIFFICULT
FOR US TO ACTUALLY CREATE THE
TYPE OF REDUNDANCIES THAT WE
WANT TO OUR MORE ROBUST
COMMUNICATIONS -- NETWORK --
THIS IS SOMETHING ALL OF US
EXPERIENCE AND Là ARE GIVE YOU.
ONE EXAMPLE OF SOME OF THE
DIFFICULTIES WE HAVE IN IT AND
IT DOESN'T REALLY.
I DON'T KNOW THAT YOU NEED TO
STAY CAN DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT
BUT NO ONE WE WANT TO PUT UP A
MACRO -- WE NEED TO GO FIND A
LOCATION TO DO THAT WE HAVE TO
ENSURE A LEASE WITH THE
LANDOWNER TO DO THAT AND THEN
GET THE PERMITTING THEN
CONSTRUCTED -- WE HAVE DELAYS
BECAUSE SOME LANDOWNERS WILL
ENTER CONTRACTS WITH US AND THEN
BACK OUT -- YOU KNOW SIX MONTHS
LATER SO THAT ADDS TO THE TIMING.
SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT THAT I CAN DISCUSS
HERE -- IN TERMS OF SORT OF THE
REGULATORY.
AT THE SIR LIMITATIONS THAT WE
HAVE THAT ARE PROBLEMATIC.
ARE THE AIR QUALITY OF QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT'S SO AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT'S
HAVE A LOT OF LIMITATIONS AND
RESTRICTIONS ON HOW LONG YOU CAN.
I HAVE A GENERATOR RUN -- EVEN
TO TEST THEM -- IF YOU WANT
TESTER GENERATORS WHICH WE HAVE
TO DO ON A MONTHLY BASIS.
THERE'S LIKE VERY EXTREME
LIMITATIONS ON WHEN WE CAN DO
THAT.
BUT THIS IS THE CLINCHER IS EVEN
DURING AN EMERGENCY SITUATION OF
THE DISASTER.
AT LEAST ONE OF THOSE AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT'S
RESTRICT RESTRICTS US TO TWO
HUNDRED HOURS OF GENERATOR --
USE.
SO IF IT IF IT'S A VERY LENGTHY --
DISASTER AND WE WANT TO REFUEL
OUR GENERATORS BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WE WANT OUR CUSTOMERS TO HAVE
SERVICE AND FIRST RESPONDERS TO
HAVE SERVICE.
WE'RE WE'RE OUT WE HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THAT RESTRICTION AND THE
WAY YOU DEAL WITH THAT IS YOU
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO TURN OFF
YOUR SYSTEMS YOU JUST GO FORTH
AND YOU GET PENALTIES YOU GET
PENALIZED PRETTY SEVERELY.
THEY'RE IN THE SYSTEM IN PLACE
TO APPLY FOR AN EMERGENCY WAIVER --
WITH AQ AND A NOT THAT I KNOW OF
THANK YOU I'M AT THIS TIME AND
LOVE TO WELCOME MY VICE CHAIR
SENATOR HANNAH BETH JACKSON.
THANK YOU I'M OF MY APOLOGIES WE
SPENT TWO HOURS DISCUSSING THE
WILDFIRE BILL THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S JUST ON BECAUSE OF
ALL THE WILD FIRES WE'VE HAD THE
ENORMOUS EXPENSE TO THE STATE.
TO MY COMMUNITY I THINK PERHAPS
TO THE CHAIRS COMMUNITY AND MANY
OF US HERE HAVING.
SUFFERED THE RAVAGES OF
WILDFIRES AND THEN IN MY
COMMUNITY WE HAD A AS ASTROS.
FLOOD DEBRIS FLOW WE CALLED IT
THAT KILLED TWENTY THREE PEOPLE
WERE SLEEP IN THEIR BEDS AT
THREE O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING
AFTER FIRE SO -- AND NOW WE HAVE
PEACH TREE IN A AN EDISON AND
SDG ANY HAVING FINANCIAL
PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED WITH THAT.
I AM ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO
BELIEVES THAT THE PREVENTION IS
ALWAYS WORTH AN OUNCE OF
PREVENTION IS WORTH A POUND OF
CURE AND I'M.
CONCERNED VERY CONCERNED THAT WE
ARE -- HAVING SOME.
I THINK IT YOU SAY TALKING.
BY EACH OTHER.
AND OUR LIVES ARE AT STAKE WE
ARE NOW BY TEN OR NEXT FIRE
SEASON.
THANKS TO CLIMATE CHANGE THINGS
ARE BURNING HARDER FASTER MORE
INTENSELY -- MORE RAPIDLY SO --
FIREWOOD.
I APOLOGIZE THAT I MISSED A GOOD
PORTION THIS BUT I DO I DO WANT
TO TAKE A MOMENT.
TO PASS MISS MCINTYRE HOW IT
FEELS TO BE THE ONLY WOMAN ON
ANY THESE PANELS TODAY.
WE REALLY DO NEED TO BRING A
LITTLE BIT MORE OF THAT.
TO PERSPECTIVE TO THE TABLE --
BUT THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE IS
SIGN AND I NOTICE YOU'RE WEARING
WHITE YOU'RE THE PERSON IN THE
WHITE HAT HAS IT WORK -- BUT I
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE THE
ALERT SYSTEM THE AND I THINK IT
WAS FAIRLY WELL COVERED.
IN THE IT VANCE PAPERS THAT WERE
DONE HERE SO I WOULD LIKE TO
JUST GET RIGHT TO THE CHASE FOR
TRUST A COUPLE MINUTES BECAUSE I
REALIZE IT'S LATE AND WE HAVE
PUBLIC.
COMMENT COMING AS WELL.
INDEED THE CHAIR LEAVE THIS YEAR
APPOINTMENTS OKAY SO.
THAT'S A THAT'S A YEAH A HINT
THAT WE SHOULD BE WINDING DOWN --
ON THE ON THE REDUNDANCY OF OUR
ALERT SYSTEMS -- IT WAS SO I
THINK TWO YEARS AGO -- IN
DECEMBER WHERE -- WE HAD A
HEARING IN THIS ROOM VERY
SIMILAR TO THIS ONE TALKING
ABOUT EMERGENCY ALERTS AND
EVACUATIONS AND WE HAD HAD THE
FIRES UP IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
THE KILLED I THINK THIS FORTY
FOUR PEOPLE.
OF THE CAR FIRE IN IN IN THE
COFFEE PARK IN SANTA ROSA AND IT
WAS CLEAR THAT WE HAVE NOT DONE.
UNNECESSARY JOB IN WARNING
PEOPLE BECAUSE THE FIRST OUR
FIRST PRIORITY NOT TRUSTED IN.
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT BUT FOR YOU
FOLKS WHO ARE THE ONES WHO
PROVIDE THESE COMMUNICATIONS
SERVICES AND DO THE WORK TO
COORDINATE NIGHT.
AND I DO AGREE THAT
RELATIONSHIPS ARE CRITICAL IN
COORDINATING EFFORTS ARE
IMPORTANT BUT YOU'RE THE FOLKS
OUT THERE WHO HAVE THOUGH THE
HARDWARE -- THE FOLKS THAT DO
THE ALERTS AND MOST PEOPLE I
KNOW TODAY DO NOT HAVE LAND
LINES.
AND SO THE QUESTION BECOMES HOW
CAN WE MAKE SURE PEOPLE KNOW TO
GET OUT OF HARM'S WAY.
AND TO BRING IN MOBILE UNITS IS
GREAT BUT THEY DON'T THEY DON'T
COME IN BEFORE THE FIRE STARTS
RAVAGING THROUGH A COMMUNITY YOU
MIGHT GET A MINUTE DAY OR TWO
LATER.
BUT WHEN THAT FIRE STARTS.
AND AN HOUR AND A HALF LEFT
AFTER A BANG DOWN THAT GAVELED
TO DISCUSSES ISSUES DECEMBER
FOURTH AND I REMEMBER SAYING
WELSH DECEMBER HOPEFULLY WILL
HAVE MORE TIME TO FIGURE THIS
OUT.
LITERALLY AN HOUR AND A HALF
LATER THE THOMAS FIRE STARTED.
AND IN MY DISTRICT EVERY OUNCE
OF THAT FIRE. FORTY DAYS SAID
FIRE BURNED AND IT MOVED ACROSS.
THE COMMUNITY ACROSS VENTURA
COUNTY AND IT ENDED UP BEING
PUSHED INTO THE BACK COUNTRY ONE
MILE FROM MY HOUSE.
SO I HAD A PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
WITH THIS AS WELL AS TRYING TO
DEAL WITH THIS FROM WORKING WITH --
YES IT DID AN AMAZING JOB AND
AND ALL THE OTHER GROUPS WHO
CAME TOGETHER.
BUT OUR ALERT SYSTEM IS NOT
ADEQUATE.
AND WE KNOW WHEN THESE FIRE
START.
UP IN THE HILLS AS MOST OF THEM
DO.
IT IS A IT IS A A A TELEPHONE
POLE.
THAT FALLS TO THE WINDOW OR
CAPTURES ON FIRE AND THEN
EVERYTHING RACES FROM THERE AND
ON THOSE POLLS ARE FREQUENTLY
WIRELESS EQUIPMENT SO THE
WIRELESS SYSTEM GOES DOWN SO THE
QUESTION BECOMES.
HOW OUR PEOPLE IF THE
ELECTRICITY SO IF THE WIRELESS
SYSTEM GOES OUT HOW ARE PEOPLE
GOING TO KNOW THAT THEY NEED TO
MOVE THEY NEED TO LEAVE THEY
NEED TO GET OUT OF HARM'S WAY?
AND SO -- I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
YOU I DON'T WANT TO HEAR ABOUT
THE MOBILE UNITS TO COME IN A
DAY OR TWO LATER.
WHAT IS IT THAT THE WIRELESS
COMPANIES ARE DOING ARE PREPARED
TO DO?
IN ORDER TO HELP YOU KNOW YOU WE
ARE YOUR CUSTOMERS.
THE THESE COMPANIES MAKE A LOT
OF MONEY HERE IN CALIFORNIA BY
SERVING THE CUSTOMERS THE PEOPLE
THE STATE AND WHEN IT COMES TO
IN A DISASTER WE NEED TO THEIR
SO WHAT ARE YOU DOING.
WHAT DO YOU NEED US TO DO TO
HELP YOU SO THAT YOU CAN HARDEN
AT INFRASTRUCTURE SO THAT YOU
CAN HAVE THE REDUNDANCIES?
THAT WE NEED SO WE CAN MAKE SURE
THAT THE WI IS SYSTEM IS
OPERATING OR OTHER SYSTEMS ARE
OPERATING AND I'VE DONE
LEGISLATION ON THIS SIDE A BILL
THIS YEAR THAT.
THAT -- WAS -- HELD UP ON THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE BECAUSE
WIRELESS COMPANIES DIDN'T WANT
TO BE TOLD WHAT TO DO.
SO WHAT IS IT THAT YOU NEED IN
ORDER TO HELP US PROTECT THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE [inaudible]
WELL THAT.
IF I UNDERSTAND YOU FEEL VERY
STRONGLY AS TO EVERYBODY ELSE
HERE CENTER JACKSON -- WELL THAT
ISN'T EVEN THE NINETY PLUS
PEOPLE WE LOST IN PARADISE SO
WELL.
THE WITH A SYSTEM -- PAN AND I
UNDERSTAND THE SORT OF IT
THERE'S A CHICKEN AND EGG THING
HERE BUT A LOT OF TIMES -- WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE OUIJA
SYSTEM IS USED IN A TIMELY
ENOUGH FASHION BEFORE THINGS GO
DOWN WE THINK THERE'S
OPPORTUNITIES TO DO THAT.
WE WANT TO WORK WITH YOU KNOW
WITH A LOCAL ORIGINATORS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND IT'S UP
TO LOCAL ORIGINATORS. TO DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT TO DO A OF
WIRELESS EMERGENCY ALERT -- THEY
DETERMINE THE MESSAGE.
THEY DETERMINE THE AREA.
AND THEN.
WE JUST DO WHAT WE'RE TOLD.
SO SOME TIME AND SO WETHINK
THAT. ONE OF THE THINGS WE LIKE
TO DO IS WORK COLLECTIVELY TO
MAKE SURE AND MORE LOCAL
ORIGINATORS WHICH ARE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS -- ARE KNOWLEDGEABLE
pIT AND UNDERSTAND THE TIMELINESS
OF IT OBVIOUSLY IF.
ENTIRE NETWORK GOES DOWN.
YOU'RE RIGHT BUT I THINK THE
CARRIERS ARE ALSO DOING A GOOD
JOB OF IT JUST BECAUSE ONE SIDE
GOES DOWN DOESN'T MEAN THEY
CAN'T RE DIRECT TRAFFIC YOU KNOW
ELSEWHERE -- I DO THINK THE
COMPANIES ARE DOING IT AT A VERY
GOOD JOB AND YOU DIDN'T YOU
DIDN'T HEAR MISTER MISTER WATSON
SO -- TESTIMONY ABOUT.
THE THINGS THAT ARE DONE IN
ANTICIPATION OF I MEAN.
YOU KIND OF KNOW WHAT'S COMING
RIGHT I MEAN THAT ALTHOUGH
SOMETIMES THEY HAPPEN VERY VERY
QUICKLY [inaudible]
SO.
COLLABORATING WITH WITH -- YES --
WITH LOCAL ORIGINATORS -- IN IN
IT AND YOU HAVE TO LOOK BACK. TO
TO SEE HOW YOU CAN IMPROVE BUT I
THINK WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS IS
ALL LOOK FORWARD TO SEE WHAT WE
CAN DO TO MAKE IT TO MAKE IT
BETTER WELL I'M INTERESTED IN
THAT OBVIOUSLY WE CAN'T GO
BACKWARDS BUT IF YOU WOULD.
ADDRESS THE QUESTION.
YOU HAVE INFRASTRUCTURE ON
TELEPHONE POLES IN RURAL AREAS
OR IN THE HILLS -- SUBJECT TO
ENORMOUS WINS SUBJECT TO
COLLAPSING AND IT WHEN THAT
HAPPENS THE EVERYTHING GOES OUT.
SO -- GRANTED YOU CAN YOU CAN --
WE HAVE LOCAL ORIGINATORS TO
DETERMINE THE MESSAGE AN AREA
BUT IF THERE'S NO INFRASTRUCTURE
TO DELIVER IT IT DOESN'T MATTER
SO WE CAN WORK ON AND I THINK
WE'RE SEEING THAT LOCALLY -- I'M
VERY INTERESTED IN HOW TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE DIFFERENT
WARNING SYSTEMS THAT ARE
DELIVERED THROUGH WIRELESS I GOT
WANTED TO THIRTY IN THE WARM
MORNING FROM WE HAD DURING OUR
FIRE DID KNOW QUITE WHAT TO MAKE
OF IT AND TURNED OUT THEY WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT EVERY TEN MILES.
AWAY SO DIDN'T HELP VERY MUCH
THERE HAVE TO BE A NUMBER OF
SYSTEMS AND BECAUSE WIRELESS NOW
IT IS TODAY THE PRIMERA WAY THAT
PEOPLE COMMUNICATE.
OR BY INTERNET TO WHICH MANY OF
WHICH ARE YOU KNOW DONE THROUGH
WIRES AND CABLES AND ALL.
WHAT IS IT?
THAT THAT YOU MAY NEED OR THAT
YOU'RE WILLING TO DO -- WE WE
CAN'T JUST LOOK AT THE LOCALS
AND SAY YOU GOT A MOVE FASTER
THEY CAN'T MOVE FASTER IF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ISN'T THERE
THAT'S YOUR INFRASTRUCTURE.
WHAT CAN WE DO GOING FORWARD? TO
ASSIST YOU IN ASSURING THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS THERE AND IT'S
FUNCTIONAL BECAUSE WE NEEDED TO
BE FUNCTIONAL.
AND IT'S RIGHT UP THERE USUALLY
IN THE IN THE RISKIEST AREAS --
BUT IT'S GOT TO WORK.
WHEN PEOPLE DIE OR THEY ARE
TRAUMATIZED BY THIS -- THIS
EXPERIENCE IT DOESN'T HELP TO
SAY WELL YOU KNOW THE SYSTEM
WENT OUT IT WAS UP IN THE HILLS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH STUFF IS.
THE STUFF ON TELEPHONE POLES ARE
GENERALLY THE MICRO THE TINY
LITTLE THINGS BUT MOST OF THE
WIRELESS NETWORK IS ON THE MACRO
TOWERS CORRECT TODD FINE AND
WHERE THE MACRO TOWERS.
I'M SORRY WHERE ARE THE MAC
FORGET WHERE THEY LOCATED ORDER
THE LARGER STILL TOWERS THAT
YOU'D SEE GENERALLY THROUGHOUT
THE AREA SO THEY'RE NOT
GENERALLY PLACED ON TELEPHONE
POLES THE MACRO SIDE SORRY FINE
BUT THEY ARE IN THE HILLS SO
THEY KNOW WHAT THEY'RE USUALLY.
BUT THEY ARE A WE HAVE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AROUND THOSE WE
HAVE RESILIENCY IN REDUNDANCY IN
THE NETWORK AS WELL WITH BACKUP
OF POWER SOLUTIONS FOR THOSE
MACROS FOR ALL MICROSITES.
IN IN THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
YOU'VE HAD FOR A PERIOD OF TIME
THAT'S CORRECT OUR MACRO SITES
ALL HAVE REDUNDANT POWER -- SOME
REMARKS WHICH HAVE REDUNDANT
POWER.
AND WHEN YOU SAY MACROS SITES
FOR THOSE THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THIS IS A LARGE POLLS YOU'D SEE
WITH IS WITH THE TOWERS ON TOP
OF THE NOT -- SMALLER SO WE CALL
MICROSITES WOULD BE ON A
TELEPHONE POLE OF FOR THE NEXT
NEXT GEN TYPE OF CELL SERVICE
BUT THE MACRO SIDES OF THE MAIN
ONES YOU'D SEE THROUGH SO YOU
DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYTHING
THAT OU NEED TO DO TO IMPROVE
YOUR SYSTEM -- BUT I'D SAY IS
THAT WE WE'VE BUILT A NETWORK
WITH MANY LEVELS OF DIVERSITY
CONTINUE LOOKING OF THERE'S
OPPORTUNITIES CLEARLY BASED ON
THE EVIDENCE WEEKS WE'VE HEARD
TODAY RIGHT -- BUT WE CAN'T WE
WE DECIDED TO STAND MULTIPLE
POINTS OF FAILURE BUT WE CAN'T
DESIGN A NETWORK THAT'S
IMPOSSIBLE IT'S IMPOSSIBLE THE
ENGINEER NETWORK.
WITH INSURANCE THAT WILL NOT
BURKE. FOR INSTANCE IN THE
CAMPFIRE WITH MARK FIRE MOVES SO
FAST AND SO QUICKLY IT IMPACTED
BOTH ARE DONE THE LINES IN THE
AREA.
SO WHAT WE COULD DO IS WE COULD
GET A SATELLITE COLD IN THERE AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN ACCESS THE
AREA WHICH RESTORED SERVICES
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
SO I AM AND WHAT I WOULD
ANSWERED YOUR QUESTION BECAUSE
IT'S IT'S NOT AN EASY ANSWER AND
I I THINK I SENT IT TO THE CHAIR
THERE -- THERE IS NO SINGLE
LEARNING SOLUTION FOR ALL
SCENARIOS.
WOULD RATHER SEE A SUITE OF
SOLUTIONS THAT I THINK WE NEED
TO EMLOY RIGHT INCLUDING WE ARE --
WHAT'S THE KHôNG RIVERSIDE ONE
ONE TV AND RADIO AND EVEN OFTEN
MOBILE ALERTS.
AND WHILE WE DON'T MANAGE THE
SOLUTIONS WE DO BUILD A STRONG
AND RESILIENT NETWORKS THAT CAN
DELIVER THEM.
AND THAT'S THAT'S OUR GOAL.
WELL I COULD GO ON FOR HOURS ON
THIS -- APPRECIATE YOUR BEING
HERE -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THERE IS MORE WORK TO BE DONE
THIS WEEK WE JUST CAN'T BE
SATISFIED WITH WHERE WE ARE WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S YOU KNOW MORE
DISASTERS THE COMMON I WILL TELL
YOU.
UP FOR THE PEOPLE IN MY
COMMUNITY WHO SPENT FORTY DAYS
WONDERING WHETHER THIS FIRE WAS
GOING TO TAKE OUT THE ENTIRE
CITY SANTA BARBARA WHICH WAS A
POSSIBILITY.
OF THE ANXIETY ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE I KNOW ARE STILL
EXPERIENCING TO THIS VERY DAY.
SO WE'VE GOT TO DO MORE WE'VE
GOT TO DO IT BETTER.
AND WE NEED TO TO BE
PARTICIPATING WITH US SO I'M
SURE WILL CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND AND HOPE THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
IMPORTANT TO YOU AS WELL.
SO WITH THAT I I THANK YOU ANY
OTHER I GUESS IT'S JUST ME
MYSELF AND ME -- SO THANK YOU
ALL VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE IN
THE AND THIS WILL CONTINUE AND I
THINK NOW WE'RE GONNA OPEN IT UP.
FOR YES YES WE'RE GONNA PEN IT
UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT IF WE
COULD HAVE SOME PEOPLE IF YOU
HAD IF THERE IS ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT.
IF YOU COULD -- PERHAPS TWO TO
THREE MINUTES SIR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I AM DAVE SHELF Là VICE
PRESIDENT SHALL RIGHT
CORPORATION DOWN IN SAN DIEGO WE
MAKE -- STATE OF THE ART MASSIVE
CATION SPEAKERS AND LOCATION
BASED -- ALERTING SOFTWARE -- I
WE WERE I'M REALLY PLEASED TO BE
HERE TODAY AND TO HEAR MULTIPLE
WITNESSES TALK ABOUT.
THE NEED FOR REDUNDANCY THE READ
THEY NEED FOR A MULTI LAYERED
APPROACH THAT THERE'S NOT ONE
SOLUTION TO ANY OF THESE
PROBLEMS -- I WOULD ALSO JUST
ADD ONE THING AT THE END HERE
AND THAT IS.
WITHOUT A COUPLE OF CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA STEP FORWARD AND
ADOPT OUR MULTILAYER SOLUTION
MILL VALLEY LAGUNA BEACH IN
PARTICULAR.
BOTH OF THOSE ARE COMMUNITIES
EARLY ADOPTERS OF THIS APPROACH --
THEY RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO
PROTECT THEIR SEVEN CERNER
CITIZENRY.
I ALSO HAVE RESOURCES A LOT OF
COMMUNITIES DON'T HAVE SO I
WOULD SAY IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
THINK ABOUT THE RESOURCE
REQUIREMENTS OF SOME OF THESE
THINGS THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
AND WHETHER THAT'S DIRECT
FUNDING FROM LEGISLATURE OR
WHETHER IT'S ESTABLISHMENT OF
FUNDED GRANT PROGRAMS IT'S IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT THAT THESE
IDEAS IN THIS APPROACH BE --
EQUALLY ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COULDN'T
AGREE WITH YOU MORE.
TURNING ONE ELSE WHO'D LIKE TO
STEP FORWARD.
PART SEEING NONE.
LOOKS LIKE WE ARE READY TO
ADJOURN I'VE BEEN GIVEN THE
GAVEL THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
FOR BEING HERE
[inaudible]
WE RICHARD